GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE'D LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH OUR
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON THIS IS
THE HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A A VERY LONG AGENDA
TODAY.
WE WILL BE HEARING. TWO
WITNESSES PER SIDE -- THREE
MINUTES EACH TOTAL -- AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
WITNESS WILL BE ASKED JUST TO
GET THEIR NAME AND POSITION ON A
BILL.
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT ARE RECOMMENDED FOR CONSENT --
THE BILLS ARE IF YOU'RE
FOLLOWING AND HAVE A SCORECARD --
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB FOR FORTY
THREE BY MR GLORIA.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWO THIRTY
TWO BYE BYE MISTER MONTH DAIS
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWO FIFTY
FOUR BY MISS QUIRK SILVA.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB FIVE FIFTEEN
BY MISTER MATHIS.
ITEM NUMBER -- FOURTEEN AB SIX
SEVENTEEN BY MR MULLIN.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B. SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN OR SEVEN FORTY ONE
SEES ME BY MISTER KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY I A. B. SEVEN
FORTY SIX BY WOOD.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BY MISS WICKS ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
NINETEEN BY MISS PETRIE-NORRIS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY TWO BY MISS IRWIN.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE AB
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR MISSED ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
MR GLORIA.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE AB
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO BY MR HOLDEN
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY TWO A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO BY MISS
WALDRON.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN OH FOUR BY MISTER
SANTIAGO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE
AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN BY MISTER
SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN AB
EIGHTEEN OH TWO IT'S AN ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE BILL.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN OH THREE ALSO IN
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE BILL.
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB THREE
SEVENTY BY MR VOEPEL.
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTEEN AB SIX OH
ONE BY MISTER BIGELOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO A. B.
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE BY MISS WICKS.
AND ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY FOUR BY MISTER
GLORIA.
WILL TAKE A COUPLE OF THINGS OUT
OF A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER TODAY
OTHERWISE THIS IS IN FILE ORDER.
THE FIRST BILL WILL BE HEARING
BY WILL BE BY MR BLOOM FOLLOWED
BY A BILL BY MISTER CALDERON SO.
MISTER BLOOM WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
WE'LL BE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY -- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM -- WILL HAVE
MEMBERS COMING AND GOING THIS IS
A BUSY BUSY DAY IN THE CAPITAL
SO -- NO FURTHER DO MISTER BLOOM
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MISTER CHAIR
AND AND MEMBERS OF A CHILD'S
ABILITY TO HEAR SHOULD NOT BE
DETERMINED BY THEIR FAMILY
INCOME YET HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEIR CHILD'S HEARING
AIDS OUT OF POCKET OR SIMPLY.
HAVE TO FOREGO THEM ALL TOGETHER
A. B. FIVE NINETY EIGHT
ADDRESSES THIS GAP IN COVERAGE
BY REQUIRING HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS AND HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES. TO INCLUDE COVERAGE
FOR CHILDREN'S HEARING AIDS.
BIRDS INCLUDE THE INITIAL
HEARING ASSESSMENT NEW HEARING
AIDS AT LEAST EVERY FIVE YEARS
NEW ERA MOLDS AND A NEW HEARING
AID IF THE EXISTING ONE IS NO
LONGER WORKING.
THE COST OF A HEARING IT IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
PARENTS OBTAINING PEDIATRIC
HEARING AIDS.
HEARING AIDS CAN COST UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A PAIR AND
GROWING CHILDREN NEED THESE
DEVICES.
REPLACED FREQUENTLY AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
BACKGROUND HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR THEIR HEARING AIDS.
AND HEARING AID SERVICES AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
CONTINUED SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
AND ALSO EXPRESSED MY COMMITMENT
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
ABOUT COST CONTAINMENT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE ANY GOOD FRIEND THE
MOTHER OF THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING CHILD AND DOCTOR
DANNIELLA CARVALLO.
DEPARTMENT OF SURGERY CHAIR AND
DIRECTOR OF THE HEARING PROGRAM
AT RADIS AT RADY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY.
HI MY NAME IS AMY GOOD FRIEND
NUSSBAUM THIS IS MY SON MAKE
NUSSBAUM THIRTEEN YEARS OLD.
IMAGINE FINDING OUT THAT YOUR
NEWBORN CHILD IS HARD OF HEARING.
CHILD NEEDS HEARING IN.
AND THEN FINDING OUT.
WILL PAY FOR ONE DOLLAR
[inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
BEING.
OKAY THE MICROPHONE THE GOOD
SISTER.
YES.
HELLO ONCE AGAIN.
MY NAME IS AMY GOOD FRIEND
NUSSBAUM.
THIS IS MY SON NICK.
IS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD.
IMAGINE FINDING OUT THAT YOUR
NEWBORN CHILD IS HARD OF HEARING.
NEWBORN CHILD IS GOING TO NEED
HEARING AIDS.
AND THEN IMAGINE FINDING OUT
THAT INSURANCE WON'T GIVE YOU
ONE DIME TOWARDS THE COST OF
THOSE HEARING AIDS.
FIRST PAIR OF HEARING AIDS WAS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WE HAVE TO GET A NEW PAIR
APPROXIMATELY EVERY THREE TO
FOUR YEARS.
ALONG WITH THE COST OF THE
HEARING AIDS WE ALSO HAVE TO PAY
FOR MOLDS [inaudible]
CHECKS.
WHEN SOMETHING BREAKS OR IF YOU
LOSE?
ONE WORKING CLASS CALIFORNIANS
MAKING MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
DO NOT GET ANY ASSISTANCE FOR
THEIR HEARING AIDS FOR THEIR
CHILD.
THAT BECAME OFFICIAL IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THAT HAS
TO CHANGE.
BECAUSE NICK WAS AMPLIFIED.
BY EIGHT WEEKS OF AGE.
HE HAD IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO CEASE
TO SPOKEN LANGUAGE AND NEVER
NEEDED ANY SPECIAL EDUCATION.
OR ANY SERVICES FROM THE STATE.
WITHOUT IS HEARING AIDS.
NIKKI WOULD HERE BELOW THE
SPEECH LEVEL [inaudible]
NO.
HELLO MY NAME IS NICK LAST BOMB.
I AM THIRTEEN YEARS OLD I PLAYED
DRUMS IN A BAND I LOVE THE LA
RAMS AND I GOT MY FIRST PAIR OF
HEARING AIDS WHEN I WAS
[inaudible]
TO MUSCLE.
I THINK IT IS CRAZY THAT HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WILL PAY FOR
WEIGHT LOSS SURGERY AND WIGS FOR
CANCER PATIENTS.
BUT WON'T PAY ANYTHING FOR
HEARING AIDS THIS NEEDS TO
CHANGE IT'S TIME TO LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE.
MY NAME IS THE NOW PROVIDE HOLE
AND I'M A PEDIATRIC
OTOLARYNGOLOGY IS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE HEARING IN COOL CLAIM
PLANNED PROGRAM THAT READ EACH
ONE AS HOSPITAL SAN DIEGO -- UC
SAN DIEGO PROFESSOR.
AND I'M ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CHAMPION FOR THE EARLY
HEARING DETECTION AND
INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
REGIONAL HOSPITAL SAN DIEGO UC
SAN DIEGO AND ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF LET CALIFORNIA HERE
INITIATIVE IN OVER THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT THE FIRST MONTHS
AND YEARS OF OUR LIVES ARE
CRUCIAL IN DEVELOPING THE
HEARING PATHWAYS IN OUR BRAINS.
AND HENCE OUR ORAL LANGUAGE.
THERE'S OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
THAT CHILDREN DEPRIVE THE NORMAL
ACCESS TO HEARING HAVE
SIGNIFICANT SPEECH AN ORAL
LANGUAGE THE LACE.
THE IMPACT THIS WILL IMPACT YOUR
ACADEMIC LIFE THEIR SOCIAL LIFE.
THEY WILL HAVE ISSUES WITH
EMOTIONAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROBLEMS AS WELL.
DEVON HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
WHO GO UNTREATED COSTS ARE
TAXPAYERS UP TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION A
LOSS OF PRODUCTIVITY.
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
HEARING AIDS IN THE EARLY MONTHS
OF LIFE.
THE EARLY HEARING DETECTION AND
INTERVENTION PROGRAMHAS
INSTITUTED THE ONE THREE SIX
GUIDELINES.
SCREENING BY ONE MONTH OF AGE
DIAGNOSING OF BY THREE MONTHS OF
AGE AN INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT BY SIX MONTHS OF AGE.
CALIFORNIA DOES A BEAUTIFUL JOB
IN SCREENING AND IDENTIFYING
YOUR CHILDREN WITH HEARING LOSS
BUT FEELS MISERABLY.
WHEN IT COMES TO TREATING THEM I
SEE THIS EVERY DAY WHEN I TAKE
CARE CHILDREN WHO ARE HARD OF
HEARING IT READ THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL?
I SEE THE DIFFERENCE IN A
HEARING AID MAKES ANALYZE AND
EARLY DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
CHILDREN.
HOWEVER BECAUSE ONLY ONE
INTELLIGENCE TEN CHILDREN HAVE
HEARING AIDS COVERED BUTTER PRO
WITH HEALTH PLAN IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SEE HOW DEVASTATING IT IS
FOR PARENTS WHO KNOW WHO ARE
UNABLE TO AFFORD THE TREATMENT
THEY KNOW THEIR CHILD NEEDS.
CURATE COVERAGE IS ALREADY
MANDATED IN TWENTY FOUR OTHER
STATES AND IT'S TIME TO LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AND PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
HI NEAR MORTON YOU'RE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
CESSATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE REPRESENTS JOB
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M MICHELLE MARCINIAK OF LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE -- IT'S
TIME TO LET CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER MARIE ASH
TRICK AND SHE WEARS HEARING AIDS
SHE'S EIGHT YEARS OLD.
MR TURN MEMBERS I'M ERIN EVANS
ON BEHALF OF THE CELL BUT
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M LARA COMPELLED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CHAT CENTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND WHERE IT'S FOR
THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LADY ASSESSMENT I'M
A RETIRED UP AND HARD OF HEARING
IN FIN TEACHER AND A PROFESSOR
AT CAL LOSING UNIVERSITY AND
IT'S TIME TO THAT CALIFORNIA
KIDS HERE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S CARE
SPECIALLY COALITION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TANYA AND THIS IS
MY DAUGHTER KIRA AND SHE IS HARD
OF HEARING.
AND WE SUPPORT AB FIVE NINE
EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI AM CLEAR HAZLETT OUR PARENT
TAXPAYER -- I GOT.
TO TELL HIS HARD OF HEARING AND
ONE WAS GOING TO BE HARD OF
HEARING AND WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THIS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO THERE MY NAME IS COVINA
MILLER.
AND I'M A TEACHER FOR THE DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING IN THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY.
AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE NINE
AIDS.
IT'S TIME TO LET CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IN KIMBALL ANYWAY
AND I'M WITHOUT MOM WITH.
HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN.
FROM SACRAMENTO.
AB FIVE NINE EIGHT IT'S TIME TO
LET THE CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DR CHRISTOPHER
CAM THIS IS EMILY CAME WHOSE
HARD OF HEARING.
WE ARE FROM DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IT'S TIME TO LET CALIFORNIA
KIDS HERE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NANCY SACRE -- I AM
HERE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA AND
FAMILIES FOR HANDS AND VOICES
THIS IS BY LITTLE HARD OF
HEARING FRIEND CASSIE AND WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT.
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS BROOKE PHILLIPS I'M A
PEDIATRIC CARDIOLOGIST FROM LOS
ANGELES AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY
AND WE SUPPORT.
CAT LIKE CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE.
MY NAME IS KATIE RIGHT THIS IS
MY GRANDSON CONNOR WE BOTH WEAR
HEARING AIDS I AM HERE
REPRESENTING HEARING LOSS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT BUT CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN A WONDERFULLY
THESE ARE MY THREE HARD OF
HEARING DAUGHTERS.
CAITLYN AGE ONE CASSIE AGE FIVE
IN CARE AT AGE TWO AND WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO WE HAVE OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR ROBIN HANSON I'M
FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND THIS IS
MY DAUGHTER WHO WON'T SAY HER
NAME SHE'S COR HANSON -- WE'RE
HERE JUST REPRESENTED OURSELVES
FROM CINEMA COUNTY THANK YOU.
HI AM JAMES THE CAFE AND I'M A
TEACHER AT THE DOCTOR LAST
ACTIVITY YOU FIVE CORTES STOCK.
AND A TIME TO THAT THE DOCTRINE
HIGH TELLING HOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA COLUMN ALSO HERE WITH
MY DAUGHTER WHO IS NINE YEARS
OLD SHE'S HARD OF HEARING
JENNIFER TO BIRTH AND SHE'S USE
BOTH -- AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
AND HER HEARING AIDS SINCE SHE
WAS A BABY AND WORST IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
SO ALL CHILDREN CAN ALSO ACCESS
THE WORLD AROUND THEM THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CAPRI SURE THIS IS
MY DAUGHTER. THREE EIGHT THREE
AVERY SHE'S FOUR YEARS OLD AND
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHERYL ASSN AND I'M A
TEACHER OF THE DEATH FOR A LOCAL
INTENT PROGRAM AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN RAISE THAT UP YEAH HELLO
MY NAME IS SHINING NINE GAP AND
I'M STUDIES YOU BECOME A TEACH
IN THE DEATH.
OF FAMILY GAP COSTA PLAQUE TO
CARRY YOU PATIENTS COMING UP I
CHARLIE TO POINT TO SPEAK OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NIKKI FINE.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER AMERI WHO
WILL BE TWO NEXT WEEK AND SHE
WEARS HEARING AIDS AND WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANKS.
FOR AND I SHADES.
OTHER -- ANYONE ELSE ANYONE ELSE
TO SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PLEASE COME ON UP.
ONLY TO MAKE ROOM FOR THEM AT
THE TABLE THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER ONLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS REPRESENTING
FORTY FIVE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT.
COLLECTIVELY DELIVER HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS -- CAP MUST OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IN
INCREASES CONSUMER PREMIUMS WELL
WE SYMPATHIZE WITH THIS ISSUE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW CURRENTLY
DEFINED HOW STATES COVER
BENEFITS.
UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
STATES REQUIRE DISLIKE A
BENCHMARK PLAN.
THAT DEFINES DEFINES HEALTH
RELATED SERVICES AND EQUIPMENT
REFER TO IS ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS.
THE BENCHMARK PLANTS THAT
OUTLINES THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS IN CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
INCLUDE THIS DEVICE.
THE ACA REQUIRES A STATE TO
COVER BENEFITS WOULD EXCEED THE
H. BEES AND ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW BOARD TO BURKE -- EIGHTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT EXCEEDS THE H.
BEASON TRIGGERS ADDITIONAL COSTS
FOR THE STATE BETWEEN TWO AND
THREE MILLION DOLLARS -- AND
ACCORDING TO TO BURKE THIS
MANDATE WILL INCREASE HEALTHCARE
PREMIUMS BY OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THIS IS JUST SIMPLY THE
WRONG TIME TO PASS NEW MANDATES --
SEVERAL BENEFIT MANDATES HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN RECENT YEARS AND HAVE
RETURNEDTHIS YEAR.
OUR MEMBERS REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF
BENEFIT MANDATES ON PREMIUMS.
PARTICULARLY AS WE FACE -- THE
IN HERE PRESSURES ON INVOLVING
MY INSURANCE MARKET.
THE TOTALITY OF MANDATES BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE EQUALS MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
THE COST OF THE MONTHLY PREMIUM
AS THE PRIMARY CONSIDERATION FOR
CONSUMERS WHEN SELECTING A PLAN.
THUS FAR CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A
BETTER JOB COMPARED TO MOST
STATES IN KEEPING COVERAGE
AFFORDABLE WELL AVERAGE PREMIUM
INCREASES BELOW OTHER STATES.
MAINTAINING A FOR A PREMIUMS AS
CRITICAL AS POLICY MAKERS STRIVE
TO DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNINSURED IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR NEW
BENEFIT MANDATES THAT DRIVE UP
THE COST OF CARE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE WHAT CAN SOME WE HAVE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
TO HEAR TODAY IN OPPOSITION I
THINK EVERYONE AT THIS TABLE
INCLUDING EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
IS SYMPATHETIC TO THIS ISSUE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS WAS NOT A
PART OF THE ORIGINAL BENCHMARK
PLAN THAT WAS CHOSEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IT WILL BE RE AUTHORIZED -- NEXT
YEAR AND WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THAT MAY BE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT.
THE INITIAL KAISER THIRTY PLUS
PLAN SHOULD BE THE BENCHMARK OR
WE SHOULD CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS THAT DO COVER OTHER
BENEFITS BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS
THIS.
BILL WOULD EXCEEDS THE H. PIECES
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL STATE COST
TO THE SYSTEM AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT IMPOSING AN
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
AT THE CALIFORNIA LEVEL AND ALSO
LOOKING AT INCREASING SUBSIDIES
TO HELP PEOPLE AFFORD THEIR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT ADDING
ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT WOULD
IMPACT THE GREATER CONSUMER
POPULATION SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BUT CERTAINLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
NEXT YEAR AS WE LOOK AT RE
AUTHORIZING THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
ANYONE ELSE.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WITH ECHO
CAPEN ACT LOOKS COMMENTS -- LOOK
FOR TO HAVE IN THE CONVERSATION --
DURING THE H. B. CONVERSATION
NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ANYONE ELSE CASEY KNOWN
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM CAN MISTER
BIGELOW.
THANK YOU THIS IS. FOR THE
AUTHOR -- HAVING HEARD THE
OPPOSITION'S COMPONENTS IS THERE
A WAY THAT YOU COULD.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
CONTINUE WORKING. TO RESOLVE
SOME OF THAT ISSUE AND ALSO
COULD YOU ADDRESS -- HURT HER
ISSUES ABOUT NEXT YEAR WHEN IT'S
GOING TO BE UP FOR RENEWAL --
FIRST OF COURSE OF COURSE I'M
ALWAYS WILLING TO DISCUSS ISSUES
WITH OPPOSITION AND THE DOORS
OPEN -- TO CONTINUING TO DO THAT --
IN SO FAR AS NEXT YEAR -- IF WE
CAN DO IT NEXT YEAR WHY CAN'T WE
DO IF THE ISSUE IS THE RATES ARE
GOING TO GO UP A LITTLE BIT AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PENNIES ON THE ON THE POLICY --
IF WE CAN IF WE CAN DO THAT NEXT
YEAR WHY NOT DO IT THIS YEAR.
HIDETHE SOONER WE DO THIS TO
SENIOR THE SOONER CALIFORNIA
KIDS ARE PROTECTED ON THIS ISSUE --
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
CHILDREN EVERY YEAR ARE NOT
GETTING HEARING AIDS BECAUSE OF
THIS ISSUE -- AND COUNTLESS
MOORE'S ARE PAYING OUT MORE ARE
PAYING OUT OF THEIR POCKETS IN
ADDITION THERE ARE PARENTS WHO
BECAUSE THEY CAN -- RECEIVE
HEARING AIDS UNDER MEDICARE AL
WHO ARE WORKING WHO ARE LEAVING
THEIR JOBS.
SO THAT THEIR CHILDREN CAN GET
MEDI CAL BENEFITS IN ORDER TO
COVER THIS -- SO IN MY VIEW
THERE IS AN IMPERATIVE THAT WE
DO THIS NOW AND NOT WAIT ANOTHER
YEAR HAD WE DONE THIS TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN I FIRST STARTED ON THIS
BILL ANOTHER THOUSAND CHILDREN
WOULD HAVE HAD HEARING AIDS IN A
TIMELY FASHION -- THIS IS TOO
IMPORTANT AN ISSUE FOR THESE
YOUNG CHILDREN INFANTS IN MANY
CASES WHO ARE DIAGNOSED AND DO
NOT GET HEARING AIDS THEIR
OUTCOMES ARE DELAYED -- THEIR
OUTCOMES AS THE AS THE THE
PROFESSOR MENTIONED -- ARE NOT
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE FOR CHILDREN
AND ALL FOR THE LACK OF A
HEARING AID.
THANK YOU -- THIS.
LAST QUESTION UP.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND
MOST LIKELY.
WE LOOK AT THE TIMING OF IT AND
IT BECOMING -- SIGNED AND THEN
ENACTED.
DOES THE TIMING ACTUALLY WORK
OUT.
ALMOST THE SAME AS IT HAPPENING
NEXT YEAR NO BECAUSE THAT
PROCESS WILL TAKE TIME THAT
PROCESS STARTS NEXT YEAR BUT IT
DOES DOESN'T NECESSARILY AND
NEXT YEAR.
SO IT WOULD BE NEXT PROTRACTED
PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE WE EVER
SEE ANY RESULTS I'M VERY SIMPLE.
THAT IT TO THE TO THE ISSUE HERE --
AND RECOGNIZE IT BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE'S A PART A
SECOND PART OF THIS. TO MAKE IT
HELP FULLY FUNCTIONAL AND THAT'S
THE PLANS SO WE NEED.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BALANCE IT
THAT ISSUES SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE AND WILLINGNESS TO WORK
ON THIS AS IT CONTINUES MOVING
THANK YOU.
THE SECULAR KERR -- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
THINK THERE'S A COME AND MADE IT
HAS MEANT -- SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE FUNDING HAS NOT
GONE UPSET.
TOO DID I HEAR THAT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT.
A IN INCOME OF FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS PER
YEAR IT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO HAVE
THE STATE PAY FOR HEARING AIDS.
ANY ASSISTANCE FOR HER.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU I
WANT TO THANK YOUR SON FOR A
PARTICIPATING TODAY BECAUSE THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT -- BUT NERVOUS
AND SCARY BUT YOU DID A GREAT
JOB AND I WANT TO THANK FIRST OF
ALL THE FAMILIES THAT SHOWED UP
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY FAMILIES
CAME IN MY OFFICE.
AND SHARE WITH ME THEIR FAMILY
EXPERIENCES WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US -- THIS IS A
GOOD FEELING BILL TO ME.
AND IT YOU SHOULDN'T WAIT THE
THING I DON'T LIKE IS HOW LONG
DO WE ASK FAMILIES TO WAIT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM I
APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO MOVE
THIS ALONG FOR AND I'LL BE IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL TODAY WHEN
WE GET TO THAT POINT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
ONCE AGAIN BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PERSISTENCE I SAID I SAID
THIS A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND I
MEAN IT I ACTUALLY ACT REALLY
MEAN IT -- I THINK WHEN -- THE I
THINK THE TOTAL POTENTIAL IMPACT
OF THIS I THINK WE HEARD WAS
ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
SIX WE ALSO HEARD THAT THE
POTENTIAL PRODUCTIVITY LOSS FOR
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T HAVE HEARING
AIDS MIGHT BE AS MUCH AS A
MILLION DOLLARS A PERSON.
WE GOT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED KIDS
WHO NEED HEARING AIDS THAT'S A
POTENTIAL ECONOMIC LOSS OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS VERSUS A
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
EXPENDITURE.
I'M SORRY THAT FEELS LIKE A NO
BRAINER TO ME -- AND I THINK AND
I'M AS I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TO HEAR TODAY -- WHILE I I
RECOGNIZE IT IS NOT PART OF THE
MANDATE OF FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HEARING LOSS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE VISION LOSS FOR A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT IS AN ESSENTIAL BENEFIT AND
SO I I LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
IN THE FUTURE HELPING TO RECTIFY
THAT SO THAT THIS IS PART OF A
PART OF THE GREATER COVERAGE --
FOR KIDS GOING FORWARD SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM -- BUT IN THIS YEAR CREE
WANTS TO SAY SOMETHING MORE I
FORGOT I WOULD ALSO LIKE A ****
IF I CAN BE A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL OF COURSE THANK YOU.
LIKE ONCE OR TWICE OKAY -- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO I'M
FORCING WE CAN'T TAKE IT UP FOR
BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER BLOOM.
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM -- AT THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT TODAY IT'S
TIME TO LET CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
BRING THAT AS SOON AS WE HAVE --
WE HAVE A VOTE WILL BRING IT UP
FOR A OR HAVE QUORUM WILL BRING
IT UP FOR A VOTE.
OUR NEXT -- NEXT YEAR WILL BE
MISTER [inaudible]
CALDERON
.
I'M SORRY THIS MAY BE THE FIRST
TIME ANYBODY'S EVER HAD WALK AT
MUSIC MISTER CALDERON.
IT'S NOT THE ONLY FIRST I'VE --
SAID IN THIS BUILDING.
IN ORDER THE BILL YOU'RE
PRESENTING TODAY OF COURSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WILL CREATE
SPECIFIC REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
IN OVERSIGHT FOR THE OPERATION
OF WAVE.
BASINS WE NOW HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO CREATE THE PERFECT
WAVE RIGHT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHILE ALSO BOOSTING ECONOMIC
ADVANTAGES.
AND TOURISM FOR THIS AREA THERE
IS ONLY ONE SURFING RANCH OF ITS
KIND IN CALIFORNIA WHILE OTHERS
ARE BEING CONTEMPLATED AND WANT
TO AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE REGULATED APPROPRIATELY.
BY DEVELOPING NEW APPROPRIATE
SANDERS AND OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS SPECIFICALLY MEANT
FOR THE FOR WAY BASINS WE CAN
ADDRESS THE AND THE VOID IN
CURRENT REGULATIONS SURROUNDING
THIS EMERGING INDUSTRY.
CURRENT SWIMMING POOL
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION
REGULATION IS NOT DIRECTLY
APPLICABLE APPLICABLE TO WAY
BASS IS DUE TO THE DIFFERENT
CHARACTERISTICS OF CONSTRUCTIVE
WAY BASIN.
DESIGN AND THE VARYING
DIFFERENCES AND OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES AND STANDARDS.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY ONE INTENDS TO
CREATE AN NEW REGULATIONS FOR
THIS INDUSTRY AS IT DIFFERS FROM
TRADITIONAL SWIMMING POOL
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS MADE
WHALEY CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
FOR THE KELLY SLATER WAVE PARK
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI NAY WAILING WITH KELLY SLATER
WAVE COMPANYI THINK THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON.
AS HE SAID WE'VE GOT SOMETHING --
RICK REALLY COOL -- WOULD BE IF
WE REALLY DO -- BUT IT'S AT SUCH
A SCALE AT TEN ACRES OVER TEN
ACRES OF WATER IT'S OVER HALF MY
ALMOST A HALF MILE LONG.
IT JUST DOESN'T FIT WITHIN THE
CURRENT CONSTRUCT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING AT TOWARDS
BRINGING SOME.
INTENSE REGULATION TO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
SINCE SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE MANY.
SEEING NONE -- WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS CONGRESS I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF -- FOR THE HELP ON THIS
BILL WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT SOME OF THIS MORE
SPECIFIC DETAILS WELL ABSOLUTELY
KEEP YOU ENGAGE AS WELL AS YOUR
STAFF BUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL IN AS A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- YOU SO
YOU LOOKS YOU'LL ACCEPT OUR
AMENDMENTS I TAKE IT FROM THERE
YEAH OKAY SUPER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE SOON AS THE BILL
COMES.
AS IS WE HAVE A QUORUM A WILL TO
TO BEGIN TO TAKE VOTES IT
DOESN'T CHOI TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MEMBERS OKAY
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WE WITNESS.
TO SO MISTER CHIU
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A TO A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB.
EIGHT A BILL AIMED TO PLACE ONE
OR MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ALL ALL K. TO
TWELVE SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AND ESTABLISH A RACIAL OF ONE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
EVERY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR SMALLER SCHOOLS
A SIMILAR BILL PASSED HIS COMEY
LAST YEAR. TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR A. B. EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND I IT BECAUSE TO NONE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
PROVIDE DIRECT FUNDING TO BRING
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS.
IN CALIFORNIA THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN SPURTING EIGHT
FOUR AND ELEVEN HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
AND RESEARCH TOLD US EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
SERVICES ARE CRUCIAL.
IN CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FACE.
AREAS TO ASSESS A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTATION CALLS INSURANCE
COVERAGE LANGRIDGE AS STIGMA.
THIS OFTEN MEANS CHILDREN NEVER
REACHED SERVICES AT ALL WHICH
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT
STUDENTS WILL BRING AND DO OF
FUTURES.
SCHOOL.
HAVE A BEING IDENTIFY ESTA BASS
SACKING TO PROVIDE SERVICE.
SERVICES ESPECIALLY FOR OTHER
REACHING CHILDREN OF COLORS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER CALL THE FINER RANKS
CLOSE TO LOSE LAST IN EVERY
SCHOOL SUPPORT STAFF CATEGORY.
I AM VERY FEELS COOPER BY A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON
CAMPUS.
AND WHEN THEY DO THIS DIFFICULT
FOR STUDENT TO HALF TIME BE ****.
AB A WILL PROVIDE A BASELINE
REQUIREMENTS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT IN SCHOOL. FOR
CHILDREN'S AND YOUNG AND USED TO
ACROSS THE STATE.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
I'M COMMITTED TO WORK WAS.
ENGAGED IN THIS AS CHAIR AS THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
UNDER CONCERNS IN ORDER TO BRING
THOSE INVALUABLE SERVICES TO OUR
CHILDREN.
WAS TO ME HERE TODAY I OF ZEMA
CHRISTIAN.
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF MENTAL
HEALTH AMERICAN OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SORROW MICHAEL GUSMAN FROM
THE USE FORWARD TO TESTIFY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SO.
FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN I'M ZIVA
CREASING PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA MHC IS A SIXTY YEAR
OLD GRASSROOTS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON POLICY ADVOCACY OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THE IDEA THAT LED TO AB EIGHT
CAME FROM CHI YET THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK WHICH
IS A PROGRAM OF MHC.
CLIENTS PRIORITIES AND DIRECTION
IS A 100% DETERMINED BY THE
YOUTH LEADERS AGES RANGE I
RANGING FROM.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SIX CLIENTS
USE LEADERS IDENTIFIED HAVING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
AT SCHOOL AS A KEY TO THEIR ON
GOING MENTAL WELLNESS.
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SUPPORT
WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE SPEND THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR TIME WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION WHICH IS
PROVEN TO FOSTER POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
IN MY ROLE AS A GOVERNING BOARD
MEMBER OF THAT SAN JUAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HRE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I RECENTLY
HEARD AN UPDATE ON IN TSS MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
AND IT'S ROOTED IN THE
IDENTIFICATION MODEL IN A 100%
THERE'S A ROLE FOR
IDENTIFICATION.
BY IN THERE'S MANY INITIATIVES
FOCUSED ON IDENTIFICATION BUT
WHAT ABOUT HELP SEEKING YOUTH
ARE LOOKING FOR A PLACE TO GO
WHEN THEY NEED HELP AND WHERE TO
GO WITH THEIR FRIENDS NEED HELP.
AND THEY CAN'T WAIT TO BE
IDENTIFIED.
WE WANT BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
ADULTS WE MUST BE MUST DO BETTER
WITH OUR KIDS CALIFORNIA HAS ONE
OF THE LARGEST ECONOMIES IN THE
WORLD YET WE'RE TOWARDS THE
BOTTOM.
OF THE LIST IN PRAYER PEOPLE
SPENDING AND TOWARDS THE TOP OF
THE LIST IN PEER PRISONER
SPENDING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU TO HONOR THE USE REQUEST. TO
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT IN
CHOOL WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIMPLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE OF FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
MY NAME IS SERRA MICHAEL GAST IN
AND I'M A POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
YOU FORWARD.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT -- AB
EIGHT YOU FOR IT IS A POLICY
ADVOCACY NONPROFIT BASED IN
SACRAMENTO THAT FOCUSES ON
SUPPORTING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
WE ARE WORKING WITH YOUTH
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
IN EFFORTS TO INCREASE RESOURCES
FOR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
EVERYWHERE WE GO WE HEAR THAT
THE NEED FOR INCREASED -- MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS ARE NECESSARY.
FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR AND SOLANO
COUNTY YOUTH LEADERS CONDUCTED A
SURVEY OF OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
YOUTH AND NEEDS YOU.
PEOPLE YOUNG PEOPLE IDENTIFIED
MENTAL HEALTH AS ONE OF THEIR
TOP THREE CONCERNS.
THIS ORGANIZATION SOLANO YOUTH
VOICES IS NOW ORGANIZING TO
BRING MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
ULTIMATELY WE BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING AT LEAST ONE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON ALL
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
CAMPUSES WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
OVERALL WELLNESS AND SUCCESS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN SCHOOL. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN FOR ELEVEN
YEARS OF AGE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS BUT OVER 70% OF THEM NEVER
RECEIVED TREATMENT.
THAT'S THE CYSTIC IS
UNACCEPTABLE WE ARE LOSING OUR
KIDS TO MENTAL ILLNESS THEY'RE
SUFFERING FROM TRAUMA.
DEPRESSION ANXIETY SUICIDE AND
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO STEP IN
AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE MORE POLICE
OFFICERS IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
THAN THERE ARE COUNSELORS.
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS IN THE
STATE ATTEND A SCHOOL THAT HAS A
POLICE OR RESOURCE OFFICER BUT
NO COUNSELOR.
ACCORDING TO THE NATION IN THE
NATION RIGHT REPORT BY THE ACLU.
THAT'S ALARMING THE PRESENCE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD NEVER
OUTWEIGH MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS THIS ONLY
SERVES TO INCREASE STUDENT.
ANXIETY AND HIDING DISCIPLINE
DISPARITIES AMONG STUDENTS AND
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES.
WHICH FURTHER TRAUMATIZE A
STUDENTS BUT ALSO DETERIORATES A
HEALTHY SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S TIME TO FLIP THIS NARRATIVE
OUR SCHOOLS ARE THE BEST PLACES
TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT.
SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
WE NEED TO ENSURE THERE ARE MORE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
SOAP SUPPORTS ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES
THAT PROVIDE TIMELY.
AND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO SERVICES.
AB EIGHT IS A FIRST STEP TOWARDS
THIS MISSION I BELIEVE THAT IF
WE DO NOT TAKE ACTION NOW OUR
YOUTH WILL CONTINUE TO SUFFER IN
SILENCE.
AND DEVELOP SEVERE OR
DEBILITATING MENTAL ILLNESS WE
ASK FOR YOUR A VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER SINCE
SUPPORT.
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE THANK YOU.
DONNA ARE TO CONVINCE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER RUN WITH THE
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT
AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT IF YOU.
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENDON MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
DR PAUL BEKENSTEIN PEDIATRICIAN
LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT.
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DR NO FOUR ACHERAL PEDIATRICIAN
LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT.
DR LISA GANZ PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATINUM VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROCK SINGLE WITH THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
MUCH [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TONY TO ERR ON THE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE COULDN'T AGREE
MORE WITH THE BOTH PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OUR ISSUE IS THE
DEFINITION OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
WE SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF
CREDENTIALED SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
NURSES SOCIAL WORKERS -- AND WE
HAVE AN ISSUE FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
HAVE A SCHOOL WITH THE HOT LARGE
POPULATION OF SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS.
THEIR I EP REQUIRES THERE TO BE
A SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST SO IN SOME
SITUATION SHE WOULD HAVE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST MEETING THAT.
RATIO BUT NOT PROVIDING ANY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN
TRYING.
TO FIND THE PERFECT LINE DOWN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS CONVERSATION
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NOTEBOOK.
THANK YOU.
IT'S OR ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE -- I JUST
LIKE TO SAY -- ONCE OR DID YOU.
WANT.
TO LOOK AHEAD IF YOU'RE.
SERGEANTS I DIDN'T SEE HIM FOR
HIS CAREER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING.
THIS BILL -- TO THIS COMMITTEE I
AM PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL I KNOW THAT -- THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
RESOLVE WHEN IT COMES TO MENTAL
HEALTH -- ESPECIALLY IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THERE NOT
BEING ENOUGH FUNDING THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH RESOURCES SCHOOLS
ARE OVERCROWDED WE HAVE RUN DOWN
FACILITIES ALL OF THIS IS ALL
TRUE.
BUT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
WE HELP CHILDREN.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS MOMENT IN
TIME I I WANT TO SHARE THAT I
CONVENE THE MEETING WITH HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN MY DISTRICT
ALL OF WHOM THEIR BIGGEST FEAR.
IS THAT SOMEONE IS GONNA COME
INTO THEIR SCHOOL AND SHOOT THEM
MY THIS IS THE REALITY.
IT IS A NEW REALITY.
THAT IS IS FOR A LOT OF US VERY
HARD TO GRAPPLE WITH WHEN IT
COMES TO GUN VIOLENCE AND
SOMETHING GOING WRONG AND AND
CHILDREN NOT GETTING THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
THAT THEY DESERVE OR MENTAL
HEALTH ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
DESERVE AND SO I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL AND I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
YOUR OFFICE CONTINUES TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO COME UP
WITH AN AGREEMENT.
AS TO WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS
RESPONSIBLE.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE WELL BEING
AND THE HEALTH CARE OF OF OUR
STUDENTS?
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE OF HANG ON COULD YOU
MISTER FLOOR COULD YOU WAIT ONE
SECOND.
WE CALL ROLE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM IT'S A FLEETING
THING SO I'M HAVE SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WOOD.
HERE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA BURKE.
CARILLO.
FLORA HERE THE MOST.
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA FROM US RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD THING SO
ANY ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MR
CHECKING WHERE MUCH -- THE
SHERIN MENTIONED THAT THROUGH
THIS MORE THAN 70% OFF THEIR
CHILDREN DIED NEEDS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. TO DON'T THE
DOOM TO NOT READ RECEIVE.
ONE BUT IN MY STUDY SHOWS THAT
IN THE MORE DISADVANTAGED AREA
THAT NUMBER CAN SHIP SHOT UP TO
OVER 80% OR EIGHTY PLUS PERCENT.
SO THE I THINK YOU THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
AND TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS --
THE SERVICES TO OUR CHILDREN FOR
NEXT GENERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
WELL I THINK HE WAS THE CHIEF
ENTITIES IN THE BILL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW CRITICAL
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT.
I SUPPORT A SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR THAT CALLED FOR OF OF
ESSENTIALLY RATIO ONE HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER FOR EVERY
SIX HUNDRED AND HEARD HUNDREDS
PUPILS.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A RATIO OF
ONE FOR FOUR HUNDRED I GUESS THE
DIFFERENCES IN THE TWO BILLS NO
SHOW WE REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE RATIO IS IN MY
MIND -- AND TO BE THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS IN
OUR STE FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND
AND LOOK AT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN SCHOOLS.
AND HONEY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT ISN'T WORKING AND
AND THEN FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY
FOR IT WHICH IS ALSO CRITICAL --
AND RATHER THAN ESTABLISHING A
RATIO STATE LAW BUT I I I WANT
TO I WANT THE BILL TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD.
I ALSO WILL SAY THAT I HAVE I
HAVE CONCERNS AROUND WORKFORCE --
WE HAVE A BIG CHALLENGE NOW.
WITH PSYCHOLOGIST -- MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN
WORK WITH CHILDREN.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKING FOR
MORE AND MORE TO BE IN SCHOOLS
WE HAVE A CRITICAL WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE ISSUE ON THIS AND AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS GOING
FORWARD SO -- WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM -- AND SO IF THERE IS A
MOTION TO BE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND MOTION BY MS BURKE -- THE
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AMOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES.
OCCUR OCCUR CURRY.
THANK AGREE NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BURKE HI BURKE I CARRILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON [inaudible] SIX
YOU HAVE SIX VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR I BELIEVE THE
BY LONG CALL EXCUSE ME BROTHERS
TO OTHERS WOULD AT A LATER POINT
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MISTER KALRA [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO IS YOUR CAR WE HAVE A COUPLE
BILLS AND YOU'LL BE ENTERED
DOING ONE FOR MR GARCIA AS WELL.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AB FIFTY AB FIFTY YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EXPANDS THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM
TO MORE ELIGIBLE MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES.
WHO CAN BETTER IS OF BEASTS AND
BE BETTER SERVING THE COMMUNITY
BASED SETTING AT A COST SAVINGS
TO THE STATE OF THE BILL?
I WANT TO FIRST ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF STAFF TO
RECONCILE THE 60% TRANSITION
WILL FROM THE INSTITUTIONAL
SETTING REQUIREMENTS.
WITH THE AMOUNT OF DAYS RESIDENT
MUST BE REQUIRED TO STAY BEFORE
BEING ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM.
OVER FOUR YEAR PERIOD AB FIFTY
INCREASES THE WAIVER SLOTS FROM
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
442-180-00500. TO KEEP PACE WITH
OUR GROWING AGING POPULATION AND
DEAL WITH THE OVER FOUR THOUSAND
AND ROLL THE WAITING LIST.
CURRENTLY.
THIS IS LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM IS
GROSSLY UNDER UTILIZED AS ONLY
FIFTEEN COUNTIES A CONVERTED TO
PAY.
AB FIFTY MAKES THE PROGRAM
STATEWIDE.
AB FIFTY ALSO SETS OUT NEEDED
ARE FAIR PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT
AND REQUIRES ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDERS BUT APARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THIS IS LEGAL DURING WAIVER
PROGRAM PROVIDES A QUICK
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES TO
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
ELIGIBLE OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ON MEDI CAL.
EXPANDING THE LW PROGRAM IS ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO THE ONLY STATE
DECISION.
FIND AT THE UNNECESSARY INSTANT
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AS A
VIOLATIONS AMERICAN DISABILITIES
ACT THEREBY ESTABLISHING THE
RIGHT OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES RECEIVE SERVICES.
IN THE MOST INTEGRATED SETTING.
EVEN THOUGH THE DEPARTMENT RENEW
THE WAIVER PROGRAM FOR ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS THERE HAS BEEN
DISCUSSION TO INTEGRATE THE
PROGRAM WITH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES WAIVER.
AND AB FIFTY INCLUDES LANGUAGE
TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT TRANSITION
AND ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT A RAMP
UP SERVICES.
PRIOR TO THAT ARE OCCURRING.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS GEORGE CANARIAN
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF SIX
BEDS AND LISA COLEMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU TO CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS GEORGE COULD NEAR AND
I'M HERE A SIX BED WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS BOARDING CARE HOMES A
SORT OF ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS.
LIKE TO START OUT BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
CONTINUING TO CHAMPION FOR
IMPROVEMENT TO THE LW PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IS JUST SCRATCHING
THE SURFACE OF ITS POTENTIAL AS
A CAN HELP SIMULTANEOUSLY
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF AN
AGING POPULATION HOMELESSNESS
AND SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
YOU KNOW I HEAR TERMS SUCH AS
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
A CONTINUUM OF CARE BUT GIVEN
THAT SAN FRANCISCO HAS LOST 34%
OF ITS IS ALL RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES AND 26%.
WAS RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE ELDERLY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IT BEGS THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER WE TRULY
HAVE A CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
FROM A MEDI CAL FUNDING
PERSPECTIVE THERE IS NO TRUE
CONTINUE ON WHAT WE HAVE INSTEAD
IS A PATCHWORK OF SERVICES.
ON ONE HAND WE HAVE A PROGRAM
LIKE AYE HSS THE PROVIDE
SERVICES AT HOME AND MIND YOU
FOR CHRONICALLY HOMELESS THAT'S
A VERY DIFFICULT SERVICE TO
ACCESS.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING SUCH AND
SUCH A SNIFFS AND IN BETWEEN
THESE TWO WE HAVE A GAPING HOLE
THAT THE ALE W. WAS TRYING TO
FILL WITH A MEAGER 500-070-0404
SLOTS. TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE THAT JUST REPRESENTS
2% OF THE TOTAL CAPACITY OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE BEDS FOR OLDER
ADULTS AND SKILLED NURSING BEDS
HENCE THE GAPING HOLE IN OUR
SYSTEM. FOR PERSONS LIVING IN A
BOARDING CARE ON SS I SS BE
FUNDING IS LIMITED TO THE NON
MEDICAL OUT OF HOME CARE RATE
WHICH IS ONE THOUSAND FIFTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER MONTH OR
ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS PER
DAY.
YOU CAN'T AFFORD A ROACH
INFESTED MOTEL FOR THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER DAY THE BOARDING
TEARS ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
HOUSING UTILITIES.
FOOD STAFF TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
WITH ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING
AS WELL AS MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
OF A BOARDING CARE HAS SIX
RESIDENTS ALL ON SS I SS P. AND
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH THE MINIMUM
WAGE OF THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE IT WOULD BE MATHEMATICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO FULLY PAY STAFF
MINIMUM WAGE.
MUCH LESS PAY FOR PAYROLL TAXES
WORKERS COMP INSURANCE LIABILITY
INSURANCE PROPERTY TAXES AND
MORE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A SURPRISE AND
TO SEE THE RATE AT WHICH SAN
FRANCISCO LOSING BOARDING CARES
OR THE LA COUNTY HAS LOST OVER
ONE THOUSAND A. R. F. BEDS OVER
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
SO WHY SHOULD WE CARE ABOUT
THESE HOMES CLOSING WHILE THESE
LOSSES COME DISPLACEMENT OF MANY
LOW INCOME ADULTS THERE ARE
SUFFERING FROM SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS PUTTING THEM AT RISK OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OR WORSE
YET HOMELESSNESS.
OF A CONTINUUM OF CARE IS TRULY
TO WORK IT SHOULD HELP PROVIDE
THE RIGHT HOUSING AND THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
WE CAN'T DISENTANGLE HOUSING
FROM HEALTH AS HOUSING OR A LACK
LACK THERE OF HAS A DIRECT
IMPACT ON HEALTH.
THE REASON WHY THESE HOMES ARE
SO IMPORTANT AND WORTH SAVING IS
BECAUSE THEY SAID AT THE VERY
INTERSECTION OF HOUSING AND CARE.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW HOWEVER IS
THAT THESE HOMES CAN'T BE
ACCESSED EFFECTIVELY FOR THAT
ONE THOUSAND FIFTY EIGHT A MONTH?
AB FIFTY CAN HELP BY INCREASING
THE LWS CAPACITY TO EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SLOTS
PROVIDE FOR GEOGRAPHIC EXPANSION
AND INCREASING PROVIDER RATE
THAT CAN AUGMENT THE SS I SS P.
RATE.
THEREBY RESULTING IN A MORE
ROBUST PROGRAM THAT WILL BE
BETTER POSITIONED TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S CHALLENGES OF AN
AGING POPULATION HOMELESSNESS
AND MENTAL ILLNESS BY HELPING
TRANSFORM MEDICALS PATCHWORK OF
SERVICES AND TOOK IN TRUE
CONTINUE OF CARE THAT DELIVERS
THE RIGHT HOUSING.
AND THE RIGHT CARE AT THE RIGHT
TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
BOB IT IS WITH INCREASING
FRUSTRATION AND FRANTIC PHONE
CALLS THAT WE'RE RECEIVING FROM
OLDER ADULTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TRYING TO FIND A PLACE FOR THEIR
LOVED.
ONE IT IS A CRUEL FATE TO FIND
YOURSELF NOT ILL ENOUGH FOR
SKILLED NURSING.
BUT NOT RESOURCE ENOUGH TO
AFFORD THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH AS AN AVERAGE
ASSISTED LIVING COST.
OR THAT YOUR ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING REQUIRE MORE THAN OUR
CURRENT I IT JUST SAYS SYSTEM
CAN ALLOW.
AB FIFTY ADDRESSES THIS IN A
COMMON SENSE IT IN A IN A GOOD
LEGISLATION APPROACH.
IT'S A WIN TO THE STATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LAST YEAR
SAID THAT THISPROGRAM SAVE THE
STATE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S A WIN TO OLDER ADULTS AND
DISABLED ADULTS ALLOWING THEM
THE DIGNITY TO LIVE IN AN
ASSISTED LIVING ENVIRONMENT
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO SHARE A
ROOM.
IN AN INSTITUTIONAL SETTING OF A
SKILLED NURSING UNNECESSARILY.
OUR PHONE CALLS ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE TO GET OUT OF A
SKILLED NURSING INTO A LOWER
LEVEL OF CARE OMBUDSMAN'S DO
AMAZING THINGS BUT WE CANNOT
FABRICATE LOW INCOME HOUSING.
BUT THE LEGISLATION CAN WITH THE
EXPANSION OF THIS BILL WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
CLEANING COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
JOE RODRIGUEZ THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CHARLES SOULE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING I
JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
WILL BUILT THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
CREATE A LOT OF HOUSING OPTIONS
FOR PEOPLE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES.
WHERE SKILLED NURSING CANNOT
FUNCTION BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE THE POPULATION BASE THERE'S
NOTHING IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES?
CLOSE TO HOME AND YOUR FAMILY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST JUST YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE MICHELLE
GIVEN TO THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS PART THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN DIVORCE ON
BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT ALSO
I WAS ASKED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORT
TO LEND THEIR SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ENTER LANGLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SELECT US HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
GEN HAMPTON ON BEHALF OF LEADING
EDGE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS SHOULD
NOT FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS A
SENIOR FOR WILL HOUSING CARE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MOLLY BY ENEMY W. ASKED ME
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF INTER COUNTY HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AIR LEVI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S THIS LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ABOUT THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MY SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU AND AND I REALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I KNOW
YOU'VE -- YUNIOR STAFF
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND AND PAST
YEARS AS WE BRING THIS BILL FOR
EVEN VERY SUPPORT OF NON
PRESSURE THAT AND I DO WANT TO
REITERATE THE COMMENT MADE THAT
THIS WILL EXPAND IT ALL COUNTIES.
SO IN PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT RIGHT NOW I
DON'T REALLY HAVE ACCESS THIS IS
AN FOR THE FIRST TIME PROVIDE
SOME KIND OF ACCESS TO CARE. FOR
SOME OF OUR MORE MOST DESPERATE
TO SENIORS PEOPLE DISABILITIES
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I PO.
AND IF YOU ACCEPT -- AMENDMENTS
YES OKAY SPAHN CLARIFY THAT TO
THINK VERY MUCH SO -- THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIARCURRY I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMON.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RAMOS RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
THAT IS SEVEN WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL.
YOUR NEXT BILL MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- NEXT
UP.
AB.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN AB.
AND ME A SECOND HERE.
AB.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN AB CODIFIES
POSITION OF CALIFORNIA SURGEON
GENERAL AND PLACES THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF THE SURGEON GENERAL.
THE COMPANY'S SURGEON GENERAL
POSITION CREATED THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON JANUARY
SEVENTH OF THIS YEAR BY GOVERNOR
MUSEUM.
PRESENTS AN ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH EQUITY IS
CENTRAL TO CALIFORNIA. TO ALIGN
EFFORTS TO ELIMINATE DISPARITIES
INEQUITIES AND TO ADDRESS TRAUMA
AND THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
THE SURGEON GENERAL IS CHARGED
ADVISING THE GOVERNOR ON A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HEALTH RISKS AND
CHALLENGES BY LEVERAGING THE
INSIGHTS OF STAKEHOLDERS.
AND SERVING AS A SPOKESPERSON ON
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES.
THIS BILL ENSURES THE POSITION
OF SURGEON GENERAL EXIST LONG
OPERA CURRENT SITTING GOVERNORS
OUT OF OFFICE.
THAT HIS LEGACY CONTINUES ON AND
THE NEED A POSITION OF SURGEON
GENERAL IS CODIFIED IN STATUTE.
FURTHERMORE IN ORDER TO BUILD A
LINE IT WITH ON GOING EFFORTS
UNDER ALREADY UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN A
COST EFFECTIVE MANNER AB EIGHTY
SEVEN PROPOSES TO PLACE THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY UNDER
THE DIRECTION THE SURGEON
GENERAL.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE UP BY WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH STATUS OF ALL POPULATIONS%
IN PLACES WITH THE PRIORITY IN
ELIMINATING HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AND INEQUITIES.
I PROVIDING THE SURGEON GENERAL
DIRECTION OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY NOT ONLY ARE WE
ALIGNING NEW EFFORTS THE SURGEON
GENERAL WITH EXISTING APRS UNDER
DPH.
BASED ON THEIR MISSION ALIGNMENT
WILL BE MAKING A COST EFFECTIVE
DECISION TO USE EXISTING STAFF
AND RESOURCES RATHER THAN
BUILDING OUT NEW POSITIONS MORE
STATE DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE STATES IN THE NATION BUT
THE MAJORITY OF ITS POPULATION
OVER 60%.
COMPRISES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
ADVANCING HEALTHEQUITY IT WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TOWARDS
LIVING UP TO OUR PROMISE OF
HEALTH FOR ALL.
BY KIND OF KIND OF BUYING NEW
INNOVATIVE IDEAS SUCH AS THE
POSITION OF SURGEON GENERAL AND
OFFICIALLY USING ALREADY
EXISTING RESOURCES WE CAN REACH
OUR GOAL OF HEALTH EQUITY
EFFECTIVELY.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LINDA TO TO NARROW ITS POLICY
ADVOCATE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK.
THANK YOU CHAIR IN MEMBERS LINDA
TEAR WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE.
WE ARE A STATEWIDE HEALTH
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
TO PROMOTING HEALTH EQUITY FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS.
AS AN ORGANIZATION WHO HAS LONG
CHAMPIONED THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALLEVIATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES THROUGH INVESTMENT
IN PREVENTION EFFORTS.
THIS INCLUDES RESPONDING TO THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
SUCH AS HOW RACE CLASS AND
GENDER BIAS AND PHYSICAL SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENTS AFFECT THE HEALTH
OF INDIVIDUALS.
AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN ANCHORS THE
IMPORTANT ROLE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL INTO STATE LAW SO THAT
ISSUES OF HEALTH EQUITY AND
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF POLICYMAKING.
GIVEN EXISTING STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY THE CITY IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO ALIGN THE OFFICES
MISSION UNDER THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S PURVIEW.
ALIGNING BOTH THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH EQUITY AND THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL WILL LEAD TO
MORE COHESIVE STRATEGY MAKING
AND INVITE GREATER CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATION TO REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES.
IN FACT OTHER STATES SUCH AS
ARKANSAS IN FLORIDA HAVE ALREADY
BEEN STATED THEIR OWN SURGEONS
GENERAL TO MEET THESE NEEDS.
ARKANSAS FOR EXAMPLE HAS
CODIFIED THE POSITION OF THE
STATE'S SURGEON GENERAL WHO
ADVISES THE GOVERNOR BY ENGAGING
A VARIETY OF DIVERSE STATE
AGENCIES ON HEALTH REFORM.
SIMILARLY AB EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
WILL BUILD UPON THE WORK OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY BY
ELIMINATING THE SILOS BETWEEN
STATE ENTITIES IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN
THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NO WORK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES TO EQUITY THE
QUESTIONS AROUND A COULD YOU
REQUIRE.
A VERY CONCERTED EFFORT ANNA
DESIGNED EFFORT -- NOT ONLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BUT ALSO WITH
LAWMAKERS AND ALSO STATE
AGENCIES.
MOVING THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY UNDER THE STERN IN
GENERAL ACTUALLY VOLUMIZING IS
THE IMPACT THAT IT CAN HAVE.
THERE ARE MANY -- AND YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MANY OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
EFFORTS TO DOING THINGS DIRECTLY
IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE EQUITY
FOCUS PARTICULARLY ME AFTER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND HAVING THE OFFICE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE SURGEON GENERAL FOCUSED
ON TRAUMA TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
IN TRAUMA SCREENING.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO THE
CALIFORNIA LIKE HEALTH NO WORK
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL.
VERY MUCH OTHER SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX HAWTHORN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR PERCIVAL PEDIATRICIAN
IN OAKLAND THANK YOU.
MARK FOR PART WITH POLICY MAKING
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I FIGURE REMAINS ON THE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME PLAN SALINAS
AND THE CALIFORNIA LINES FOR YOU
THINK COMMUNITY JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN WHICH LIKE CLOSE MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER CHAMBERS
OF GAS FROM MY PHONE.
YOUR BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER -- MAYES A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO MA'AM SECRETARY OF
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
PREPARATIONS MAN SECTOR PLEASE%
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGAR
CURRY I BIGELOW BONTA BURKE.
CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA. FOR NOT VOTING.
LONG.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS ROTH IRA REGUS.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. SEVEN OF SEVEN BOTH
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL AS
WELL SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTERCHAIR AND ON TO
THE LAST ONE PRESENTING A WITH
YOUR PERMISSION ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA --
AB.
SIX FIFTY SIX THIS FEATURE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF SUMMER GARCIA.
AB SIXTY SIX HIGHLIGHTS
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
COORDINATED AT INTERSECTIONAL
STRATEGIES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
VIOLENCE AND THE ENVIRONMENTS
AND LISTENERS.
SECOND.
CURRENT POLICIES IN PUBLIC
FUNDING RESPONDED BY LISTENER
REACTIONARY FASHION RATHER THAN
A PREVENTIVE.
ONE THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL TO
TAKE A PROACTIVE APPROACH A
VIOLENCE PREVENTION IT WILL DO
THIS THROUGH THE CREATION OF AN
OFFICE OF HEALTH.
HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL WITH THE GOAL OF
ADDRESSING THE NEXUS BETWEEN
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AND PUBLIC
HEALTH INEQUITIES.
THIS NEW OFFICE WILL BE TASKED
WITH DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING AND
MONITORING A CALIFORNIA VISION
AND PLAN FOR VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SAFETY AND HEALING BY.
CONNECTING THE VISION AND PLAN
TO THE GOVERNOR STRATEGIES FOR
YOU DEVELOPMENT CRIMINAL
JUVENILE JUSTICE REFORM
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND OTHER
RELATED AREAS OPPORTUNITY.
IDENTIFYING AND INTEGRATING
TRAUMA CENTER DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS
SUCH AS EARLY AND PERIODIC
SCREENING.
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT TO
SUPPORT BY THIS PREVENTION
INTERVENTION AND HEALING AND
CREATING AN INTERACTIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY
THAT PRIORITIZES THE VOICES OF
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND
DOING THE WORK TO PREVENT
VIOLENCE.
AT PROMOTE PEACE AND HEALING AND
COMMUNITIES.
ALONGSIDE THIS BILL IS A BUDGET
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT STAFF CONSULTANTS AND
INITIAL EXPENSE ASSOCIATED WITH
CARRYING OUT THE TASKS AND
RESPONSIBILITY THE OFFICE.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORTER DEANGELO MAC DIRECTORS
STATE OF THE DIRECTOR STATE
POLICY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND COME UP ALL
DHALIWAL CO FOUNDER.
AND ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR AT THE
RISE CENTER.
SHARE OUT THERE WE ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S ANGELA MAC.
I'M WITH PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
AND THE STATE DIRECTOR -- THERE
AND UP THERE PROCESS BONSOR THIS
BILL.
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX FIVE SIX
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES PROMOTES
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND FOCUSES
ON ELIMINATING HEALTH
DISPARITIES BY TRANSFORMING
NEIGHBORHOODS INTO PLACES THAT
NURTURE WELL BEING.
AND THIS INCLUDES STANDING
BEHIND GOOD POLICY THAT MAKES
HEALTH A REALITY FOR ALL.
AB SIX FIVE SIX IS A GOOD POLICY.
WE BELIEVE THAT VIOLENCE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE OF GREAT
MAGNITUDE VIOLENCE IS THE NUMBER
ONE CAUSE OF DEATH FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO MALES.
AGES FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OF AGE AND IN MANY CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION.
VIOLENCE IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH FOR PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
THE INDIRECT EFFECTS OF VIOLENCE
INCLUDE CHRONIC DISEASE SUCH AS
HEART DISEASE CANCER STROKE
ASTHMA AND MANY MORE.
AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
LIKE PTSD -- DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY INCREASED EXPOSURE TO
VIOLENCE LOWERS EVERY DAY
QUALITY OF LIFE AND INCREASES
THE RISK OF PER PERPETRATING
VIOLENCE.
MENTAL TRAUMA FROM EXPOSURE TO
VIOLENCE HAS BEEN SIGNATURE THAT
SCIENTIFICALLY SHOWN TO INCREASE
A PERSON'S RISK OF ADOPTING
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR THEMSELVES --
MEANING THAT VIOLENT BEHAVIOR
TRANSMITS AND SPREADS BASED ON
EXPOSURE JUST LIKE IN THE
EPIDEMIC DISEASE.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES WOULD HELP TO
REVERSE THE EFFECTS OF TRAUMA
DUE TO VIOLENCE BY ADDRESSING
THE ROOT CAUSES OF VIOLENCE AND
DEVELOPING IT AND IMPLEMENTING
WITH THE HELP OF CULTURALLY
COMPETENT COMMUNITY MINDED
INDIVIDUALS.
A CALIFORNIA PLAN FOR VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SAFETY AND HEALING IN
CONCLUSION -- I'M EXCITED TODAY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THIS RIGHT --
IN MY PREVIOUS WORK I SERVED
OVER HUNDREDS OF YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN -- AFFECTED BY VIOLENCE
SHOT STABBED ASSAULTED AND I SIT
BEFORE YOU AS THEIR VOICE SAYING
PLEASE.
PASS THIS BILL WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KHAN
RECALL DALI WALL AND ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF THE
RISE YOU CENTER IN RICHMOND.
MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE HER AND HERS
ALLOWED I'M PROUD SPONSOR OF AB.
SIX FIVE SIX RICE CREATE SAFE
SPACES GROUNDED IN SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO LOVE
LEARN EDUCATE HE'LL AND
TRANSFORMS LIVES AND COMMUNITIES.
WE DO THIS THEIR PROGRAMMING IN
AREAS OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
EDUCATION AND JUSTICE YOUTH
LEADERSHIP IN RGANIZING AND
MEDIA ARTS AND CULTURE. TWENTY
FOURTEEN YOUR TWENTY FOURTEEN
RISING GAUGE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
YOUNG PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND ARTICULATIONS OF
TRAUMA VIOLENCE COPING AND
HEALING.
WHAT WE LEARNED IS THE FOLLOWING
THAT TRAUMA IS PERVASIVE ASSUMED
AND MULTI DIMENSIONAL?
YET GETS TREATED LARGELY BY THE
ADULTS AND SYSTEMS THAT WE WORK
AND AS EPISODIC BEHAVIORAL AN
INDIVIDUAL.
TRAUMAS ORGANIZE THEIR SILENCING
AND SHAMING MEDIATED THROUGH
SUBSTANCE USE AS WELL AS HARM TO
SELF AND OTHERS.
IN A SUBSEQUENT YOUTH WEBINQUIRY
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE -- WHO
TALK TO THEIR PEERS ABOUT THEIR
PRIMARY COPING STRATEGY WHICH
WAS SMOKING WEED ONE OF THE MOST
PAINFUL AND PROFOUND THINGS WE
HEARD WAS THAT?
YOUNG PEOPLE SHARE THE RISK OF
GETTING CAUGHT WITH MARIJUANA.
FELT LESS HARMFUL THAN THE RISK
OF TRYING TO ACCESS AN ADULT WHO
COULD HELP.
SO THIS ATMOSPHERIC DISTRESS IS
REFLECTED IN REINFORCED THROUGH
ON EMPATHETIC AND JUDGMENTAL
EXPERIENCES WITH ADULTS WHO ARE
STEWARDS OF THE SYSTEMS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
SO RISE WE WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE LEGAL
INJURY AND TOO MANY TIMES MERE
MY STAFF HAD TO INTERVENE THE
LANGUAGE AND TONE OF HEALTH CARE
STAFF WINNER FOR TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE WEBER OVER A DOZEN BULLET
HOLES IN THEM AS NON COMPLIANT --
ACTING AS BABIES.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND SOCIAL SERVICE
SYSTEMS THAT HOLD THEM CULPABLE
FOR THEIR INJURY AND THEN LACK
IN CONNECTING THEM TO THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THAT ARE
RIGHTFULLY AND LEGALLY BEARS.
SO WHEN WE ASK YOUNG PEOPLE WHAT
THEY NEEDED THE MOST RESPOND
RESOUNDING RESPONSE WAS THE NEED
DESIRE AND EXPECTATION FOR
ADULTS AND A SYSTEMS.
WHO CAN CARE A FIRM AND LOVE
THEM?
THEY SAID THEY NEED ADULTS AND
SYSTEMS WHO CAN PROVIDE GUIDANCE
AND STRUCTURE AND PREDICTABILITY.
AN ADULT WHO CAN WORK TOGETHER
BETTER WITHIN AND ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS RESPONSIBLE FOR US FOR
THEM.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE OFFICE
OF HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
AS EVER TIMELY IT'S A DIRECT
CALL TO ACTION FROM OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND IN ORDER TO MEANINGFULLY
CREATE HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WE
MUST UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS
SAFETY AS OUR YOUNG PEOPLE DO
AND ALL OF ITS DIMENSIONS.
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLITICAL AND
INSTITUTIONAL WE MUST UNDERSTAND
THAT SAFETY LIES IN SANCTUARY
NOT SURVEILLANCE THAT COMES
THROUGH HEALING NOT JUST
INTERVENING OR ENFORCING.
AND THAT MY SAFETY IS CONNECTED
TO THE ANGELOS HIS TO MINE HOURS
TO YOURS AND YOURS TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE'S AND TO EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM.
THANK YOU AND WE HOPE TO HEAR
AYE VOTE FOR SIX FIVE SIX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
JULIET SIMMS ON BEHALF OF
PREVENTION INSTITUTE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BY
PROSKAUER PROCESS BECAUSE
SPONSORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS AWESTRUCK HEM
HAVE TO SEE IF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HAVING A RUMOR IS A WE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA ALSO CO SPONSORS A
STRONG SUPPORT THINKING THANK
YOU.
AND IT'S NOW IT'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN AT THE
CATHOLIC WORK IN SUPPORT.
THE KID.
ARE YOU FOR LIKE ON BEHALF OF
DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A SPONTANEOUS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CARE PERSONAL
PEDIATRICIAN OAKLAND AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK AND SUPPORT.
SIR MICHAEL GAS IN WITH YOU
FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX PRISCO CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S TRUST í
THANK YOU. FOR SHALL DICKER WITH
THE NATIONAL NETWORK OF HOSPITAL
BASED VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
TO KNOW WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEE NONE WHICH I CLOSE WHICH CAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SHARES OF GAS
FROM ABOUT THANK YOU.
THE BILL DOES ENJOYED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE NAMES
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
I FLORA.
FLOOR NOT VOTING LIMON.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
GIVE FIVE WILL BE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH COULD
MISTER KALRA [inaudible]
MR GABRIEL
.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED ONE SIX SIX A BILL TO
PROVIDE MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR PROFESSIONAL VIOLENCE.
PREVENTION SERVICES FOR VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND OTHER
VIOLENT INCIDENTS.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHERRY
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS MEASURE.
THIS LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY THAT FAR TOO
MANY VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE ARE
AT HIGH RISK FOR RE INJURY AND
RETALIATION.
INDEED STUDIES HAVE ESTIMATED
THAT IN URBAN AREAS OVER 40% OF
PATIENTS TREATED FOR VIOLIN
INJURY SUCH A SHOOTING ARE RE
INTERRED WITHIN FIVE YEARS.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE ALARMING
TRENDS PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH
HAS IDENTIFIED HOSPITAL BASED
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
AS ONE OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE
AND EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING RATES OF FIND THE RE
ENTRY.
THESE PROGRAMS BRING SPECIALLY
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION SPECIALISTS SO YOU
TO THE HOSPITAL AND A UNIQUE
MOMENT OF OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS.
AS HIGH RISK FOR BINARY INJURIES.
CITIES HAVE REPEATEDLY
DEMONSTRATED THE SUCCESS OF SUCH
PROGRAMS YET THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN A ONLY A
FEW CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS LEADING
TO THOUSANDS OF MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
CYCLE OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES EVERY
YEAR.
AB ONE SIX SIX WOULD LEVERAGE
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS BY
CREATING A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
STREAM FOR THESE PROGRAMS BY
EXPANDING UTILIZATION OF THE
SERVICES THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
SAVE LIVES.
PROTECT TAXPAYER FUNDS REDUCE
BURDENS ON THE MEDICAL JUDICIAL
SYSTEMS AND ADDRESS TROUBLING
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION ARE
ARI FRY LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS TO RECORD
WITH THE DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
AND SHALL DECKER VICE CHAIR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SURGERY AT
UCLA AND FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF
THE UC SAN FRANCISCO WRAPAROUND
PROJECT THANK YOU AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHARMAN WOULD AN
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
MY NAME'S ARE SHALL DECKER AM A
TRAUMA SURGEON AND CURRENTLY THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR AT UCLA AND
FOUNDING DIRECTOR -- AS
REPRESENT OF GABRIEL HAD
MENTIONED OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
WRAPAROUND PROJECT A HOSPITAL
BASED VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAM.
I ALSO SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR THE
NATIONAL NETWORK OF POSSIBLE
BASED VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAM.
AT THE HOSPITAL BASED MODEL IS
THAT OF PROGRAMS THAT WORK WITH
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT VIOLENCE
IN THIS COUNTRY AND CERTAINLY IN
THE STATE.
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
CURRENTLY IT RIVALS OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE CONSIDER
EPIDEMIC.
VIOLENCE IS THE NUMBER ONE
KILLER AS DEANGELO MAC HAD
POINTED OUT OF YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN AND NUMBER TWO
AMONG LATINOS.
APPROACHING IT THROUGH A PUBLIC
HEALTH LENS ALLOWS US TO
RECOGNIZE IF WE WORK TO MITIGATE
RISK FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH
VIOLENCE WE CAN GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THIS ISSUE.
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND AMERICANS
ARRIVING OR TRAUMA CENTERS
ANNUALLY AND AS A RESULT OF
GUNSHOT WOUNDS AND STAB WOUNDS
FOR MANY OF THESE VICTIMS IT'S
NOT THEIR FIRST INJURY.
TRAUMA SYSTEMS HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
TO CARE FOR VICTIMS PHYSICAL
WOUNDS.
AFTER DAYS OR EVEN MONTHS OF
RECOVERY THAT WE JUST CHARGE
THESE PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE WITHOUT
ADDRESSING WHY THEY GOT HURT.
THE RESULT WE SEE THE SAME YOUNG
FACES BACK IN OUR TRAUMA BAY.
YOU CAN SEE HOW THIS IS TOTALLY
INADEQUATE VIOLENCE IS A CHRONIC
RECURRENT DISEASE PLAGUING OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT WE CAN PROVIDE A
WHOLE PERSON CARE.
OUR TRAUMACENTERS CAN AND
SHOULD BE THE PORTAL OF ENTRY
INTO ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
AND BUILD SOCIAL CAPITAL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
HOSPITAL BASED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROVIDES WHOLE
PERSON CARE AT THIS CRITICAL
MOMENT IN SOMEONE'S LIFE.
IN A GROWING NUMBER CENTERS
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BECOME PART
OF THE FABRIC OF THE TRAUMA
CENTER IN THE TRAUMA SYSTEM.
DESPITE THE STRUGGLE TO FUND THE
WORK.
CULTURALLY COMPETENT TRAINED
PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS GO TO
THE BAD SIDE OF AN INJURED
PERSON JUST LIKE I DO.
AND PROVIDED DURING THAT GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY AT A MENTOR SHIP
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY INDELIBLE
THIS PREVENTION PROFESSIONAL IS
SOMEONE WHO HAS OVERCOME IRVINE
VIOLENCE.
AND THEY'RE THE BACKBONE OF
THESE PROGRAMS THEY PROVIDE NOT
ONLY MENTOR SHIP BUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATION
THAT TRADITIONALLY VICTIMS WOULD
NOT SEEK OUT ON THEIR OWN.
OUR RESEARCH PROVES THAT THIS
APPROACH WORKS WE HAVE HAD
SUCCESSES WITH REDUCING
RECIDIVISM OF UP 23240% IN OUR
TRAUMA CENTERS AND WE'RE ABLE TO
GET PEOPLE TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED AND HAVE NOT
SOUGHT OUT TRADITIONALLY ON
THEIR OWN.
IN ADDITION WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE THROUGH OUR LEVERAGE IN
THE COMMUNITIES EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
ALL WENT WITH THIS MIKE TEXADA
IS -- PREVENTION PROFESSIONAL AT
SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL.
WHEN I WORKED THERE'S A TRAUMA
SURGEON I WOULD HAVE THIS MOMENT
RIGHT BEFORE I MADE AN INCISION?
WHEN I WOULD SILENTLY SAY TO
MYSELF I JUST HAVE TO GET?
THIS PATIENT OFF THE TABLE SO
THAT MY CAN SAVE HIS LIFE.
THE VALUE OF PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS IS PROFOUND.
WE NEED TO CODIFY THAT IN AB ONE
SIXTY SIX CAN DO IT.
IT PROVIDES NOT ONLY MECHANISM
TO SUSTAIN EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT WORK IT PROVIDES THE
IMPETUS FOR NEW ONES AND
SOLIDIFIES A PROCESS OF TRAINING.
AND QUALITY ASSURANCE.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS JUST TO
CONTINUE TO PUT ON REALLY
EXPENSIVE BANDAIDS WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE UNDERLYING
MODIFIABLE RISK FACTORS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RISK OF
VIOLIN INJURY.
DISCHARGING INJURED PATIENTS
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSES IS A CAN TO DISCHARGING A
PATIENT AFTER A HEART ATTACK
WITHOUT ASPIRIN.
OR ANY TYPE OF A OF HYPERTENSIVE
BLOOD PRESSURE -- ADJUSTMENT FOR
DIET AND EXERCISE.
I I AM -- I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE TO PROVIDE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I'LL.
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ARI
FILE IT CAN LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR DIFFERENT LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE --
WHICH IS THE WORKING CALIFORNIA
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
IS NOW CURRENTLY LED BY FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN AND GONE BALLOT
SURVIVOR GABBY GIFFORDS.
SO FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE'VE
TYPICALLY TESTIFIED IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE -- ON
EFFORTS PREVENT ANNOUNCED
REGULATION OF FIREARM COMMERCE.
SMART CARD ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
AND WE BELIEVE THE TIME HAS COME
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S THE WORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
TO CHECK CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND
WELL BEING IS AT LEAST AS
IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGE AN ENORMOUS HUMAN
IMPACT OF COMMUNITY VIOLENCE IN
THE STATE.
MURDER IS NOT JUST LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR YOUNG MEN OF COLOR
YOUNG BLACK MEN IN THIS COUNTRY
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR AS MANY
DEATHS AS EVERY OTHER BECAUSE
COMBINED AMONG YOUNG BLACK MEN --
HUMAN NATURAL ACCIDENTAL SUICIDE
COMBINED.
AND THOSE WHO DO SURVIVE A
SHOOTING RIGHT THAT'S THE HIGHER
RISK OF RE INJURY ESPECIALLY
WHEN BECOME EMBROILED IN CYCLES
OF INJURY TRAUMA AND RETALIATION
THAT CAN THE WHOLE COMMUNITIES
SCARRED BY THE ACTIONS OF A
RELATIVE FEW.
REPORTER RATES OF PTSD AMONG
YOUTH AND SOME OF OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
AT NEARLY TWICE THE RATE
REPORTED FOR TROOPS RETURNING
FROM IRAQ.
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
THAT'S WHEN THAT MEDI CAL IS
UNIQUELY WELL EQUIPPED TO
ADDRESS SINCE EVEN BEFORE ECA
EXPANSIONS OF MEDICAID IN THE
STATE. TWO THIRDS OF ALL GONNA
SOLVE HOSPITALIZATION PATIENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WERE COVERED BY
THE MEDICAID PROGRAM.
WE COULDN'T MUST BE DOING SO
MUCH MORE TO INVEST IN PROGRAMS
THAT WORK FOR THE HIGHEST RATE
HIGHEST RISK PATIENTS IN THIS
POPULATION.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AB ONE SIXTY SIX TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE
AISLES PREVENTIVE SERVICES AND
HELP MAKE CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL
LEADER IN TREATING COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE AS A SERIOUS
INCREMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
BECAUSE CAMINO VIOLENCE IMPOSES
ENORMOUS FISCAL BURDENS ON THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM WE ALSO ESTIMATED
THAT THIS BILL WOULD RESULT IN
DIRECT COST SAVINGS TO MEDICAL
MANY WOULD PAY FOR ITSELF.
IF IT IS ABLE TO CHEAT EVEN
MINIMAL REDUCTIONS IN FARMS ALL
RELATED INJURIES AMONG THE
MEDICAID POPULATION. FOR THESE
REASONS AND ESPECIALLY THE HUMAN
IMPACT -- WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK.
VERY MUCH OTHER SUPPORT.
DEMAND REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SPORT THANK YOU.
DE ANGELO MAC PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT CHAIR FOR THE
NATIONAL NETWORK OF HOSPITAL
BASED VIOLENCE INTERVENTION.
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NETWORK AND SUPPORT.
HARRISON ALTER EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CON REBUTTAL RISE YOU CENTER IN
RICHMOND STRONG STRONG STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARK FILL PART WITH POLICY
MAKING THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
ACTUALLY -- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME
[inaudible]
APOLOGIES.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AND COMMITTEE MISTER
MISS REGARDING.
THANK YOU I WITH THE MOTION YET --
YES YES MA'AM OKAY SECOND YEAH.
ANOTHER MOTION SO -- THANK YOU
SO I APPRECIATE YOU -- YOU
DOCTOR STEPPING INTO THIS PLANE
AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
LINE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AND SO SO THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE.
STEPPED UP IN CALIFORNIA
TREMENDOUSLY -- WITH THE
LAWCENTER OVER THE YEARS AND
OTHERS ON OUR LAWS ON THE BOOKS
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE BUT THIS
IS AN AREA THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE
SO IN OUR HEALTH WILL SO.
I SEE THE OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY DONE SO JUST WONDERED IF
IF THERE'S ANY AND I KNOW.
THEY DON'T THEY HAVE THEIR MEDI
CAL EQUIVALENT TO SOME OF THE
OTHERS JURISDICTIONS AND STATE
TO MENTION.
OTHER ANY -- ANALYSIS SEARCH
RESULTS AS FAR AS THE IMPACT AND
AND POTENTIALLY.
THE INITIAL COST FOR THE
BENEFITS DOWN THE ROAD.
SOME MULTIPLE STATES HAVE TAKEN
EFFORTS TO INVEST IN THE HOUSE
WILL BE FOUND TO MENTION
PROGRAMS THROUGH A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING APPROACHES
SOME THROUGH THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAMS OR VICTIMS.
OF CRIME ACT ASSISTANCE GRANTS
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LEE
PENNSYLVANIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT IS THE HAS A SMALL PILOT
PROGRAM CURRENTLY FUNDING THIS
THROUGH MEDI CAL.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A COVERED
BENEFIT IN THIS PROPOSAL.
DOES THEIR JURISDICTIONS.
COVERED BENEFITS.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW ONLY
PENNSYLVANIA AT THIS POINT --
NEW JERSEY IS MOVING A NEARLY
IDENTICAL BILL THIS YEAR AND WE
HOPE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL HELP
LEAD THE WAY TO MAKE THIS PART
OF A A DEFINED COVER BENEFIT
FROM MEDICAID POPULATIONS WOULD
COULD NATIONWIDE ARE -- ARE THE
MAJORITY OF GUNSHOT VICTIMS --
THAT IS THEIR INSURANCE -- SO
CALIFORNIA HAS CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN
INVESTING -- IN HOUSE WILL BE
FOUND TO THE BENCH PROGRAMS
WHICH HAVE SHOWN EFFECTIVENESS --
IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT FUNDER
THAT MEDI CAL HAS NOT FUNDED
THOSE OR COVER THOSE IS DEFINED
BENEFIT.
FOR YEAH RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
FOR THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COULD I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE THE COST
OF THIS ARE SO SIGNIFICANT IN
TERMS OF THE COST HIM A LIFE IN
THE FINANCIAL COST OF THIS.
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE THAT EVEN IF
THERE'S A VERY SMALL REDUCTION --
FROM IT IN IN RECIDIVISM AND
VIOLENCE BECAUSE OF THIS PROGRAM
I COULD GENERATE ENORMOUS COST
SAVINGS FOR THE STATE.
YEAH I DON'T I DON'T RECALL THE
NUMBER BUT I'VE SEEN THAT COSTS
OF A GUNSHOT.
VICTIM THE OUR COSTS AND IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL I DO IN REPEATS
ITSELF OUT IT'S YOU KNOW
RIDICULOUS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE COST SO WE THIS
WAS ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO THAT WE
DID A STUDY IN SAM'S IS GOING ON
AVERAGE IT WAS IT WAS ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
VICTIM?
OF FOR GUNSHOT STAFF GOING A
LITTLE BIT LESS EXPENSIVE BUT
BUT THAT PUTS IT IN PERSPECTIVE
AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS IF WE
COULD.
IF WE COULD REDUCE RECIDIVISM BY
JUST TWO PEOPLE THAT THE THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD PAY FOR
THEMSELVES AND THOSE ARE FOR
SURVIVORS.
CORRECT YES YEAH AND I I MEAN
I'VE SEEN ESTIMATES THAT HAVEN'T
NORTH OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A TRAFFIC
[inaudible] TO ONE ANYONE ELSE.
WELL.
AS WHICH WHAT CLOTHES ACT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU I SUPPOSE SAID THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- IT'S WE ACTUALLY
HAVE AN OF AN ANALYSIS DONE BY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM -- OF ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ABOUT POINT.
ZERO ZERO ZERO ONE OF OF MEDI
CAL EXPENDITURES AND IF IF A
GUNSHOT WOUND COSTS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TREAT.
OF THIS THIS PROGRAM WILL MORE
THAN PAY FOR ITSELF -- AND
GENERATE HUGE SAVINGS OF LIFE
AND RESOURCES SO I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- THIS DOES ENJOY DO
ACCEPT OUR AMENDMENTS I YES I
HAVE OKAY ALL RIGHT -- SO THE
BILL THE MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY -- MISS CARILLO SECOND MY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL.
WHAT WOULD I MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY BUT ANGER CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
I'M SORRY BIGELOW.
NOT VOTING BIGELOW NOT VOTING
BONTA.
BURKE I BURKE I CARILLO.
HI Là M<c.cyan> WE NEED A FLOOR.</c>
FOR NOT VOTING FLOWN.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE THIS
AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIGN.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
SEC.
YOUR BILL HAS SEVEN BOTH BELIEVE
THE BILL ON CALL WE STILL HAVE
MEMBERS THAT ARE OUT AND ABOUT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT UP MISTER JONES SAWYER.
JOE SORRY HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS --
PEOPLE HERE TODAY.
WHICH GROUP WITH HEALTH PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
FOR I DO. SEVENTEEN OH NINE
FIRST.
WHICH DIFFER [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
RESENT AB TWO FIVE EIGHT A BILL
THAT WOULD USE FUNDS FROM
PROFITABILITY.
PROJECT SUPPORT EARMARKED FOR
TRAINED FOR TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION TO FIND SUSTAIN WILL
HELP THE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
THE BILL ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THE GRANTS CREATED BY THIS BILL
WILL HELP FILL THE VOID AND
NUMBER OF SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
STAFF.
ALLEVIATE THE WORKLOAD --
ALREADY OVERWORKED TEACHERS AND
CONNECT SCHOOLS TO EXISTING
COMMUNITY RESOURCES.
THIS BILL IS STRUCTURE SAID THAT
GRANTS WILL LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY A
50% FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE SERVICES.
CURRENT RATIOS OF SUPPORT STAFF
ARE TERRIBLE WITH ONE COUNSELOR
FOR EVERY SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE STUDENTS ONE NURSE FOR EVERY
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
AND ONE SOCIAL WORKER FOR EVERY
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS THIS BILL PROVIDES
GRANTS TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS WHAT
SERVICES BEST FIT THE NEEDS OF
THEIR STUDENTS FOR THE FOR SOME
THIS MAY MEAN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. FOR OTHERS TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND IDENTIFYING
STUDENTS IN NEED OF TREATMENT
FOR OTHER STILL THE CREATION OF
A SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER
MIGHT BE MOST APPROPRIATE THIS
PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER A
SIMILARLY.
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN COLORADO
WHICH ALSO SAW EFFECTIVE HELP
PROGRAMS RESULT IN IMPROVED
STUDENT HEALTH AND ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT WITH ME TODAY -- TO RIDE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY I HAVE
HELEN DOUBT IN FROM TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY.
KIDS I HAVE TWO PEOPLE AND I
ONLY HAVE ONE NAME BUT WE'RE
GOING TO WORK IT OUT.
BUT YOU'RE THOSE SELF IDENTIFY
YES.
I'M I'M HELEN DROPPED OUT IN IN
WITH ME.
TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY KIDS IS
LYDIA BORN FROM -- THE SCHOOL
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND HAS -- AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THIS
WILL ACTUALLY PROVIDE A FUNDING
SOURCE FOR SCHOOL NURSES
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SOCIAL WORKERS.
BECAUSE WHAT WAS FOUND IN
COLORADO AFTER THEY PASSED THEIR
CANNABIS INITIATIVE THEY DID NOT
SEE THE NUMBER OF KIDS -- THE
NUMBER OF USERS GO UP AND THEY
PROVIDE IT WITH IN THE SCHOOLS
VERY SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THE COULD
FIGURE OUT THE KIDS THAT NEEDED
TREATMENT.
SEND THEM IMMEDIATELY TO
TREATMENT FOR THE REST OF THEM
TO FIGURE OUT PARTICULARLY WITH
MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS THE
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD COULD WITH
THAT COULD BE CREATED.
THE KIDS WOULD GO TO WHERE THEY
WOULDN'T -- OVER USE -- AND DO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND IT'S BEEN
THEY'VE HIRED OVER TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOL NURSES.
OUT OF THEIR CANNABIS FUNDS AND
THESE ARE ALL FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
WITH MEDICAID AND THAT CANNABIS
FUNDS WOULD PROVIDE THE MATCH SO
WE THINK IT'S A REALLY EFFECTIVE
USE OF THE CANNABIS MONEY WE
KNOW -- THEIR OTHER BILLS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE IN TERMS OF HOW
OVERALL FOR THE CANNABIS BUT
THIS RIGHT NOW IT'S SAYING GRANT
SPECIFICALLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO
MAKE THE DECISION ON WHAT'S THE
MOST USEFUL WAY OF USING THESE
MONEY FOR KIDS.
IN LYDIA CAN FINISH.
MEDIA ONE REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION.
SCHOOLS ALL THE HIDDEN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
AND AS WITH ANY OTHER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM YOU NEED ADEQUATE
PROVIDERS.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT MEET THE
PROFESSIONAL RATIOS FOR THESE
PROVIDERS.
OUR CHILDREN DO NOT LEAVE THEIR
HEALTH AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS AT
THE SCHOOL FOR ABSENTEEISM
CHRONIC DISEASE MANAGEMENT.
PTSD ALL CAN BE MANAGED OUR
SCHOOLS BUT WE NEED
PROFESSIONALS IN ADEQUATE
NUMBERS TO PROVIDE THE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AS WELL AS TRAINED
STAFF. TO RECOGNIZE AND REFER
FOR THE EASTER THESE SERVICES.
AB TWO FIFTY APRIL ALL SCHOOLS
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THESE HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS.
SCHOOLS A WHERE THE KIDS ARE.
AND HEALTHY STUDENTS LEARN
BETTER WE ASK FOR AND I FELT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT TONY TOOK CARE ON THE AT
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI PATRICK MORE TEAR WITH FIGHT
CRIME INVEST IN KIDS AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DONNA OUR TICKET WHICH
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
IN A ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMES AND
COMMITTEE.
MISTER JONES WE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YES ASK FOR YOUR HIGH VOTE
WAS WHAT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION -- MOTION
IS -- DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS CARILLO
ON A SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW --
MEDITECH TRIP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
HI BIGELOW AYE AYE BONTA
[inaudible]
BURKE.
I CARILLO.
HI.
FLORA FLORA HI THE MOON
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS.
RODRIGUEZ AGAIN LOOPY SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
YOU HAVE SIX THOSE WILL LEAVE
THAT ONE ON CALL ONE WHEN SOME
OF OUR OTHER MEMBERS RETURN.
THANK YOU.
ANOTHER CHANCE SO ANOTHER BILL --
BILL NUMBER. SEVENTEEN OH NINE
YES.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NO NIGHT
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT
ADMINISTRATIVE IN TRAINING --
MOVE THE BILL SECOND.
AB -- SEVENTEEN OH NINE PROVIDE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY ABILITY
TO DEDICATE RESOURCES TO
TRAINING THEIR SKILLED WORKFORCE
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR
NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATORS
RENEW THEIR LICENSES AND ENSURE
STATE OVERSIGHT.
OF LICENSURE EXAMS CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES ONE PRECEPTOR PER
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY SINCE
THE PRECEPTOR IS OFTEN AN
ADMINISTRATOR THE SKILLED
FACILITY NURSING FACILITY THIS
CAN BE UNNECESSARILY LIMITING
FOR LICENSED FACILITIES WITH
MORE THAN ONE LOCATION.
THIS REQUIRES ADMINISTRATORS
TAKE TIME AWAY FOR MANAGING A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TO
COMPLETE THEIR ROLE AS A
PRECEPTOR AND TRAIN FUTURE
ADMINISTRATORS.
AB SEVENTEEN OH NINE ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY ALLOWING SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THEY HAVE A
DEDICATED PRECEPTOR THAT CAN
SERVE AS A DESIGNATED TRAINER AT
MULTIPLE FACILITIES.
THIS LETS NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATORS FOCUS ON MANAGING
THE FACILITY TO ENSURE ALL
PATIENTS ARE RECEIVING THE CARE
THEY DESERVE.
THIS BILL ALSO STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS FOR NURSING HOME
ADMINISTRATORS TO RENEW THEIR
LICENSE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH REVIEW THE
LICENSURE EXAMS FOR CERTIFIED
NURSE ASSISTANTS.
AND NURSING HOME ADMINISTRATORS
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS JED
HAMPTON REPRESENTING LEADING
EDGE CALIFORNIA.
SPONSORS OF THE BILL MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AYE CHEN WITH MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE CHEN HAMPTON AT
WITH THE LEADING IT'S CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER SIX HUNDRED
NOT FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS A
SENIOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ASSISTED LIVING SKILLED NURSING
TOO MANY CARE TURNING
COMMUNITIES.
I'M VERY PROUD TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THE SIDE VERY
IMPORTANT BILL IN REDUCING.
HERE'S TO HIRING A SKILLED IN
HIGHLY TRAINED LONG TERM CARE
WORKFORCE AND I HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SHOULD YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PAYS
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY BLOMBERG ON THE HOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA
BLACKOUTS NO WORK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HAVE YOU ACCEPT THEIR AMENDMENTS
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
OF COURSE I ALWAYS APPEAR
AMENDMENTS MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
VERY KIND AND JUST JUST NEEDED
TO HEAR IT FROM YOU [inaudible]
A PERSON -- NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- WHICH LIKE CLOSER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THE BILL DOESN'T DO A JOB IT
DOESN'T.
IT I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEAN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW [inaudible]
AGAIN -- SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW I'M BIGELOW AYE AYE
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
HI CARILLO I FLORA [inaudible]
LIMóN MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
YOUR FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE BILL
ON COUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
MR SALIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE SERVER LEYVA OF THREE
MEASURES BEFORE YOU AND AS SUCH
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF.
WITH A WE JUST HAVE YOU COME
BACK LATER FOR THE OTHERS.
NO NOW OKAY ALL RIGHT.
THE BILL SECOND FISHING THAT SO
WE WILL FORTY WOULD ESTABLISH AN
OLDER ADULT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR TO
OVERSEE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OLDER ADULTS.
ESTABLISH OUTCOME INDICATORS IN
AN INTEGRATE CARE AND
STANDARDIZED GERIATRICS TRAINING
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
RESHAPE THE MOTION AND SECOND I
HAVE -- WHAT THIS IS IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANET
FRANK AND I'M A FACULTY
ASSOCIATE AT THE UCLA CENTER FOR
HEALTH POLICY RESEARCH AND ON
FACULTY AT THE UCLA FIELDING
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE FINDINGS FROM OUR STUDY ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
IN OLDER ADULTS SPONSORED BY THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
IN OUR STUDY WE FOUND
SIGNIFICANT UNMET NEEDS.
ARE AND GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE FOUND A FEW PROGRAMS OR
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO OLDER
ADULTS.
OUTCOMES MEASUREMENT AND DATA
WAS QUITE LIMITED SOURCE DATA
REPORTING HOWEVER WE DID ALSO
IDENTIFY PROMISING PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS THESE DEFICITS.
BASED ON OUR FINDINGS WE MADE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING TO ESTABLISH A FULL
TIME ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP
POSITION AT THE STATE LEVEL
DEDICATED TO OLDER ADULT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
WITH THE PROPER AUTHORITY THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO AN OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF POLICIES TO
IMPROVE SERVICES.
PROVIDE NEEDED OVERSIGHT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS ESTABLISH STANDARDIZED
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
GUIDE COUNTY EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
OLDER ADULT OUTREACH AND
DOCUMENT DOCUMENTATION OF UNMET
NEED.
PROMOTE STANDARDIZE GERIATRIC
TRAINING AN INCREASE SERVICE
INTEGRATION EFFORTS ESPECIALLY
BETWEEN MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGING AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
SERVICES. TO PROMOTE A
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE FOR OLDER ADULTS.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE STRONG AN IMMEDIATE NEED FOR
A FULL TIME LEADERSHIP POSITION
TO OVERSEE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
OUR STUDY SHOWED THAT OLDER
ADULTS HAD HIGH UNMET NEEDS BUT
WE DID NOT QUANTIFY THAT NEED
HOWEVER RECENT STATE DATA.
PRESENTED AT LAST WEEK'S
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL MAY SHED SOME
LIGHT ON THESE UNMET NEEDS.
DATA WERE PRESENTED SHOWING THAT
JUST OVER TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS THOSE SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER WERE PROVIDED WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULT
POPULATION IS ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION.
IN MOST OLDER ADULT PREVALENCE
STUDIES SHOW THAT ABOUT 20% OF
OLDER ADULTS OFTEN SUFFER FROM A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROBLEM.
BUT LET'S TAKE A MORE
CONSERVATIVE NUMBER LET'S JUST
SAY 10% OR ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS ARE IN
NEED OF SERVICES.
SO THE STATE SERVED TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND REPRESENTING A VERY
TIGHT TINY PROPORTION OF THOSE
ARE IN NEED AND RIGHT NOW.
NO ONE HAS RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE THE SYSTEM BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS.
SURELY CRONE I'M A SENIOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND I WAS HONORED TO HAVE
ATTENDED A CONFERENCE DOWN IN
LOS ANGELES.
WHERE JANET AND HER COLLEAGUES
FOR MAKING A PRESENTATION ABOUT
THEIR STUDY?
AND I SAID.
THERE'S A BILL I'M GOING TO
CARRY IT.
AND I PROCEEDED TO PUT THAT BILL
TOGETHER.
AND THROUGH SOME CHANCES OF
WHATEVER.
THIS GUY HERE SAID A I WANT THAT.
SO HE DID HE TOOK IN THE CITY'S
GONNA AUTHOR IT.
BUT I WOULD JUST TELL YOU THAT
THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL
THAT WAS INTRODUCED A LACKED A
WHOLE LOT OF DETAIL AND ALL OF
THAT DETAIL HAS BEGUN TO COME
TOGETHER.
AND I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT I'VE I
THINK ARE IMPORTANT.
WHEN WE WENT TO THE AGING
COMMITTEE -- ONE OF THE MEMBERS.
VEHEMENTLY I MEAN HE WAS SO
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUT
HE SAYS YOU'VE GOT TO INCLUDE
VETERANS.
WITH THE HIGH SUICIDE RATES IN
THE PTSD SITUATION YOU KNOW WITH
VETERANS AND WHATNOT THEY NEED
TO BE INCLUDED NOW CONSIDER THAT
SOME OF OUR NOT IT NECESSARILY
OLD.
HERE THEY MAYBE FROM MORE
COURAGE -- SITUATIONS BUT THEY
STILL HAVE THE NEED FOR THESE
SERVICES -- I SEE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE AND ENCOURAGE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS INTER
PROVIDING INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE PROGRAMS.
THAT AT THAT ADDRESS SOME OF
THEIR SPECIFIC ISSUES.
THESE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS CAN
AND SHOULD BE BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF OTHER AGENCIES FOR
POSSIBLE IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS IS WHERE I THINK ADVISORY
BODIES SHOULD HAVE REGIONAL
REPRESENTATION IN ADDITION TO
STATE ORGANIZATIONS.
SEEMS LIKE IF HE COUNTIES AROUND
THE STATE HAVE BUILT SILOS
AROUND WHAT THEY DO AND DON'T
NECESSARILY SHARE WHAT THEY DO
WITH OTHERS AND THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE'S SOME
INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY OUT
THERE THAT WE'RE NOT HEARING
ABOUT.
THAT OTHERS COULD POSSIBLY USE.
SO HOW OFTEN.
ARE WE OR WILL THERE BE AN AUDIT
LIKE INTERVENTION TO DETERMINE
THE OUTCOME BEST PRACTICES
EXPERIENCE LESSONS LEARNED NOT
TO BE REPLICATED IN THE FUTURE.
AND SPECIFICALLY HOW THE MONEY
WAS ALLOCATED AND HOW IT WAS
ACTUALLY USED ALONG WITH THE
RESULTS.
HAVING STATE LEVEL OVERSIGHT
WILL ENSURE THAT THE BUDGET
REQUESTED WAS ACTUALLY USED AS
DESCRIBED IN THE REQUEST THIS IS
WHERE AN OPPORTUNITY IS CREATED
TO PUT THE SPOTLIGHT ON
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES AND
SUCCESSFUL AND CREATIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
I URGE YOU.
TO GIVE US AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RENTAL HAGER WITH
CALIFORNIA'S PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHAIR MEMBERS OUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
OF SPORT.
CUT TO MOST BURKE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING IN SPORTS.
GEN HAMPTON MEETING IT'S
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEE KNOWN BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS -- RESPOND
AS WELL SAVE.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
NOT JUST THAT IT'S AN ALARMING
RATE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
INCREASE OF THE SUICIDES AT THAT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT WAS
ACTUALLY REFERRING TO AN
APPRECIATE -- THE DO SUPPORT
POSITION ON BOTH SIDES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD --
COUPLE COMMENTS WELL WE DON'T
YET KNOW WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
MASTER PLAN ON EIGHTEEN WILL
CALL FOR IT'S CLEAR THERE WILL
BE RENEWED FOCUS.
ON MANY OF THE ISSUES ADDRESSED
IN YOUR BILL.
AND THAT ARE INCLUDED AS DUTIES
OF OF THE OLDER OLDER ADULT
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITION CREATED
BY YOU BY YOUR BILL AB.
FOR EIGHTY AS A PLAN UNFOLDS WE
MAKE IT CLEAR CONSENSUS ON
WHETHER THIS POSITION SHOULD BE
LOCATED IN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES NUMBER DEPARTMENT
OF AGING AND THAT'S STILL UP IN
THE AIR AT THIS POINT OBVIOUSLY.
TOOK THIS THE BILL WAS FOR THE
EFFORTS -- EFFORTS WILL BE MADE
TO ENSURE THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL ALL LINES.
WITH THE GOVERNORS OF PROPOSED
MASTER PLAN -- TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR AGING POPULATION SO I KNOW
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
ABSOLUTELY THE BILL DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION -- TO DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW IN
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
UNLESS A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT.
WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMóN MCCARTY.
THIS AREA.
RAMOS RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON.
YOUR FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE BILL
ON COFFEE Là MEMBERS OUT ABOUT
THANK YOU FOR SHE THAT MISTER.
X. A. B. [inaudible]
TEN FIFTY EIGHT THE BILL
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
FIRST MISTER CHAIR FAVE MAY
PROCEED.
SELECT SURVEY AT THANKING YOU IN
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS BILL TO
HELP IDENTIFY THE BARRIERS.
AT TO INTEGRATING TREATMENT
MAYBE TEN FIFTY WOULD ESTABLISH
A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP
AND IDENTIFIED MINISTRY TO THE
LEGAL BARRIERS. TO THE DELIVERY
OF INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR BETTER.
FISHERIES WITH CO OCCURRING
SUBSTANCES.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS AND
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
REQUIRES THE H. YES TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THOSE
BARRIERS.
IF YOU HAVE TESTIMONY HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA THAT WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
MANY OF THE CLIENTS WE SERVE IN
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS --
COME TO US WITH CO OCCURRING
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND YET THE SIR AND
YET TO RECEIVE CARE THEY MUST
OFTEN NAVIGATE BETWEEN SEPARATE
SYSTEMS -- WHICH CAN BE
CHALLENGING EVEN THOUGH MOST
COUNTIES HAVE MERGED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES.
REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISMS COUNTY
CONTRACTS WITH THE STATE
DOCUMENTATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OVERSIGHT AND OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS
REMAIN BIFURCATED.
AND THIS PRODUCES INEFFICIENCIES
AND BARRIERS TO THE INTEGRATION
OF THESE SERVICES.
MOREOVER THE NEED FOR CLIENTS TO
NAVIGATE TO DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
AND WORK WITH SEPARATE CLINICAL
TEAMS CAN INTERFERE WITH ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE CARE.
OUR CLIENTS DON'T COME TO US
BIFURCATED.
NEITHER SERVE OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES BE BIFURCATED IF
WE'RE GOING TO EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDE A WHOLE PERSON CARE.
CLIENT CARE SHOULD BE SHAPED BY
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL NOT BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS OF
SEPARATE DELIVERY SYSTEMS. TO
PROVIDE INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
CALIFORNIA MUST IDENTIFY
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT MODELS THAT
SERVE THE WHOLE PERSON.
THROUGH THIS STAKEHOLDER PROCESS --
WE WOULD WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY BARRIERS
TO PROVIDE A WHOLE A WHOLE
PERSON CARE AND MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE CHANGES IN
REGULATION OR IN THE STATE PLAN
IN ORDER TO BETTER INTEGRATE --
THESE SERVICES FOR THE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR CLIENTS I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION EVERY
ARGYRIA VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT -- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SITE
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON THE HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S SOCIETY VICTIMS NOT
A SIN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WHICH I CLOSE MISTER
SALAS THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND SAID DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND BY MISS KOREA.
LAST MINUTE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
BIGELOW HI BIGELOW AYE BONTA
BURKE BURKE HI CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
LIMóN.
MCCARTY THIS AREA FROM US.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON.
YEAH FIVE FIVE AS BEFORE WE THAT
BILL HUNT CAUGHT WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE SECOND.
THAT A MOTION AND A SECOND SORRY
THANK YOU MISTER AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY NINE WOULD HELP ADDRESS A
SEVERE GROWING HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BY
APPROPRIATING.
THE ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT WE
DISCUSSED YESTERDAY AND SUB
TWEET IT IS A MATTER OF FACT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
CORRECT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE IDEA OF
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT ROBERTS ON BEHALF OF KAISER
PERMANENTE A WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE I THINK TO
SOME MEMBERS ALSO BRING THIS
BILL FOR TODAY AND ALSO -- IN
FROM THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE I
YESTERDAY WHEN I SPOKE ON BEHALF
OF YOU -- KAISER PERMANENTE A
SURGE OF NINE MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER THIRTY SIX
HOSPITALS IN OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY MEDICAL OFFICES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE QUALITY
INAPPROPRIATE CARE IS IMPERATIVE
TO TRACK A QUALIFIED ANSWER
SINGLE WORK FORCE IN THE STATE.
HAVE BEEN SHOWS THE EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT OFTEN LEADS TO BETTER
HEALTH ANCHOR OUTCOMES BETTER
JOBS HIGHER INCOME EARNINGS
IMPROVE ACCESS RESOURCES THAT
REINFORCE HEALTH.
BECAUSE APARTMENT DAY IS HELPING
TO IMPROVE MANY HELP INCREASING
ACCESS EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
SCHOLARSHIPS INVESTMENTS IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE IN DEVELOPING A
MORE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE THAT
MIRRORS THE COMMUNITIES IT
SERVES.
WE START BUILDING THAT PIPELINE
OF TALENTED AND DIVERSE HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS EARLY WITH
PROGRAMS.
THEY INTRODUCE UNDER REPRESENTED
GRADE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO CAREERS AND HEALTH
CARE.
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SCHOLARSHIPS
AND PREFER THAT PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO EMPOWER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ENSURE
CAREERS IN HEALTHCARE.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES AND
PRAXIS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE
WILL HELP UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS IN THOSE UNDERSERVED
GEOGRAPHIES AND WILL DIRECTLY
ACCESS. TO MEET WILL DIRECTLY AT
ADDRESS ACCESS TO CARE
CHALLENGES WITH THE SEGMENTS
THEREBY IMPROVING OVERALL HEALTH
OUTCOMES WITH THAT WHERE AND
PROUD SUPPORT OF AB TWO AB.
SEVENTY FIFTY NINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SPITTLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICTOR CHRISTY
CALVET HELPLESS ADVOCATES
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ARE BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBG WHY
INSTITUTE NINE AND THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARCHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MONICA ARE LESS MODEST WITH THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING TO GO FORWARD OBVIOUSLY
WE WE KNOW WE HAVE A HUGE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION CAME UP
WITH A VARIETY OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS SO WITH THAT
PRICE TAG ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD OF YOUR
BILLS ASKING FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON WHICH WOULD BE A NICE
JUMP START ON SOME OF THE SOME
OF THESE -- ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO US -- I RESPECT IT
I OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU ARE TO
PASS UP TO APPROPRIATIONS --
MADAM SECRETARY WELL JOINT TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THINKING THIS SHOW FOR THOSE
COMMENTS.
A MAN SECRETARY -- WE HAVE --
PROMOTION BY MR BIGELOW SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO MOTION IS PASSED
TO PREPARATIONS SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY?
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE.
AND I CARILLO HI CARILLO I'VE
FLORA.
THE MOST MCCARTY.
THIS AREA FROM US RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE BILL OKAY ALL AND MISTER
CHAIR PERHAPS -- FOR THAT LAST
BILL WHEN IT MOVES OUT OF
COMMITTEE MISTER BIGELOW IS
INDICATED HE'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR.
GOT IT.
AWESOME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT UP MISS QUIRK SILVA
.
COVER FOR SECOND
HI THE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
MEMBERSHIP QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
THAT'S ALREADY ON THE DAY I GOT
A LONG WAY TO GO.
THAT IS AWESOME YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT RIGHT -- BUT
YOU CAN CALL ME QUICK SILVER IF
YOU WANT [inaudible]
ANY.
THAT'S RIGHT I'M HERE TO PRISON
AB -- FIVE SIXTY THREE AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL BILL TO
ME AS THE IT IS NO SECRET THAT
NOT ONLY ORANGE COUNTY BUT OUR
ENTIRE STATE.
IS FACING A HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND WHEN YOU ADD THAT IN WITH
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE SEE
WITH OUR OWN HOMELESS -- FROM
SOME OF OUR HOMELESS BEING --
VETERANS -- TO SOME OF ARE
HOMELESS BEING NOT ONLY FAMILIES
BUT ALSO THOSE THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE
OR ADDICTION -- TO SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES -- WE ALSO NOTE
THAT AS WE ARE THIS YEAR
FOCUSING ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AS A PRIORITY THAT
WE HAVE TO NOT -- TO TACKLED ARE
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH RELATED
TO HOMELESSNESS AND SADLY I
PERSONALLY HAVE HAD MORE THAN A
FOR A FEW INSTANCES ONE LEADING
BACK TO TEN YEARS AGO WHEN -- IN
THE CITY OF FULLER TEN AS A
COUNCIL MEMBER.
WE HAD A MAJOR INCIDENT ON THE
STREETS OF FULLER TEN WITH THE
DEATH OF ALL HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL
WHO SUFFERED FROM SCHIZOPHRENIA
KELLY THOMAS IN THIS CASE MADE.
NEWS ACROSS NOT ONLY OF THE
STATE BUT REALLY THE WORLD AND
TEN YEARS LATER AND THE THIS
FALL I OFF ALSO PERSONALLY HAND
MY BROTHER -- BILLY J. SO DIE ON
THE STREETS.
AND WHAT A PARK -- WHO OFF ALSO
SO THIRD -- SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
DEALT WITH HOMELESSNESS THAT
BEING SAID ALL TOO OFTEN WE SEE --
WHEN THESE?
CASES ARE FIRST OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY GET THE CALLS 911- CALLS
AND WHEN THERE IS A NEED THEY
ARE MANY TIMES AND UP IN OUR
HOSPITALS.
IN RG ALES AND WITHOUT HAVING
PROPER CARE.
THEY'RE DYING THEY ARE DYING OR
STREETS IN ORANGE COUNTY AT THE
RATE OF THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
WHO HAVE DIED.
THIS LAST YEAR INCLUDING THIRTY
IN THE MONTH OF MARCH IN THE
STREETS OF ORANGE COUNTY.
AND THIS IS THE ORANGE COUNTY
THAT IS HIGHLIGHTED WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY HOUSEWIVES OF THE
STREETS THAT ARE PAVED IN GOLD
AND THIS IS THE ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT.
PEOPLE COME TO FOR ENTERTAINMENT
AND AT THE HAPPIEST PLACE DON
MILLER ON OUR EARTH AND YET IN
OUR ELOISE IN OUR PARKS IN OUR
HOSPITALS WE SEE.
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED DIE.
AND IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND IT'S OUR MORAL OBLIGATION AS
A STATE.
AND AS A COUNTRY TO DO MORE AND
WE CAN DO MORE -- IN AB SIX FIVE
SIXTY THREE WOULD CREATE THE
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY CRISIS
NETWORK REPORT RESPONSE PILOT
PROGRAM.
A PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING A
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND SERVICES
FOCUSED ON PREVENTION.
DIVERSION AND EARLY INTERVENTION
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR MENTAL
WELLNESS CRISIS.
I'LL JUST LET MY GUESS HERE
SPEAK FOR JUST A SHORT MOMENT
BUT I WILL TELL YOU ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS MODEL ADDS IN
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN BEFORE.
IS OUR PUBLIC SAFETY BUT ALSO
OUR HOSPITALS WORKING TOGETHER
TO SOLVE THIS SO HERE WITH ME
TODAY -- WORKING ON THE SYSTEM
OF CARE WE HAVE DOT DAN YOUNG
WITH MINE GO SEE OUR FULLER TEN
POLICE CHIEF.
ROBERT DONE IN TWO ONE ONE
THAT'S A CRISIS NUMBER THAT YOU
CAN CANNOT CALL KAREN WILLIAMS
SO WE'LL START OVER HERE.
THEN YOU HAVE TO KEEP YOUR
REMARKS VERY BRIEF AS I KNOW.
I CHAIR IS A VERY ADAMANT THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHRIS I THINK
WE'VE GOT SOME FIFTY SOME BILLS --
TODAY THAT'S RIGHT SO -- START
WITH US RIGHT OVER HERE MIND OC
THANK YOU.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I I
WILL BE VERY BRIEF MY NAME IS
DAN YOUNG I SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF HOPE HOSPITAL.
HAVING OME -- MANY YEARS AGO
ALSO BEING -- THE MAYOR OF
SANTANA AND I'M CURRENTLY ON THE
BOARD OF OF MINE DOES SEE MY NO
SEE IS PART OF THE MOVEMENT IN
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE A UNIQUE
JOURNEY THAT WE'RE ON A VERY
EXCITING JOURNEY.
WHERE WE INTEND TO CREATE A
SYSTEM OF CARE IN ORANGE COUNTY?
TO DEAL DIRECTLY AND
COMPREHENSIVELY WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND ADDICTION.
THIS JOURNEY HAS TAKEN MORE THAN
EIGHTY ORGANIZATIONS PUT HIM
INTO A ROOM AND WE DECIDED AS A
COLLECTIVE AS A MOVEMENT.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SYSTEM OF CARE NO ONE WILL FALL
BETWEEN THE CRACKS IT FOR SYSTEM
IS CREATED.
AND IMPLEMENTED AS WE ARE
CURRENTLY DESIGNING AT THIS IS
MORE THAN CONVERSATION OUR FIRST
MAJOR PROJECT IS OUR FIRST BE
WELL CLINIC.
IT WILL OPEN IN ORANGE WILL
START CONSTRUCTION ON IT NEXT
MONTH IT'S A FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT.
AND UNIQUELY THAT COMES FROM
FUNDING FROM HOSPITALS.
CAL OPTIMA IN THE COUNTY SO WE
HAVE A UNIQUE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP GOING THIS IS THE
FRONT END OF THE SYSTEM THIS
BILL WE NEED THIS BILL IN ORDER
FOR THESE CLINICS TO WORK AND SO
WE ASK YOU RESPECTFULLY IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE -- GIVE US AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL AND HELP US TO
CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM OF
CARE TO DEAL WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND ADDICTION THROUGH A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP I BELIEVE
UNIQUE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN
WE'LL GO WITH OUR POLICE CHIEF
NEXT.
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMORY
MEMBERS IF ME MY NAME'S BOB DONE
TO PLEASE A CITY FOR TEN AND A
MEMBER OF THE NORTH FORK I
PUBLIC SAFETY TASK FORCE.
TASK FORCE ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH TEN CITIES IN
NORTH WHICH COUNTY. TO
COLLABORATE AND ADDRESS
REGIONALLY OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
CHALLENGES AMONG THAT THE FOCUS
IS ON HOMELESSNESS.
WE BELIEVE HOMELESSNESS SHOULD
BE RARE BRIEF AND NON RECURRING
AND THE NORTHRIDGE TYPE PUBLIC
SAFETY TASK FORCE IS ACHIEVING
RESULTS IN THAT DIRECTION.
REGIONALLY ACROSS OUR TEN SEASON
MEMBERSHIP.
TASK FORCE RECENTLY COMPLETED A
HOMELESS CENSUS REPORT IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BASE LINE OF INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITHOUT HOUSING IN OUR
REGION.
AND TO MEASURE OUR EFFORTS THUS
FAR IN PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION.
OUR REPORT IDENTIFIED THE
FOLLOWING THE FOLLOWING KEY
FINDINGS.
WE'RE GONNA FIVE SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN HOMES ADULTS
WITH A HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
CHILDREN. 52% IDENTIFIED AS
HOMELESS FOR OVER THREE YEARS
41% REPORTED A PERSISTENT MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION. 37% REPORTED
ACTIVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
CHALLENGES AND 54% OF WOMEN
RESPONDING HAD EXPERIENCED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WITHIN THE
LAST YEAR.
THE TASK FORCE NOT ONLY TRACKING
EASY TENER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN INDIVIDUALS BUT WE
ARE ALSO IN THE MANY TECHNOLOGY
SO THAT WE CAN TRACK THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND OUR EFFORTS THAT WE GIVE TO
THEM IN THE STREETS.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE SIXTY THREE BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES A SYSTEMATIC APPROACH
TO CREATING BEHAVIOR BUT
BEHAVIORAL PHYSICAL SOCIAL
SAFETY NET.
FOCUSED ON USER NAVIGATION THAT
IS INTENDED TO DIVERT FROM OUR
JAILS IN EMERGENCY ROOMS OFFER
EARLY INTERVENTION WILL CHAPLAIN
CHALLENGES OCCUR.
EVERY EVENT INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES MENTORING INDUSTRY
HOMELESSNESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOULD
INAUDIBLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KAREN
WILLIAMS AND I HAVE THE HONOR TO
SERVICES CO TWO ONE ONE ORANGE
COUNTY.
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION
RESERVE THE TWO ONE ONE DIALING
CODE FOR COMMUNITY INFORMATION.
AND REFERRAL SERVICES THE FCC
INTENDED THE TWO ONE ONE CODE IS
AN EASY TO REMEMBER AND A
UNIVERSALLY RECOGNIZABLE NUMBER
THAT WOULD ENABLE THE CRITICAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS.
AND FAMILIES IN NEED AND THE
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES CURRENTLY ACTIVE TWO
ONE ONE SYSTEMS COVER ALL OR
PART OF FIFTY STATES.
PLUS WASHINGTON DC IMPORTER RICO
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT IN
CALIFORNIA TWO ONE ONE COVERAGE
IS AT 96%.
WE SERVE TO POINT WITH THE
SERVER THREE POINT TWO MILLION
ORANGE COUNTY RESIDENTS WE TAKE
OVER NINETY THOUSAND CALLS A
YEAR.
PROVIDING ALMOST A QUARTER OF A
MILLION REFERRALS AS WELL AS
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND WEBSITE
REFERRALS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN SO YOU CAN SEE THERE'S
DEFINITELY A NEED. TO ONE ONE
SEE PROVIDES CALL THIS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT AND REFERRALS
TO SERVICES SERVICES.
FOR EVERYDAY NEEDS IN TIMES OF
CRISIS.
THE CONSOLIDATION OF THIS --
PROGRAM WILL LEAD TO MORE WARM
AND HOT HAND OFFS ADDITIONAL
CASE MANAGEMENT AND COORDINATED
SYSTEM OF SERVICE NETWORK
PROVIDERS DELIVERING ASSESSMENT
CARE.
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILIES.
VERSUS FORCING USER INTO A
GOVERNMENT MANDATED SYSTEM THAT
ISN'T AN EFFECTIVE FOR PERSONAL
NEEDS.
AB FIVE SIXTY THREE IS PARAMOUNT
TO PARAMOUNT TO A STRENGTHENED
CENTRALIZED NAVIGATION PROGRAM
IN VISION FOR ORANGE COUNTY --
AND I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SIR RECEIVERS FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN ORANGE COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SO IT PROBABLY SEEN JUST
OF HEALTH IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE WINDOWS.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN WHICH I CLOSE.
BUT AGAIN JUST THE URGENCY AND
THIS PILOT PROGRAM TO NOT ONLY
US BASICALLY TO SAVE LIVES AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS QUIRK
SILVA THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO I'M SORRY TO SEE
OPPOSITE MISS CARILLO MOTION A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW --
MOTIONS TO PASS TO CORPORATIONS
OUT OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE[inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA [inaudible]
LEVEL [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
GET FIVE ZERO FIVE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
MISTER CHAIR THINK IT YOUR
WITNESSES MR GRAYSON
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- AB
SIX FIFTY ONE WILL INCREASE MEDI
CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS.
WITHOUT PASSAGE OF THIS
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENT WILL
REVERT TO NINETEEN NINETY THREE
LEVELS YOU MERCY AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE STATEWIDE.
EMS SYSTEM AND PROVIDE A
CRITICAL LINK TO TRANSFER
PATIENTS BETWEEN RURAL AREAS --
SUCH AS HOSPITAL'S TRAUMA
CENTERS BURNS CENTERS CARDIAC
STROKES CENTERS AS WELL AS
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS.
CURRENT MEDI CAL RATES -- PAY
PROVIDERS FOR FAR BELOW THE RATE.
THAT IS NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THE MEDIC COW BASS AND
MILEAGE RATES HAVE NOT BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
SO AB SIX FIFTY ONE WILL REPLACE
THE MEDI CAL RATE FOR AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS. TO THE RULE
OF MEDICARE LEVEL AND SO I WILL --
ASK FOR MY WITNESSES TO SELF
INTRODUCE AND SAY -- IN A VERY
EXPEDITIOUS WAY WHY THIS IS THE
BEST BILL YOU'VE HEARD ALL DAY.
THANK YOU ARE BILL BRYANT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CARE MEDICAL SERVICES -- AIR
AMBULANCES DO NOT SELF DISPATCH
WE RELY ON THE EMS FIRST
RESPONDERS FIRE DEPARTMENTS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS IN THE FIELD WHEN THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED US TO
RESPOND.
SAME FOR RURAL PHYSICIANS WHO
NEED TO SEND THOSE PATIENTS TO
TERTIARY CARE CENTERS -- IN THE
MAJOR -- METROPOLITAN AREAS --
WHEN THAT AIR AMBULANCES
RESPONDING WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHETHER THE PATIENT AS ANY FORM
OF INSURANCE OR NOT?
THEY CALL WE GO -- THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME BILL AS AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE FROM
LAST YEAR.
AND IT DOES INCLUDE SOME PATIENT
PROTECTION -- PROVISIONS AGAINST
BOUNCE BILLION AND WE JUST LIKE
TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
HEALTH ACCESS TO WORK WITH US IN
DEVELOPING THE STANDARDS.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE IN THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SIR.
CHAIRMAN WOULD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CHRISTOPHER
HALL AND THE DIRECTOR GOVERNOR
FAIRS FOR PH I. R. MEDICAL WE
SERVICES AND CALIFORNIA FROM
BASES IN MODESTO SUSANVILLE
READING.
AND SONORA CALIFORNIA WE JOIN
WITH OUR OTHER MEDICAL PROVIDERS
AND PROVIDING SERVICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
SINCE SUPPORT.
AM J. D. AS HE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
MORTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JENNIFER ALI FLIGHT PARAMEDIC
FOR PH I CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KAREN FRIEND MET FOR THREE
REDDING.
IN SUPPORT GIVE.
A ROBBER LYNCH AMER'S HERE SIXTY
SIX BY PARAMEDIC IN SUPPORT.
THE BILL IS A MONEY MERCIER
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PRIME MENDEZ PROGRAM DIRECTOR
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA REACH A
MEDICAL GROUP STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOT FLANDERS WITH -- METHODS
SUPPORT.
MARTY ARCUS REACHER MEDICAL
SERVICES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ROSS FAKE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF OUR MEDICAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
NICK LOUISE'S CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GEN FLOOR STEPHANIE WHY CAN SOME
WE HAVE THIS VISION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE. TWENTY ONE
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES -- I THANK THE MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS -- VERY IMPORTANT
BILL -- FOR BUT I CAN JUST SPEAK
FROM MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
IS WORKING IN THE M. S. INDUSTRY
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS THERE'S
BEEN.
HUNDREDS OF OCCASIONS OF OR I'VE --
RAND MEDICAL CALLS WITH THE AND
SERVICES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I COULD BE SPEAKING FROM NOT
ONLY FOR MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
ABOUT.
FROM THE CARE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS GIVE TO PEOPLE ON A
DAILY BASIS IS INCREDIBLE -- I
THINK THE ONLY WAY YOU KNOW IT
IS BY WORKING WITH THESE MEN AND
WOMEN AND IF BY CHANCE SOMEBODY
MAY HAVE BECOME A A PATIENT AND
OR MAYBE A ROLL ERROR TRAUMA
TYPE CARE PATIENTS THAT NEEDED
THEIR SERVICE.
IT'S A GODSEND TO SEE THESE
FOLKS DOING THEIR JOB AND I
THINK WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO HELP
THEM -- TO KEEP THEM IN SERVICE
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE A VERY
CRITICAL LINK IN THE EMAIL
SERVICE HERE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA'S ON A THANK RING
THIS.
FOR LIKE SEE IF I CAN BE A CALL
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL WITH YOU.
THANK YOU LOOK FOR TO SUPPORT AS
WELL THANKS.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IT'S CRITICAL LIFELINE IN A IN A
LARGE RURAL DISTRICTS SUCH AS
MYSELF BUT ALSO.
IN A IN AN URBAN AREA AS WELL WE
WERE MINUTES SO REALLY REALLY
MATTER SO -- COULD ALONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS OF THE OF THE
AIR AMBULANCE SERVICE AND I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR TO YOUR BILL THANK YOU --
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
PLEASE AND IF YOU WOULD MR
CHAIRED DOCTOR WHAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO BRING
RECOGNITION TO THE THOSE IN
FLIGHT SUITS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
FOR THE WONDERFUL LIFESAVING
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO US IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT.
AND THEN ALSO JUST ONE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISTER MISTER MAYES.
A SECOND BY MS CARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE CARRILLO.
NO I FLORA.
LIMóN MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON.
YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
MR DEEP
.
THIS CHAIRMAN YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MEMBERS --
FOR YOUR TIME I'LL MAKE IT
REALLY SHORT THE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB A SEVEN ONE NINE MOVE
THE BILL.
ALL OF OF OKAY ILLITERATE I WOKE --
PLEASE PROCEED.
WITH THE GERMAN IN IN IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL --
AB NINETY SEVEN TO REDUCE MEDI
CAL PAYMENT RATES TO HEALTH
PLANS AND PROVIDER.
OF THE LEGISLATURE MADE THESE
CUTS IN ORDER TO HELP ADDRESS
THE STATE BUDGET DEFICIT AT THAT
TIME -- WE ARE NO LONGER -- IN
IN SUCH A A DIRE SITUATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S NO LONGER FACING A
BUDGET DEFICIT RATHER THAN WE
HAVE A BUDGET SURPLUS.
AND AT THE TIME WHEN PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND ACCESS TO
CARE.
A WE SHOULD INCENTIVIZE MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS TO TAKE ON MORE
PATIENTS BY REMOVING THESE
REDUCTIONS.
OF THAT WERE MADE WHEN THE STATE
WAS A FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING --
I'M GOING -- TO CUT MIGHT COME
ASHORE IN REQUESTS -- IT WITH
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME IS -- KELLY
BEAM AND AND BOB ACKERMAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN CASE -- ANY OF
YOU GUYS HAVE QUESTIONS.
SO KELLY BEING HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW WHAT THE
INCREASE IN ELIGIBILITY FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DO ALL IT CAN
TO ENSURE THEIR PROVIDERS
WILLING TO TREAT THESE PATIENTS --
PROVIDER REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
ALREADY AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
COUNTRY FOR MANY SERVICES -- AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE NINE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR BY BACKGROUND I
HAVE TWO OF OR ON BEHALF THREE
PROVIDER TYPES RADIOLOGY
PATHOLOGY AND DM ME -- ALL THESE
SERVICES I HAVE INCREASING COSTS
REFORMS OVER THE YEARS HAVE NO
ADJUSTMENT FOR OVER A DECADE --
AND NO ONE EVER DETERMINE THE
RATES WERE TOO HIGH IN THE FIRST
PLACE SO.
REALLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL COALITION FOR ASSISTIVE
IN REHAB TECHNOLOGY AND CART.
WE ARE THE MANUFACTURES AND
PROVIDERS OF COMPLEX REHAB
TECHNOLOGY AND ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER THESE CUTS AND WE
APPRECIATE RIVA THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TO
NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD -- WE HEARD
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY YESTERDAY
IN OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT
THE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AND
AND AND VARIETY GROUPS THAT HAVE.
BEEN LIVING UNDER THESE CUTS FOR
A LONG TIME AND I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU THAT -- IT'S TIME
FOR THIS TO END -- AND FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL I SHOULD
THE BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR.
AND I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IN
FOR WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WILL THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION IT WAS A CHORUS
SO I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHO DID
IT SO.
I WILL CALL MISTER MAYES --
MOTION MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO -- MOTIONS TO PASS
TO PREPARATIONS MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
HI CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA
[inaudible]
Là M<c.cyan> [inaudible]</c>
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
WALDRON.
IF SEVEN BOTH BELIEVE THE BILL
ON CALL YOU'VE GOTTEN CLOSER
THAN ANYONE ELSE TO GET IN THE
BILL OUT SO I JUST MONEY YOU
KNOW THE COURAGE IN THERE SO --
MISTER GRAY.
YEAH MR GRAPH
.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVERSIDE WITH
THE RESPECT YOUR AGENDA I WILL
KEEP THIS -- FAIRLY BRIEF -- AB
SOME SIXTY THREE STANDARDIZES
PAPERWORK THAT CAN -- SO AS TO
ALLOW DOCTORS TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH KIDS IN LAST TIME WITH
PAPERWORK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE VOTE
CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE WITH
US -- TO FOLKS TO TEST BY MISTER
[inaudible]
RED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THAT ALSO IS
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
AT A BLACK FAMILY SERVICES WERE
STATEWIDE CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND CHILD WELFARE AGENCY.
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE BARRIERS ARE
AGENCY PARTICULARLY OUR
EMPLOYEES EXPERIENCE IN
PROVIDING.
DIRECT SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES DUE TO THE BURDEN SEND
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
CHILDREN COVERED UNDER MEDICARE.
WHO ARE SEEKING THE PST T.
SERVICES -- I SHOULD NOTE THAT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES
COMMISSIONED MTM SERVICES. TO
CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS OF REQUIRED
OUTPATIENT PROGRESS NO
DOCUMENTATION STANDARDS FOR SIX
COUNTIES IT INCLUDED ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA ORANGE MARIN
MONTEREY AND CINEMA.
AS WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
COMPARED IT TO THE STATES OF NEW
YORK AND MASSACHUSETTS UNDER
STATEWIDE DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS.
BASED ON THE RIGOROUS REVIEW
PROCESS UNDERTAKEN BY THE
CONSULTANTS THEY FOUND THAT
QUOTE A RELIABLE PICTURE EMERGE
OF EXCESSIVE.
DOCUMENTATION -- REQUIREMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA -- ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR
COMPLETING PAPERWORK IS FIVE
MINUTES AND IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
TWENTY MINUTES.
AS THE WHITE AGENCY WE WORK IN
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND MOST IF NOT ALL
REQUIRE DIFFERENT FORMS.
COUNTY PAPER REPORTING ACCOUNTS
440255% OF THE PROVIDERS TIME
AND THE SHEER VOLUME AND
DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION.
HAS LED TO EMPLOYEE BURNOUT --
INCREASED FRUSTRATION AND PEOPLE
LEAVING THE FIELD JUST AS WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A STATE WAGE WORK
FOR SHORTAGE.
ON THE COUNTIES IN WHICH WE
PROVIDE SERVICES -- TWO CHILDREN --
HAVE THEIR OWN UNIQUE
DOCUMENTATION DATA REQUIREMENTS
THERE ARE NO TWO COUNTIES THAT
HAVE IDENTICAL DOCUMENTATION
PACKAGES.
THE COUNTIES ARE THE REQUIRE
THEIR OWN FORMS OR A PRESCRIBED
LIST OF DATA REQUIREMENTS. FOR
AN AGENCY THAT OPERATES IN
MULTIPLE COUNTIES THIS LEADS TO
INEFFICIENCIES WITH DUNDON SEES
AND COSTLY SERVICES -- WE KNOW
THAT ARE TALENTED AND
PROFESSIONAL STAFF -- CAME INTO
THE FIELD OF SOCIAL WORK IN
PSYCHOLOGY TO PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY OF CARE FOR
PEOPLE IN CRISIS.
YET THE BURDEN SOME
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS HAS
RESULTED IN CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS NOT GETTING ACCESS
TO CRITICAL MENTAL HEARST HEALTH
SERVICES AND TO LOW MORE --
STAFF MORALE AND BURN OUT -- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR RIFLE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE COMMITTEE
IN THE CHAIR THANK YOU -- I
WANTED A URGED THE SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SIXTY THREE AS A
PRACTICING PSYCHOLOGIST I'M THE
CHIEF OF PSYCHOLOGY AT TALK
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL -- I WANTED
ADD JUST REVIEW THAT AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW ONE IN FIVE
CHILDREN SUFFER FROM A
DIAGNOSABLE MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER DURING THEIR CHILDHOOD.
AND CURRENTLY SUICIDE SERVES AS
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH OF CHILDREN TEN TO
FOURTEEN AS WELL AS FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE.
AS CHAIRMAN WOULD POINTED OUT WE
ARE -- IN A SHORTAGE OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS -- AND WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS -- LIKE CHILD
PSYCHOLOGIST TRAIN FOR ELEVEN
YEARS -- FAMOUS PEDIATRICIANS --
THERE IS A SHORTAGE THERE AND
THERE'S ONLY ABOUT -- TEN
THOUSAND LICENSE CHILD
PSYCHOLOGIST IN THE COUNTRY --
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A A RESOURCE
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO RETAIN
AND YET WHEN WE HAVE AS ARE MY
MY COLLEAGUE AS SAID -- WHEN WE
HAVE ALL OF THIS PAPERWORK IT'S
SO HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO GO INTO
PUBLIC SERVICE -- BECAUSE WE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE LOW --
AND I HAVE ALL THIS PAPERWORK ON
THERE ARE -- I'M JUST.
POINTING OUT THESE ARE JUST THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FORMS IT TAKES TO
ENROLL SOMEONE INTO TREATMENT IT
TAKES ABOUT TWO AND A HALF HOURS --
JUST TO FIND OUT IF SOMEONE AS
QUALIFIES FOR TREATMENT.
AND AS A CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST AS I
SEE A CHILD -- IN IN TREATMENT
AND DO WHAT IS THE THE EVIDENCE
BASED THING TALK TO THE CHILD TO
SUFFER DEPRESSION -- TALK TO THE
PARENTS TALKED WITH THE SCHOOL
TALK WITH THAT I HAVE -- WITH
THEIR DOCTORS IF THEY HAVE A
MEDICAL ILLNESS I HAVE TO FILL
OUT SIX DIFFERENT NOTES FOR THAT
ONE SESSION -- AND IF I GET ONE
WORD WRONG ON THOSE NOTES IT
DISQUALIFIES ALL OF THEM AND I'M
NOT PAID -- AND IN FACT ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN ANOTHER COUNTY
GOT ONE OF THEIR BILLS TONIGHT
BECAUSE THEY BUILD FOR THE TIME
THEY SPENT LISTENING TO THE
PATIENT AND NOT JUST THE TIME
THEY SPENT TALKING TO THE
PATIENT.
SO -- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TRAINING NEW NEW PROVIDERS WHICH
IS -- IMPORTANCE WE ALSO FIND --
IT THAT WE'RE SPENDING TWICE AS
LONG -- JUST TRAINING THEM HOW
TO FILL OUT PAPERWORK THIS IS
OUR MANUAL OF TEACHING THEM HOW
TO DO PAPERWORK ALONE -- IN THE
END I THINK WHAT WE FIND IS THE
PROVIDERS SPENDING TIME
SERVICING THE CHART INSTEAD OF
SERVICING THE PATIENT.
AND IF WE COULD REDUCE THE PAPER
WORK WITHOUT EVEN INCREASING THE
WORK FORCE WE COULD SERVE 30%
MORE CHILDREN.
I HAVE FIFTY KIDS ON THE WAITING
LIST RIGHT NOW -- AS YOUNG AS
SEVEN CHILDREN WITH CANCER WITH
EPILEPSY WHO ARE NEEDING
SERVICES DESPERATELY I COULD SEE
THE MALL IF I COULD REDUCE THAT
PAPERWORK THANK YOU SO MUCH I
URGE A VOTE.
YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU MAYOR MARTIN
HERE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CESSATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIELLE MAILLET CALIFORNIA
LINES OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE UNDERCARD KARBI ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HOPING TO
SEASON TO PORT.
KAMALA TRADER WITH REDWOOD
COMMUNITY SERVICES LIKE MENACING
ON HUBBLE COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
CARE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
PER SE BECAUSE HERE ON BEHALF OF
OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION.
FIVE MISTER MISTER MAYES A
SECOND I WAS TAKE YOUR CRUISE
LIKE CLOSE MISTER GRAY.
I JUST LIKE FAST DRIVER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THE BUSH THE THE BILL
HAS THE THE QUESTION IS TO PASS
A PURPOSE I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
I THINK YOU WITH BEING THIS BILL
FORD.
OF THERE'S A POINT WHICH WE CAN
DO THIS FOR ADULTS AS WELL --
BECAUSE I'M I'M I'M FAIRLY
CERTAIN THE PAPERWORK BURDEN
DOESN'T.
STOP WHEN YOU TURN.
EIGHTEEN QUESTION RIGHT RIGHT --
I SHOULD ENTERTAIN THAT IN MY
CLOTHES.
WITH RESPECT TO THE ANALYSIS AND
THE COMES ON THE ADULT
POPULATION THAT MAKES LAWCENTER.
THE ONLY CONCERN I WOULD HAVE IS
THAT WE INSURE THAT WE GET THIS
DONE IT MIGHT BE TWO SEPARATE
WORKING GROUPS IT MIGHT BE A
MATTER OF TIMING -- BUT I THINK
YOU MAKE AN EXCELLENT POINT --
AND WE SHOULD EMBRACE THAT COULD
WORK ON A POTENTIALLY THIS BILL
OR TOGETHER LATER DATE.
BUT YEAH NOT ASKING YOU TO TAKE
IT AMENDMENT JUST HOPE FOR THE
FUTURE.
FOR THOSE MAY FLOWERS TREATING
IT ALSO OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
ANCHOR CURRY.
I GOT CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA [inaudible]
THE MOST [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NEWS AREA RAMOS.
ROSS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
YES SEVEN VOTES WILL THE BILL ON
TOP DAY MISTER THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU -- SEE THIS IN THIS
WAY [inaudible] SIX IT WAS
REASONS.
I DO SEE WAS PETRIE-NORRIS.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB NINE TWENTY THE
PURPOSE.
OF THIS SPELL IS PROTECT
PATIENTS WHO ARE IN RECOVERY FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AS AMERICANS
DEPLETE CRISIS IS TRULY
STAGGERING ACCORDING TO THE CDC
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY PEOPLE DIE
IN THE UNITED STATES FROM
OPIOIDS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THIS NOW MAKES OPIATE OVERDOSE A
TOP FIVE CAUSE OF DEATH.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING AND IT EVERY
SINGLE STEP IT SEEMS THERE ARE
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS WHO ARE
PROFITEERING FROM THE SUFFERING
OF OTHERS.
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES HAVE
ENGAGED IN DECEPTIVE MARKETING
PRACTICES DOCTORS WHO HAVE
KNOWINGLY OVER PRESCRIBED THESE
DRUGS.
AN UNLICENSED RAPE
REHABILITATION CENTER OPERATORS
WHO ARE EXPLOITING PATIENTS FOR
PROFIT.
THERE IS MUCH THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THIS AREA AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF BILLS MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT ADDRESSING VARIOUS ASPECTS
OF THIS ISSUE I THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES THE NEED
FOR PRO APPROPRIATE LICENSING
AND OVERSIGHT OF FOR PROFIT DRUG
REHABILITATION CENTERS WELL
THERE ARE GOOD ACTORS IN THIS
SPACE THAT ARE DOING POSITIVE
WORK FOR THOSE SEEKING RECOVERY.
UNSCRUPULOUS OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING PATIENTS TO READ HIGH
PROFITS.
THIS HORROR STORY PLAYS OUT TIME
AND AGAIN THE PATIENT IS
RECRUITED OUT OF STATE BY A BODY
BROKER.
OUT OF NETWORK INSURANCE
POLICIES ARE PURCHASED FOR THE
PATIENT AND THEN RUN UP TO THE
TUNE OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
AFTER THIRTY SIXTY OR NINETY
DAYS.
THE I. INSURANCE RUNS OUT
PATIENT IS CURBED TURN OUT IN
THE STREETS AND EXACERBATING
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
SOMETIMES PATIENTS ARE EVEN
ENCOURAGED TO RELAPSE IN ORDER
FOR THE CYCLE TO BEGIN AGAIN.
AND THE REASON THAT THE CYCLE IS
POSSIBLE IS BECAUSE THERE'S A
TOTAL LACK OF REGULATION AND
OVERSIGHT.
CURRENTLY REHAB CENTERS THAT
SERVE SIX OR FEWER CLIENTS ARE
AND LICENSED AND ENTIRELY
UNREGULATED.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW THESE FACILITIES ARE
SPECIFICALLY TREATED AS SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENCE.
I WENT SIX PEOPLE DECIDE TO LIVE
TOGETHER IN A SOBER ENVIRONMENT
IN ORDER TO FURTHER THEIR
RECOVERY IT IS TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE TO TREAT THIS AS A
SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCE.
BUT WHEN A NETWORK EVERY HAVE
HOMES ARE OWNED AND OPERATED BY
A FOR PROFIT CORPORATION.
THIS IS NOT A HOME THIS IS NOT A
RESIDENTS THIS IS A BUSINESS.
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY AIMS TO
ADDRESS THE COMMERCIAL INCENTIVE
DRIVING THESE UNSCRUPULOUS
OPERATORS SPECIFICALLY AB NINE
TWENTY CLARIFIES THAT SIX AND
UNDER TREATMENT FACILITIES THAT
ARE PART OF A LARGER BUSINESS
NETWORK.
I EAT IN AND ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH A TREATMENT
PROVIDER THAT OWNS OR OPERATES
TWO OR MORE FACILITIES.
IS A BUSINESS IN A RESIDENTIAL
HOME.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE AND TO AS A SIDE.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
ADDRESSING MANY ASPECTS AS THE
AGREED CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A SUPPORT.
OUR TIME IT DID NOT [inaudible]
OKAY.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
MEMBERS SHARE DATA FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS.
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND DICTION FOCUSED
COUNSELORS.
AND OVER FIVE HUNDRED TRIP
PROGRAMS AND SOBER LIVING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALTHOUGH WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THE CONTENTIONS THAT.
THERE ARE ABUSES IN THE PATIENT
BROKERING ASPECT OF THE BUSINESS
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN CARE OF
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY DOES NOT
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL WE CREATE OUR MEMBERS AND
FOUND THAT OVER 90% OF THEM.
OWN MORE THAN.
ONE FACILITY OR TYPE OF FACILITY
SO IF THIS WERE TO GO INTO A
FACT WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT A
MAJOR CATASTROPHE OF
CONSTRUCTION.
AND ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES --
IT DOES MAKE SENSE FOR
BUSINESSES TO OWN MORE THAN ONE
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
IF THEY'RE GOOD AT IT IF THEY'RE
EFFECTIVE THERE SHOULD BE NO
REASON WHY THEY SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO OWN.
MORE THAN.
ONE REMOVING THEIR EIGHTY
PROTECTION IN MANY COMMUNITIES
WOULD BASICALLY PUT THEM OUT OF
BUSINESS.
SO -- THAT WOULD NOT BE A GOOD
IDEA ALSO THE CONSORTIUM OF CARE
IS A CONTINUUM SO IT MAKES SENSE
FOR A COMPANY.
TO OWN A A DETOXIFICATION CENTER
AND THEN PERHAPS AN INPATIENT
CENTER AND THEN AN OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAM AND MAYBE A
SOBER LIVING SO THAT THEY COULD
GUIDE PATIENTS THROUGH THEIR
CARE -- IN ORGANIZATIONS THEY
TRUST.
THERE'S BEEN NO STUDY TO SHOW.
THAT DO OWNERSHIP OF PROGRAMS OR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MODALITIES IS
A HARM TO THE CUSTOMERS.
WE WOULD WELCOME -- WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT SHE HAS
PRESENTED TODAY BUT AS IT IS
WRITTEN WE MUST POST THANK YOU.
OR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IN OUR PRE PACKED THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTAKE OCCUR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- SO I I AGREE THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY GOOD ACTORS OUT
THERE.
BUT THE BAD ACTORS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE SYSTEM PUTTING
PATIENTS CALL IT OF CARE AT RISK.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS -- THAT
MAY BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
IN THIS BILL THAT COULD LIMIT
ACCESS TO HOUSING FOR THESE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO EMPOWER
ANY LOCAL GROUPS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO HAVING THESE TYPES
OF FACILITIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT
I HOPE YOU CONSIDER HOW WE MIGHT
ADDRESS THAT ACCESS ISSUE MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY.
JUST RUMORS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN AND READ THE BILL HERE
IS SOME OF THE TESTIMONY AS FAR
AS SOME OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A SOME OF THE
ORDINANCES THAT PUT.
CONSTRAINTS ON THE NUMBER OF
SIZES THAT ARE THERE -- STARS TO
LOOK AT HOW SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT -- AREAS ARE SPARSELY --
IN THE DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
JURISDICTIONS OF THE CITIES THAT
ARE THERE.
AND SEEING THAT -- AND KNOWING.
THE CONCERN THAT'S THERE IS
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
SOMEWHERE FOR SOMEONE TO GO FOR
THE REHABILITATION SERVICES ARE
THERE IN THE ONGOING --
REHABILITATION SERVICES FOR THEM --
IT'S ENCOURAGING TO HEAR THAT
YOU ARE IN DIALOGUE WITH THE THE
INDUSTRY -- TRYING.
TO COME TO TERMS OF SOME OF
THOSE -- QUESTIONS ARE THERE BUT
I THINK AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION THE ORDINANCES THAT
ARE THERE ARE SOME OF THOSE
ORDINANCES A START TO PUSH --
HOUSE YOU KNOW TRANCE --
TRANSFORMATION HOUSING -- OUT
INTO SOME AREAS I THINK NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT TO I WAS SUPPORTED
TODAY -- BUT HOPEFULLY HERE THAT
THERE'S ONGOING DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY AND I'LL
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT ON BOARD AND
I THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
THAT THE AIM OF THIS BILL IS
CERTAINLY NOT TO PUT GOOD
OPERATORS OUT OF BUSINESS SO IN
THE SAME WAY THAT WHEN WE HAVE
REGULATIONS AS IN PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT FOR EVERYTHING FROM
RESTAURANTS. TO HEAR SIGNS.
TO DOCTORS OFFICES THE GOAL IS
NOT TO PUT THE GOOD ACTORS OUT
OF BUSINESS THE GOAL IS TO
PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC AND I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
CAPACITY FOR TREATMENT SERVICES
IS THIS CRISIS IS NOT YET IS NOT
GETTING BETTER AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE GOOD
CAPACITY. FOR TREATMENT SERVICES
NOT JUST SOMETHING WHERE PEOPLE
GET TRAPPED IN A CYCLE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE OTHER
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THIS IS
THAT TH LORD'S WORK -- IT IS --
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT -- I CAN
ATTEST I WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN WOULD YOU KNOW -- MY COUNTY --
WE HAD WORKED ON THIS -- YEARS
AGO -- AND I KNOW THAT AN ORANGE
COUNTY IT'S ALSO -- QUITE THE
QUITE THE PROBLEM ON THE QUITE
THE ISSUE -- AND SO KNOWING THAT
YOU'RE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU -- FOR
FOR TAKING IT IT UP -- AND AND
GOOD LUCK TO YOU AND IS THAT IF
I CAN BE SUPPORTIVE IN ANY WAY --
AND ANY INFORMATION -- I WOULD
LOVE TO I'M SURE -- THIS IS --
BUT I STILL WANT TO CALL YOU
SUPERVISOR RAMOS SO BUT MY AT
THE SUMMIT MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FROM SAM YOU KNOW COUNTY IT'LL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY A THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING A MORE FOR BILL
FORD I'M SYMPATHETIC TO CONCERNS
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS --
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THE
INDUSTRY HAS SOME PROBLEMS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED I'M WE SEEM
PROGRESS THOUGH -- WITH THE
PATIENT -- PROGRAM BILL WAS THAT
FROM LAST YEAR AND YOUR BILL OF
AB NINE NINETEEN THIS YEAR
SEEKING ACTIVE ENFORCEMENT WAS
PATIENT BROKERING.
A LAWS AND THAT BILL WAS THAT
THOSE ON CONSENT TONIGHT HOWEVER
I FIND MYSELF IN THE SAME
POSITION I HAVE BEEN OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
ON SIMILAR BILLS I CAN'T IGNORE
THE FACT THAT INDIVIDUALS
RECOVERY FROM ALCOHOL AND DRUG
DEPENDENCY PROBLEMS ARE
PROTECTED UNDER THE FEDERAL
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
AND OF AND FAIR HOUSING ACTS AS
WELL AS THE STATE'S FAIR HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT LAWS.
SO FOR THIS REASON I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY -- BUT I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF THIS CONTINUE
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO BETTER
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND PROTECTION.
OF OF RECOVERY CLIENTS WERE
PROTECTING THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THOSE SUFFERING FROM SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS -- WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE ABSOLUTELY SO I I'VE JUST
FIRST ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS
YOU RAISED IN TERMS OF POTENTIAL
CONFLICT WITH.
AND THE EIGHTY A AN FHA AND SO
WE HAS REACHED OUT TO
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WE KNOW WITH
THAT VERY QUESTION BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WHEN IT CROSSED
SOMETHING THAT.
I IS IN LINE WITH THE ADA AND
THE FHA ARE THEY SO FAR GIVEN AS
AN INFORMAL OPINION THAT EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY HAS BEEN CRAFTED.
SPECIFICALLY TO AVOID POTENTIAL
ISSUES IT'S BEEN CRAFTED VERY
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON ALCOHOL AND
AND DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY
FACILITIES.
THAT DO YOU HAVE -- THE RECOVERY
ASPECT NOT YOU'RE JUST A HOME SO
FOR THAT REASONTHEY THINK THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE FOCUSED ON
THAT PARTICULAR ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT THIS WILL IN FACT BE IN
LINE WITH THE ADA AN FHA AND
WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR THEIR
FORMAL OPINION.
TO DISSONANT THOUGHT AND
OBVIOUSLY WILL CONTINUE.
TO AS THIS BILL HOPEFULLY MOVES
THROUGH -- TO INSURE THAT WE
TAKE ON ANY NECESSARY AMENDMENTS
SO THAT IT'S NOT IN CONFLICT
WITH.
EXISTING LAW.
I'M AND I THINK WHAT I WOULD
JUST SAY IS.
I THINK THEY'RE REALLY SIMPLE
FACT IS THAT IN SO MANY WAYS I
JUST FEEL LIKE.
OUR FRAMEWORKS.
FOR TREATMENT ARE FRAMEWORKS FOR
REGULATION ARE FRAMEWORKS FOR
DEALING WITH THIS CRISIS ACROSS
THE BOARD HAVE NOT CAUGHT UP TO
THE REALITY OF WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE FACING AND WHAT WE'RE
CONFRONTING.
I'M AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU RAISED AND I
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO CRAFT A
SOLUTION THAT.
ULTIMATELY DOING WE ALL WANT TO
DO WHICH IS MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
HELPING AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE GET GET WELL AND GET
THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK SO.
I'M IT WITH THAT I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME TO ENACT
THE SAME KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
PROTECTIONS. FOR PEOPLE BATTLING
ADDICTION THAT ARE IN PLACE FOR
PATIENTS FACING ANY OTHER
MEDICAL CHALLENGE ON AN EIGHTY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU -- THERE IS A MOTION
BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISS
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASS --
CHAIR HAS A NINE RECOMMENDATION --
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD NOT VOTING WOULD NOT
VOTING MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
THE MOST MCCARTY.
THIS AREA.
RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
YOU HAVE SIX VOTES THE BILLS ON
CALL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH --
MISS RAMOS I'M SORRY MISS WICKS
EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE
POP IN THERE.
THIS CASE IS W. W. BEFORE OUR
HI.
WELCOME THANKS FOR COMING.
READY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- REQUESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE WHICH WOULD BE ONE
NICK EXCLUDING MEDI CAL FROM THE
BILL. TO DELETING REFERENCES TO
SMALL GROUP TO EXPLICITLY APPLY
THIS BILL TO LARGE GROUP
COVERAGE. THREE ADDING ADDING
THREE IVF CYCLES AND UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS --
COVERAGE LIMITATION -- FOURTH
ADDING A LIFETIME LIMITATION AND
LASTLY -- MAKE THESE CHANGES TO
BOTH HEALTH AND SAFETY INSURANCE
CODE SO I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THOSE MOMENTS.
AS REQUESTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
SO WHAT WHEN I WAS IN MY EARLY
THIRTIES.
I WAS WORKING A HUNDRED HOURS A
WEEK YEAH [inaudible]
THANKS -- TWENTY WORKING A
HUNDRED HOURS A WEEK HELPED
ELECT PRESIDENT OBAMA AND THE
LAST THING ON MY MIND WAS ON IT
WHEN I WANTED TO HAVE A FAMILY.
BUT NEVERTHELESS I VISITED A
FERTILITY DOCTOR AT THE ADVICE
OF A FRIEND -- AND I GOT THE
NEWS THAT MY FOLLICLE COUNT WAS
LOW.
AND I HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
OVARIAN DYSFUNCTION.
AND KNOWING THAT I WAS YEARS
AWAY -- FROM WANTING TO HAVE A
FAMILY MIGHT MY DOCTOR HAD
RECOMMEND FREEZING MY EGGS.
BECAUSE I WAS LIVING IN THE
STATE OF ILLINOIS.
WHICH REQUIRES I'VE YOU HAVE TO
BE COVERED BY LAW -- MY
INSURANCE WAS REQUIRED TO COVER
SALANDER WENT EGG FREEZING I WAS
LUCKY BUT NOT MANY CALIFORNIANS
HERE IN THE STATE ARE LUCKY. FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
SUFFER FROM INFERTILITY OPTIONS
ARE LIMITED ARE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE.
AND THIS BILL AIMS TO CHANGE
THAT.
IN MOST CLINICAL CONTEXT
INFERTILITY IS DEFINED AS THE
INABILITY TO BECOME PREGNANT
AFTER TWELVE MONTHS OF TRYING TO
CONCEIVE WITHOUT CONTRACEPTIVES.
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
GYNECOLOGISTS AND THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ALL
RECOGNIZE INFERTILITY IS A
DISEASE.
WELL ONE IN EIGHT COUPLES ARE
IMPACTED BY THE DISEASE AND HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING PREGNANT OR
SUSTAINING A PREGNANCY EXISTING
STATE LAW LIMITS THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THOSE SUFFERING
FROM INFERTILITY.
BY SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDING IVF
TREATMENTS.
THE STATE MANDATED EXCLUSION
EXIST DESPITE A MULTITUDE OF
EVIDENCE THAT SUGGEST THAT IVF
IS AN EFFECTIVE TREATMENT FOR
INFERTILITY INFERTILITY THAT
RESULTS IN INCREASED PREGNANCY
RATES AND LIVE BIRTH RATES.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF TWO STATES
IN THE NATION TO EXPLICITLY
EXCLUDE IVF FOR COVERAGE.
LOUISIANA IS THE OTHER STATE.
NINE OTHER STATES INCLUDE SOME
FORM OF IVF COVERAGE WE CAN JOIN
THOSE NINE STATES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THIS BY
REQUIRING LARGE GROUP PLANS TO
COVER IVF TREATMENT.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT I HAVE
AGREED TO TAKE WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE COST THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
CHAMBER OF ANALYSIS WE BELIEVE
SO SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS.
WITH THESE NARROW PROVISIONS AB
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL HELP
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF WOMEN
WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM.
INFERTILITY ACCESS INFERTILITY
IVF TREATMENT -- THROUGH THEIR
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS AND WHILE
THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT I IT'S
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO
HELP FAMILIES THAT SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED FAMILIES THAT
WANT TO HAVE CHILDREN AND I DO
BELIEVE.
FAMILIES COME IN ALL SHAPES AND
SIZES BLENDED FAMILIES ADOPTED
CHILDREN -- ALL KINDS OF WAYS
BUT IVF IS ONE WAY THAT WE CAN --
ALLOW FOLKS TO HAVE.
A FAMILY HAVE CHILDREN SO I
WOULD RESPECTIVELY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I WILL
LET ME WITNESSES SELF INTRODUCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
SUSAN WOMAN AND I'M PLEASED TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN I'VE HAD TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
PROVIDING FERTILITY CARE.
I RECENTLY RETIRED FROM THE REAP
AT THE SCIENCE CENTER IN SAN
RAMON WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST AND MOST SUCCESSFUL IVF
CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND NOW FUNCTION IN PART TIME
CRACKED A PART TIME OF ROLE AS A
CONSULTANT FOR THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER.
I SPEAK TODAY AS A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE AND A
PROFESSIONAL MEMBER OF RESOLVE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO EDUCATE
THE MEMBERS ON SOME BASIC FACTS.
FIRST INFERTILITY IS A
RECOGNIZED DISEASE OF THE
REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEM.
SECOND THE INFERTILITY IS
PREVALENT IN THE UNITED STATES
INFERTILITY AFFECTS ABOUT SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION PEOPLE OR
12% OF THE REPRODUCTIVE AGE
POPULATION.
THERE IS AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF
CONDITIONS THAT CAUSE
INFERTILITY AFFECTING BOTH MEN.
AND WOMEN.
AND THEY HAVE A WIDE RANGING
IMPLICATIONS OF HEALTH ISSUES
THAT OVERLAP WITH INFERTILITY.
THE PRESENT STATE OF OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE IS THAT IT
TREATS SOME MEDICAL CONSEQUENCES
OF THESE CONDITIONS.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO INFERTILITY
IT EXCLUDES THAT TREATMENT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW
THAT IN VITRO FERTILIZATION IS
THE STANDARD CARE FOR MEDICAL
TREATMENT OF REFRACTORY
INFERTILITY.
AND IT IS HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL. FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THIRTY YEAR OLD
WOMAN WHO UNDERGOES IVF SHE HAS
A 49% CHANCE OF LIFE BIRTH.
IN THE SECOND TREATMENT CYCLE
6169% AND A THIRD 81%.
THERE ARE FEW MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS THAT REPORT SUCH A
HIGH SUCCESS RATE.
HOWEVER LACK INSURANCE FOR THIS
MEDICAL CONDITION RELAYS THE
RESULT IN A DELAY OF EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT.
BECAUSE A WOMAN'S REPRODUCTIVE
POTENTIAL DECREASES WITH AGE
DELAYING INTERVENTION DUE TO
PERSONAL FINANCES RESULT IN A
LOWER SUCCESS RATE AND AN
OVERALL HIGHER COST PER LIVE
BIRTH.
WITHOUT INSURANCE COVERAGE
PATIENTS OPERA LESS EXPENSIVE
TREATMENTS BUT SINCE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS EFFECTIVE AND
THOSE SECONDARY OPTIONS -- SO
SEE WITH HIGHER RISK OF
COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS THE TOPIC
PREGNANCY AND MULTIPLE BIRTH.
FINALLY INSURANCE COVERAGE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH BETTER PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES LOWER HEALTH CARE COSTS
RELATED TO DELIVERY AN INFANT
CARE PRIMARILY BY FOSTERING
BETTER AND SOUND MEDICAL
PRACTICES SUCH AS SINGLE EMBRYO
TRANSFER WHICH REDUCES PRETERM
DELIVERY RATES [inaudible]
NOT.
N. MANDATED STATES WOMEN UNDER
THE AGE OF THIRTY FIVE YEARS OUR
160% MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A
SINGLE EMBRYO TRANSFER THAT A
WOMAN IN A NON MANDATED STATE.
INFERTILITY PHYSICIANS AND THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE SUPPORT
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
INFERTILITY JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
MEDICAL CONDITION.
I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
[inaudible]
EIGHTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
CINDY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CINDY
FLAN HI I AM HERE TODAY AS A
PATIENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR WHEN I WAS.
TWENTY SIX MY HUSBAND I BEGAN TO
START BEGAN TRYING TO START A
FAMILY.
WE TRIED TO CONCEIVE FOR NEARLY
A YEAR AND A HALF WITHOUT
SUCCESS BEFORE MY DOCTOR TESTED
US FOR INFERTILITY.
IT TURNED OUT THAT THE MEDICAL
CONDITION WAS IN WITH ME.
IT WAS WITH MY HUSBAND.
WE HAD EXCELLENT INSURANCE AND
ASSUME THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
TREATING A MEDICAL CONDITION OR
DISEASE.
EVERYTHING WOULD BE COVERED.
I WAKE UP CALL CAME SOON AFTER
THAT.
ONCE OUR CONDITION WAS COATED IN
THE SYSTEM AS INFERTILITY WE
WERE DONE.
OUR HEALTH PLAN.
IMMEDIATELY DID AN ABOUT FACE
AND DENIED COVERAGE TELLING US
THAT SINCE THEY DIDN'T COVER
INFERTILITY WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY
FOR ALL TREATMENTS OUT OF POCKET.
WE WERE REFERRED TO REPRODUCTIVE
AND ENDOCRINOLOGIST BUT EVEN
WITH THE REFERRAL OUR INSURANCE
WOULD NOT COVER EVEN THE COST OF
THE CONSULTATION.
EVERY TEST NEEDED FROM NOW ON
WOULD HAVE TO BE PAID OUT OF
POCKET.
EVEN IF IT WAS A TEST THAT
INSURANCE WOULD NORMALLY COVER.
BEFORE WE EVEN AT THE SPECIALIST
WE HAD ALREADY SPENT THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS.
THEN CAME THE TREATMENT OPTIONS.
ALL OF WHICH WOULD HAVE TO BE
PAID FOR OUT OF POCKET.
IN VITRO FERTILIZATION WHICH HAS
THE HIGHEST LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESS WOULD COST ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
WE SPENT THE NEXT THREE YEARS
SCRAPING TOGETHER THE MONEY TO
PAY FOR FERTILITY TREATMENTS.
EVEN THOUGH THE LINE TREATMENT
PUT US EVEN MORE AT RISK.
AFTER FOR TEN USING INTRAUTERINE
INSEMINATION AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS.
ARE DOCTOR SUGGESTED WE MOVE ON
TO IN VITRO.
I REMEMBER LOOKING AT OUR DOCTOR
THAT DAY.
AND SAYING THIS IS IT WE'RE OUT
OF MONEY.
WE'RE LITERALLY GIVING YOU ALL
THE MONEY WE HAVE.
WE HAD SPENT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OVER THE SIX YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING. TO HAVE A BABY
AND WE WERE BROKE.
OUR INSURANCE COVER NOTHING.
WE WERE LUCKY BECAUSE I LAST
CYCLE WAS SUCCESSFUL.
MY SON IS SEVEN YEARS OLD TODAY.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
GRATEFUL I AM THAT WE HAVE HIM.
STILL TODAY MY SON OFTEN ASKS
WHY HE DOESN'T HAVE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
AND WHILE YES THE ANSWER IS THAT
IT'S BECAUSE WERE INFERTILE.
THE TRUTH IS THAT WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO TREAT WHAT IS
A TREATABLE DISEASE BECAUSE
INSURANCE WON'T COVER IT.
MY STORY IS NOT UNIQUE.
OVER THE FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN
A PART OF MANY OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
I'VE BEEN A PART OF MANY
INFERTILITY SUPPORT GROUPS BOTH
VIRTUAL IN PERSON.
I HAD THE HONOR TO SUPPORT OTHER
STRIVING FOR PARENTHOOD.
MANY WHO OF WALK THE SAME PATH
AS ME.
AND HAVE NOT ENDED UP AS A
MOTHER OR FATHER.
I'VE WATCHED COUPLE SELL THEIR
HOMES.
LOSE THEIR HOMES.
BORROW FROM FAMILY.
START GO FIND THESE.
WHOLE FUNDRAISERS AND GARAGE
SALES WORK MULTIPLE JOBS.
WHEN I TOLD MY ONLINE SUPPORT
GROUPS THAT I WOULD BE
TESTIFYING TODAY?
RESPONSES INCLUDED WE WOULD NOT
HAVE THE FAMILY WE DO IF NOT FOR
MANDATED COVERAGE IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
AND THE ONLY REASON I HAVE MY
KIDS IS BECAUSE ILLINOIS AS A
MANDATE STATE.
CALIFORNIANS WONDER IF PEOPLE IN
MASSACHUSETTS AND ILLINOIS CAN
HAVE A FAMILY WHY CAN'T WE FOR I
HOPE THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
WILL STAND UP FOR US TODAY FOR
OUR DREAMS OUR HOPES.
AND YES OUR RIGHT TO HAVE A
FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS A SUPPORT.
ORGANIZATION PLEASE SHANNON
SMITH CROWLEY REPRESENTING
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL WERE CO SPONSOR.
MY NAME IS PAUL FLYNN I AM A
PATIENT AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK WERE IN SUPPORT
WE ALSO HOPE THEY FUTURE BILLS
WILL COVER MEDICARE RECIPIENTS.
THANK YOU.
I ALWAYS IT ALL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
AND CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA WILLIAMS
I'M AN IVF PATIENT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LINDA DINNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHILLINGLY BERMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER
FIALLO MáS OFFICE WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NO I BOTTOM -- WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SIR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
ALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS
REPRESENTING FORTY FIVE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
COLLECTIVELY.
DELIVER HEALTH PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE TO TWENTY FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS -- CAP MUST
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
INCREASE WILL INCREASE THE COST
OF LARGE CHECK GROUP PREMIUMS
WELL WE SYMPATHIZE WITH THIS
ISSUE -- YEAH WE HAVE A EXTREME
PRICE SENSITIVITY TO OF THE COST
OF NEW MANDATES AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE.
THE AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THIS
BILL WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED --
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES LARGE GROUP
PLANS TO OFFER COVERAGE FOR
INFERTILITY THIS APPROACH ALLOWS
EMPLOYERS -- TO PROVIDE THIS
COVERAGE TO THEIR MERRILEES IF
THEY CHOOSE -- TO YOU KNOW AND
IF IF THE AUTHOR ACCEPTS THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- THERE
WOULD NEED TO BE ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS -- TO ESTIMATE THE COST
IMPACT ON THE LARGE GROUP MARKET --
AND AS SAID EARLIER WITH OTHER
MANDATE BILLS WE JUST REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS IS THE
WRONG TIME TO ESTABLISH NEW
MANDATES FOR COVERAGE THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE TO WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AND FORTUNATELY.
WELL WE HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
EMPATHY FOR THE STORIES THAT
WE'VE ALL HEARD.
I THINK PUTTING AN ADDITIONAL
MANDATE ON LARGE GROUP EMPLOYERS
WHO VOLUNTARILY CHOOSE TO
PROVIDE HEALTHCARE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
IS CERTAINLY AT THE WRONG TIME
TO DO THAT I THINK THE ALSO
THING THAT WE'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS.
IT ME ADDITIONALLY SUBJECT THEM
TO THE EXCISE TAX IT'S DUE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IT HAS BEEN DELAYED SEVERAL
TIMES BUT THERE'S CERTAINLY A
40% EXCISE TAX IN ADDITION TO
THE CURRENT PRICES OF HEALTH
CARE IN THE LARGE GROUP MARKET.
WOULD FURTHER ENCOURAGE LARGE
EMPLOYERS TO CONSIDER SELF
INSURING AND THAT WOULD TAKE
THEM OUT OF THE OVERSIGHT OF
CALIFORNIAN PUT THEM UNDER THE
FEDERAL RESERVE RULES SO
CERTAINLY FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
CONCERNED.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT LARGE
EMPLOYERS OFTEN DO CHOOSE TO
HAVE VERY ROBUST COVERAGE AND DO
YOU AS AS THIS IS A MANDATORY
OFFERING CAN OFFER THIS IN
ADDITION TO YOU AS A WRITER ON
THEIR POLICY.
WE WILL BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND SEE IF
THERE'S SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO COME TO SOME COMMON GROUND
BUT RIGHT NOW AS IT AS A MANDATE
ON LARGE EMPLOYERS CERTAINLY A
CONCERN IN A PRICE SENSITIVITY.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH IN IT
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AND ALSO
TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
TRYING TO PURCHASE HEALTH CARE.
WE'RE INCREDIBLY PRICE SENSITIVE
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAKE HEALTHCARE AFFORDABLE FOR
EVERYONE.
OTHERS AND OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
KAREN CIRCUITS IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND IN UP AS OPPOSITION.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE F.
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
WE'D SHARE THE CONCERNS ON THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF ALL THE
MANDATES THANKS THANK YOU.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLORES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
GIVE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS BURKE.
SURPRISE SURPRISE I AM.
TWENTY YEAH SIGN AUTHOR AND AND
ALWAYS THE ONE TO MAKE COMMENTS
ON THESE ISSUES AND QUITE
FRANKLY CRY ABOUT THEM BECAUSE I
HAVE HAS.
VIA AN GREAT I'VE BEEN BLESSED
TO HAVE MY DAUGHTER AS A RESULT
OF FOR IT AS A RESULT OF IVF AND
AND LOTS OF OTHER THINGS AND
THERE IS NOT AS THEY SIT HERE
ACTUALLY WAITING FOR HER TO COME
ACROSS THE STREET FROM SCHOOL TO
SAY HI TO HER.
MONEY BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
HERE SO LATE TODAY -- I KNOW
WHAT IT MEANS TO A FAMILY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A CHILD THAT
WANTS.
ONE AND I KNOW THE STRUGGLES OF
WANTING TO HAVE A SECOND CHILD
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO MAYBE A
FOR THAT -- BECAUSE THE COST IS
SO HIGH JUST TO GET THEIR I
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
KNOW IT IS YOU HAD TO TAKE SOME
DIFFICULT AMENDMENTS.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR CONTENT
CONSIDER CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON THIS I THINK
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
AND GOD KNOWS THAT IF I HAD
KNOWN I COULD MOVE TO ANOTHER
STATE AND HAVE THEM PAY FOR IT I
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE [inaudible]
ON BUT BUT IT IS IMPORTANTAND
IT IS A QUALITY OF LIFE AND I
KNOW THAT WE ARE COST SENSITIVE
HERE BUT WE SHOULD ALSO BE
FAMILY SENSITIVE AND SENSITIVE
TO THE STRUGGLES OF OF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND OF OTHER
STATES CAN AFFORD IT I'M SURE WE
CAN.
FIND A WAY -- TO IT'S A GREAT
HONOR TO BE A MOM.
AND AND NO ONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
BETTER THAN I DO I STRUGGLED FOR
TEN YEARS TO BE HERE SO I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AN OUTLOOK
FOR DEVOTING ON THE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND AUTHORSHIP
ON THIS AS WELL [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
STRUGGLES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
AND THIS IS THE ONE AREA THAT --
I WANTED.
TO GET SOME CLARITY ON THIS IS
THAT THIS BILL DELETE SOME
EXEMPTIONS FOR THE RELIGIOUS --
ORGANIZATIONS AND FREEDOM ON
THOSE AREAS IS THERE STILL
ONGOING DIALOGUE AS FAR AS
TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT COMPONENT
OF IT.
HAPPY.
TO WELL.
HAVE YOU TO WORK WITH YOU ON
YOUR AND YOUR OFFICE ON AND CHAT
MORE ABOUT IT THANK YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THAT WITH
SHARKS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS -- I
WILL I WILL TELL YOU IN PRACTICE
OF THAT THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION BUT I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AND SOME
CONCERNS -- I'D VERY MUCH
PPRECIATE YOUR WITNESSES AND
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AND AND AND THIS AND
THE TESTIMONY THAT GOES ALONG
WITH THAT I I KNOW.
AS A PARENT -- HOW VALUABLE WITH --
THE VALUABLE BUT HOW AMAZING IT
IS TO BE A PARENT -- AND THAT'S
WHY I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE --
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT COST AND AND I
TOPSY COSTLY TO PROVIDE -- TO
PAY FOR THIS CARE BUT THERE'S
ALSO OTHER OTHER COSTS AND AND
AND A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
UNFORESEEN COSTS THAT MAY BE
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH A BENEFIT
LIKE THIS -- THERE YOU KNOW
THERE ARE RISKS OF A HIGH RISK
OF MULTIPLE PREGNANCY MULTIPLE --
HIGH RISK PREGNANCIES --
MULTIPLE BIRTHS -- PREMATURE
BIRTHS AS THE CALIFORNIA.
BENEFITS REVIEW -- PROGRAM
POINTS OUT A PARTICULAR I WITH
IVF AN OVULATION STIMULATING
MEDICATIONS INCREASE RISK OF
MULTIPLE GESTATION PREGNANCIES.
WHICH ASSOCIATE WITH AN
INCREASED RISK OF MATERNAL --
AND PERINATAL CON COMPLICATIONS
INCLUDING PER CLAMP SCEA PRETERM
BIRTH AND LOW BIRTH WEIGHT SO
THOSE.
ADD ADDITIONAL POTENTIAL COSTS
AND I'M I ONLY SEE THAT TO POINT
IT OUT BUT BUT AS I THINK.
WE CAN'T IGNORE THAT YEAH NO I I
I WOULD LET MY WITNESS BECAUSE
THE HEALTH CARE EXPERT.
THERE ARE PUBLISHED STUDIES THAT
DEMONSTRATE THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF INSURANCE
MANDAED COVERAGE FOR
INFERTILITY.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE IDEA OF
COVERAGE THEN YOU MAKE SOUND
MEDICAL DECISIONS IN IDEA
PRACTICING YOU HAVE.
A LOWER INCIDENCE OF MULTIPLE
BIRTHS A LOWER INCIDENCE OF
PRETERM BIRTH AND A LOWER
INCIDENCE OF MATERNAL
COMPLICATIONS.
SO WHAT HAPPENED OVER THE YEARS
HIS IDEA PREGNANCY RATES HAVE
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF EMBRYOS
TRANSFERRED HAS DECREASED.
BUT IN NON MANDATED STATES OKAY
THERE'S IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR
A POSITION TO WORK AGAINST THAT
PRESSURE FROM THE PATIENT WHO
THINKS THAT.
PUTTING TWO EMBRYOS BUT BACK IN
THE UNIVERSE IS BETTER THAN.
ONE BECAUSE THEY WANT THAT EXTRA
FIVE OR 7% PREGNANCY RATE WHEN
THEY'VE GOT INSURANCE COVERAGE
AND THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN TRY
AGAIN.
THEY'RE MUCH MORE WILLING TO
SPACE OUT THOSE.
THAT THAT TREATMENT OVER TIME
BECAUSE THEY KNOW ULTIMATELY
THEY'LL BECOME SUCCESSFUL.
SEVERAL PUBLISHED REPORTS THAT
CHAU PREGNANCY COMPLICATIONS ARE
REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS REDUCE
DIRECT DO.
TO DECREASED RISK OF PRETERM
DELIVERY AND THERE IS ADVANCE
ADVANCES MADE WITH EMBRYO
FREEZING.
AND WE'RE FINDING IS THAT IF WE
CAN FREE SURPLUS EMBRYOS
ENTRANCE AND THEN FROZEN CYCLE
LOWER RISK OF COMPLICATIONS IN
PREGNANCY AS WELL.
SO ARE THERE IS EXISTING STATE
REGULATIONS AROUND IVF.
THERE ARE NOT EXISTING STATE
REGULATIONS I KNOW ABOUT NUMBERS
OF ANDREAS TO TRANSFER THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY IS VERY
SENSITIVE IT TO IT AND THEY
PROMOTED AND WANTED VERY MUCH.
AND WHEN THEY HAVE THE THE
ABILITY TO ADVOCATE FOR THAT WAS
SOUND MEDICAL PRACTICE THROUGH
BETTER ABLE TO CONVINCE PATIENTS
FOLLOW THAT.
THAT SOUND MEDICAL ADVICE.
SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY LOWER RISK.
WHEN YOU HAVE A MANDATE COVERAGE
FOR IDEA?
THAT WILL TAKE TIME THOUGH --
FOUR FOUR BEHAVIORS TO CHANGE
NOW IT LOOKS IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T TAKE TIME AT ALL.
YEAH BUT THE FINISH OF YOU DON'T
WANT -- SO I SO I'M ASKING YOU
KNOW I KNOW THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL -- HAVE RECOMMENDED
GUIDELINES SO YOU HAVE
RECOMMENDED GUIDELINES FOR THIS.
ARE THERE IS THERE ANY STATE
OVERSIGHT -- FOR EXISTING --
EXISTING FOR FERTILITY CLINICS
AND CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I LOOK AT
THE CASE WE HAD YOU KNOW. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT BIRTH IN A A A BIRTH
OF A BABY SO YOU KNOW.
I JUST THINK YEAH SHE HAD
INSURANCE COVERAGE -- BUT NO
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW AREAS OF
MEDICINE THAT ACTUALLY IS
REGULATED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
EVERY CYCLE OF IVF THAT THE
START IS REPORTED TO THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL WE HAVE A
SISTER ORGANIZATION THE SOCIETY
FOR ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT MONITORS ALL THIS AND IT IS
AMAZING BECAUSE THAT THE DOCTORS
IN THIS FIELD SPECIALIZED IN
THIS.
SO THE LEARNING CURVE IS SO
DIFFERENT IN THIS AREA AND THE
ACCEPTANCE AND THAT THE CHANGE
IN PRACTICE.
IS IS SO GREAT COMPARED TO OTHER
AREAS OF MEDICINE IT DOESN'T
TAKE TEN YEARS TO MAKE A CHANGE
IN THEM THE PROFESSIONAL
GUIDELINES SO THERE REALLY.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MORE DATA
DRIVEN AREAS OF MEDICINE.
THERE ARE THERE ARE RECOMMENDED
GUIDELINES BY A SURROUND LIKE
PERSONALLY.
YEAH I WAS I BUT I WAS LOOKING
ARE THERE ANY STATE REGULATIONS
OR THE RAINY AND AND SORT YOUR
FEDERAL.
AND SO THAT MAKES ME GO BACK AND
WONDER AT SOME POINT IF.
YOU KNOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS -- THAT WE DO -- LOOK AT
POTENTIAL STATE STATE GUIDELINES
ON THIS.
I'M SORRY I THIS THIS IS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH MY
FAITH COMPLETELY IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- SPECIALLY RIGHT
NOW THE WELL.
AND AND WE'RE ALSO HAPPY TO LOOK
AT OTHER STATES AND SEE WHAT
THEY'VE ADOPTED AND AND KEEP
TALKING WITH YOUR STAFF AND YOUR
AYE NEWS YOURSELF ABOUT SOME OF
THE STUFF.
AND I GUESS AND I GUESS IT GOES
BACK TO MY ORIGINAL COMMENTS
ABOUT THE THE UNFORESEEN
POTENTIAL COST OF CARE.
OF OF OTHER CARE AS WE'RE
TRANSITIONING TO A POINT WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE MORE -- WE
HAVE COVERAGE FOR THIS -- IT'S
STILL GOING TO TAKE AWHILE
BEHAVIOR DOESN'T TRACK.
MEDICAL BEHAVIOR ISN'T CHANGED
QUICKLY I WILL TELL YOU THAT
FROM FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND SO.
SO THEY'RE STILL WILL BE THE
POTENTIAL FOR SOME OF THESE ON
FOR SEEING COSTS THAT THAT WILL
BE A PART OF THE SYSTEM.
AND SO I'M SAYING THIS I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT
I'M SAYING THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S FURTHER WORK TO DO HERE
AND AND THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
COSTS AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT -- FOR ANY OTHER
COME -- THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO AND A SECOND BY MISS
BURKE -- MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible] THIRTY THIS
AREA RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
YOUR FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL.
GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THIS RACE
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT AB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX WHICH ENSURES ADEQUATE AND
TIMELY ACCESS TO SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WERE PLACED OUT OF
COUNTY YOU SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
KNOWN AS S. T. R. T. PEAS.
BUT BEFORE I START I WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS FOR WORKING
TO MAKE THIS BILL BETTER I'M
HAPPY TO BE AMENDING.
THE BILL.
AS A RESULT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE SAM
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES SCOPE A
COMMITTEE WHICH I SHARE HAS BEEN
FOCUSING ON THE PROVISION OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
IN EBRUARY OF THIS YEAR OUR
COMMITTEE HELD AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT
THE ISSUE OF PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER.
WHICH OCCURS WHEN A YOUTH IS
PLACED OUTSIDE OF THEIR COUNTY
OF ORIGINAL JURISDICTION.
SPECIFICALLY PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER IS A PROCESS BY WHICH
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ARRANGEMENT AND PROVISION OF
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO FOSTER USE.
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY IS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE COUNTY OF
ORIGINAL JURISDICTION TO THE
COUNTY IN WHICH A YOUTH IS
PLACED.
KNOWN AS THE COUNTY OF RESIDENCE.
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE WITH OUR YOUTH STATE
COUNTY AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS WORK TO
TRANSFORM THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THROUGH CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
OR C. C. R..
A KEY TENET OF CCAR'S TO ENSURE
THAT ALL YOU'D HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW UP NOT IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING BUT IN A
LOVING FAMILY HOME THAT MEETS
THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. TO
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH.
NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH PLACED AN
OUT OF COUNTY CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS AB EIGHT TO SIX
ACCOMPLISHES SEVERAL THINGS.
FIRST IT ENSURES ADEQUATE AND
TIMELY PROVISION OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO FOSTER YOU.
BY PROVIDING FOR PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER ONLY IN CERTAIN.
SITUATIONS AND BASED ON
APPROPRIATENESS FOR THE YOUTH
SECOND IT PROVIDES A MORE
STRUCTURED UNIFORM PROCESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHEN A
COUNTY PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO FOSTER YOU.
BY REQUIRING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STANDARDIZED FORMS IMPOSING
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
IMPLEMENTING TIME LINES BY WHICH
CERTAIN TASKS MUST BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
AND THIRD IT PROMOTES
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING DH CS
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO COLLECTED MAKE AVAILABLE
CERTAIN DATA REGARDING THE
PROVISION OF SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY.
THE PURPOSE VULNERABLE YOU WITH
THE SERVICES SUPPORTS AND CARE
THAT THEY NEED TO TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD.
THAT AND LEAVE SUCCESSFUL
FULFILLING LIVES AB EIGHT TWENTY
SIX FURTHERS THIS PURPOSE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND I WANT
NO ONE TO TURN A TURNED IT OVER
TO THE WITNESS WITNESSES.
AN ELSE THAT THE SELF INTRODUCE
THE BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS KATHY CENTER L<c.cyan>G WITH</c>
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE DIRECTION THE BILL IS HEADED
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
YOUR STAFF AND THAT COMMITTEE --
STAFFER HUMAN SERVICES AS WELL
FOR WORKING THROUGH THAT
AMENDMENTS WITH OUR GROUP OF
COUNTY ASSOCIATIONS.
IT'S A REALLY CRITICAL ISSUE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
RECEIVE TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY ALL
HAVE SUFFERED TRAUMA AND NOT
JUST BECAUSE OF THE ABUSE OR
NEGLECT EVEN JUST THE REMOVAL
FROM THE HOME.
SO WE WERE PART OF THE GROUP
THAT WORKED ON AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
SUPPORTED THAT BILL.
AND IT AFFECTS BOTH FOSTER
FAMILY HOME PLACEMENTS AND
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS AND ALSO THE
S. T. R. T. P. PLACEMENTS THAT
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON THAT'S
THE AREA WHERE WE REALLY HEARD
THE CONCERNS ABOUT TIMELINESS.
AND ABOUT COMMUNICATION SO THIS
BILL REALLY SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THAT LEVEL OF ISSUE THE
AMENDMENTS -- SORT OF PUT THE
PRESUMPTION THEY MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A CLEAR REASON TO
TRANSFER THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
THAT NEW COUNTY AND THEY ENHANCE
THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN COUNTY --
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES AND
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY --
AGENCIES AND ALSO THE CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITIES THEMSELVES --
WE'RE GLAD TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M FIRMLY DATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AS MISS
SUNDERLAND INDICATED ON THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ALL OF OUR GROUPS
GOT TOGETHER WORKED ON THESE
AMENDMENTS WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE STAFF -- AND ASTHMA
CENTRALLY MENTIONED IT ALSO WILL
HELP WITH THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN COUNTIES ARE MAKE SURE
THAT CHILDREN GET TIMELY
ASSESSMENTS AND THEN THERE'S A
DATA COMPONENT THAT'S AN
ORIGINAL PART OF THE BILL THAT
WE ALL STRONGLY SUPPORT WE WANT
TO KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THESE TRANSFERS AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING -- SO WE ARE SO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE SUPPORT AS
AMENDED AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MISS RAISES THE
MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF IN A LINE
MY COMMENTS WITH THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LEE UNDER OUR
STATE AND THEN AS A FOSTER
PARENT.
IN ADOPTIVE PARENTS I SUPPORT
YOUR BILL.
THANK [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE.
THE NONE OF THAT -- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- FOR SHADE YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND SOME OF THE
MANY ISSUES WE'VE BEEN WHAT LOOK
LOOKING AT STRIVE A STRONGLY IN
OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL --
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
OF THE MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MS BURKE A SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY BUSH'S DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGAR CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA.
LIMóN MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON AYE. SEVEN WE'RE STILL
ONE SHORT OF LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
REYES READING CLOSER THERE.
WE COULD JUST KEEP PEOPLE HERE
FOR A LITTLE WHILE LONGER
[inaudible]
MR MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU ALWAYS START WITH
JUST GOING AMERICORPS ONTO WITH
AB.
TEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS A. B. TEN SIXTEEN
WILL CREATE THE RARE DISEASE
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY MOVE THE BILL --
OKAY IN LIGHT OF THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND I'LL BE
BRIEF -- CALIFORNIA WITH
ENJOYING A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE CREATED RARE
DISEASE ADVISORY COUNCILS TO
ADVISE A STATE ON RARE DISEASES
THE COUNCIL WOULD ALSO CONDUCT
RESEARCH TO INCREASE THE STATE
UNDERSTANDING OF RARE DISEASE AN
IMPROVED BUT ACCESS. TO AND
QUALITY OF CARE [inaudible]
AND WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
.
AHEAD IN START FIRST HI MY NAME
IS LEE AND ARCHDEACON.
AND I'M FROM EL DORADO HILLS.
I LIVE THERE WITH MY THREE
CHILDREN. FOR THIRTEEN YEARS MY
HUSBAND AND I WANTED TO START A
FAMILY BY MEANS OF ADOPTION.
AFTER MANY CLASSES BACKGROUND
CHECKS FROM STUDIES WE FINALLY
RECEIVED THE CALL FROM THE
SOCIAL WORKER THAT CHANGED OUR
LIVES FOREVER.
ABOUT A MONTH LATER WE FOUND
OURSELVES IN A HOSPITAL ROOM
HOLDING OUR ADOPTED NEWBORN.
BABY BOY.
WHO MEET TOGETHER NAMES AS AN
ADOPTIVE FAMILY?
ALONG WITH -- THE BIOLOGICAL
MOTHER NICOLAS.
NICOLAS CRIED UNCONTROLLABLY
WHEN THE HOSPITAL AND HE SEEMS
SLIGHTLY YELLOW.
BUT WE WERE SURE THAT THIS IS
NORMAL.
ABOUT THREE MONTHS AFTER HE WAS
BORN.
NICHOLAS GOT REALLY SICK WITH A
RESPIRATORY VIRUS.
HE SEEMED TO HAVE NEVER FULLY
RECOVERED AND CONTINUOUSLY BEING
PRESCRIBED READING TREATMENTS.
AS WELL AS NEVER ENDING
ANTIBIOTICS.
ORAL STEROIDS SEEM TO BE ENERGY
SHORTLY AFTER AND IT SEEMED TO
MAKE HIM MORE COMFORTABLE BUT
THE CRYING AND SCREAMING
CONTINUED.
I CONTINUE TO QUESTION
PEDIATRICIANS NURSES AND ANYONE
WHO WOULD JUST LISTEN TO MY
STORY.
I WAS ADVISED THAT BECAUSE I'M A
FIRST TIME MOM.
THAT THIS IS NORMAL.
WHEN NICHOLAS WAS CLOSE TO THREE
YEARS OLD?
I MADE THE DECISION TO FINALLY
SWITCHED PEDIATRICIANS.
IT WASN'T VERY LONG AFTER THAT
WE FINALLY HEARD.
A DIFFERENT DIAGNOSIS.
HIS PEDIATRICIANS RAN LABS MADE
CALLS TO HIS COLLEAGUES AND THEN
REFERRED.
US TO A GASTRO INTERNALLY JUST
IN PALO ALTO.
NICHOLAS WAS ADMITTED TO THE
GOOD SAMARITAN HOSPITAL.
INTEL HIS OXYGEN LEVELS BEGIN
STABLE AND THEN WAS REFER TO
LUCILLE PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL.
ONCOLOGY AND HEMATOLOGY.
NICHOLAS WAS DIAGNOSED SOON
AFTER WITH BETA THALASSEMIA
INTERMEDIA A BLOOD DISORDER THAT
IMPAIRS THE ABILITY.
OF THE BODY TO DELIVER OXYGEN'S
SELLS TO ITS TISSUES.
BUT WE WERE TOLD THAT SOMETHING
ELSE WASN'T RIGHT.
WE WERE ASKED TO TAKE HIM BACK
TO THE HOSPITAL FOR A LIVER
BIOPSY.
AND ANOTHER BLOOD DRAW DUE TO
HIS HIGH ENZYMES.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH JOE BEAR SYNDROME.
BOB IS CAME BACK IN THREE DAYS.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE FIRST
IT REVEALED THAT HE HAD SOME
SORT OF MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY.
SO NOT CLEAR WHICH KIND HE'D
BEEN REFERRED TO THE MDA CLINIC.
FOR FURTHER TESTING WHICH INTEL
GENETIC SEQUENCING.
AT THAT TIME TO CLOSE WAS THREE
AND A HALF YEARS OLD TO THE DATE.
HE WAS FEELING BETTER BACK TO
DAY CARE.
AND I FOUND MYSELF GROCERY
SHOPPING AND SAFE WAY.
AND MY PHONE RANG.
IT WAS THE NEUROLOGISTS TELLING
ME MRS ARCHDEACON.
YOUR SON HAS CHEN SKEWER
DYSTROPHY.
HE WILL START TO LOSE THE
ABILITY TO WALK.
HIS RESPIRATORY HOPE WILL FADE
[inaudible]
AND EVENTUALLY.
HIS HEART WE'RE GOING TO FILL
YOUR THERE IS NO CURE THERE'S NO
THERAPY.
AND ALL I CAN DO IS REFER YOU TO
CCS.
WITH THE HOPES TO BEGIN PHYSICAL
THERAPY.
JUST GO HOME AND ENJOY THE TIME
YOU HAVE WITH THEM.
THE AVERAGE LIFESPAN IS INTO THE
LATE TEENS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GROCERY STORE IN
GETTING THAT CALL.
I IMMEDIATELY FELT A LOSS FOR MY
CHILD.
AND THEN INGER.
SO LONG BECAUSE I WAS DISMISSED
AS BEING A FIRST TIME MOM.
I WENT HOME TOGETHER MY THOUGHTS
AND SORT OUT THE BEST YOU XIN
NEUROLOGISTS WHO IS LOCATED UP
ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN CINCINNATI.
WE WERE GIVEN A WEALTH OF
KNOWLEDGE AND HELP.
BUT NOT EVERYONE HAS THE OPTION
TO TRAVEL ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES FOR CARE.
MANY THINGS HAVE CHANGED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
BUT IT'S STILL SLOW PROCESS.
MANY SERVICES ARE DENIED BECAUSE
OF LACK OF KNOWLEDGE.
OF HIS COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS.
NICHOLAS HAS A MULTIPLE
SPECIALIST.
WHO WERE NOT EASY TO FIND DUE TO
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF THE
NEEDS OF RARE DISEASE?
AND DUE TO HIS NEVER ENDING
PROCESS.
IN THE NEVER ENDING PERSISTENCE
AND CARE NICHOLAS IS DOING MUCH
BETTER THAN THE AVERAGE CHILD
WITH TO SHINE.
WE WERE ACTUALLY TOLD BY THE
TIME HE WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD HE
WOULD BE ENOUGH POWER CHAIR FULL
TIME.
HE WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO RUN
JUMPERS GET.
WITH EARLY INTERVENTION AND
CONTINUE THERAPY NECKLACES
TWELVE YEARS OLD TODAY AND CAN
STILL WALK.
HE CAN RUN HE CAN SKIP HE CAN
JUMP.
AND WE WERE EXTREMELY CAUTIOUS
AS WE ARE WHERE WHAT TO LOOK FOR
WHEN HE'S.
FIFTEEN NEEDING CONSTANT BREAKS.
WHAT THIS HE HAS LAST MEDICAL
VISITS LESS NEED FOR IN HELD
MEDICATIONS AND A STABLE WITH
HIS WITH JUST A FEW MEDICATIONS?
I OFTEN THINK ABOUT WHAT IF I
WASN'T SO PERSISTENT.
WHAT IF I HAD WAITED AND WHAT IF
I LISTEN TO THESE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS?
WOULD HE BE ALIVE TODAY.
WOULD HE BE WALKING.
MOST LIKELY NOT.
HAVING A CHILD WITH MULTIPLE
RARE DISEASES IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT WHEN THOSE WHO ARE
MAKING THE DECISIONS.
DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE MEDICAL
COMPLEXITY OF LIVING WITH A RARE
DISEASE.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD MANY TIMES OVER
AND OVER THAT IF THEY CAN'T SEE
IMPROVEMENT HE WILL NO LONGER BE.
WILL NO LONGER QUALIFY FOR
THERAPY.
HIS DISEASES ARE PROGRESSIVE
THEY'RE NOT CURABLE BUT HE
DESERVES A QUALITY LIFE LIKE
EVERY OTHER PERSON.
I'VE OFTEN WISHED THAT THERE WAS
ANOTHER VOICE FOR MY SON.
AND OTHERS WHEN MAKING DECISIONS
ON SERVICES AND PROVIDED CARE.
AND I TRULY HOPE THAT WE CAN SEE
A DAY VERY SOON WHEN WE WILL
HAVE A VOICE OF UNDERSTANDING
THAT CHILDREN LIKE MINE ARE
COOKIE CUTTER.
MY HOPES ARE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
RARE DISEASE.
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN CALIFORNIA
TO HELP THE STATE UNDERSTAND THE
UNIQUE NEEDS FOR PATIENT ACCESS
TO QUALITY OF CARE AND ACCESS TO
SERVICES THAT ENSURE THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
THESE PATIENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE.
ON BEHALF OF THE RARE DISEASE
PATIENTS IN YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF AB.
TEN SIXTEEN CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL
OF IRAQ RIGHT CALIFORNIA
LICENSES ASSOCIATION WITH PROP
SPONSORED LEGISLATION AND IF I
COULD HELP SEAT THE REST OF MY
TIME AND WE HAVE.
VERY LITTLE TO IS ABOUT
[inaudible]
HEY.
MY NAME IS A BLESSING I LIVE
WITH A RATED SCENES.
ALONG WITH AND BE IF THEY AIM AT
THE MULLIN DISORDER PEOPLE WITH
AND BE A DAY.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO THAT
PARTICULAR ENZYME IN YOUR BODY.
COCKING PROGRESSIVE DAMAGING ALL
ORGANS AND THE SEVERITY OF THE
DISEASE IS DEMAND.
FOR PEOPLE I THINK THAT WOULD
AND BE AT STAKE.
LIVE AT THE SHORE FOR ME MY
GRILL.
GREEN HEART AYE BINDS LIVE WORK
JOINT.
CAN'T HEAR THE IN GAME HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED.
THERE'S NO CARE BRAND BE AT SIX
FOURTEEN TO GET TREATMENT THAT
THAT FLOW.
NO THE PROGRESSION OF TRAVEL TO
DIFFERENT.
LOCATIONS TO RAISE A WARRANT A
RARE DISEASE.
I'M NOT STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS
I'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN HELPING THE
RATE AT THIS COMMUNITY BY FANNIE.
A WARRANT A LOT OTHER BUT WE
NEED A STRONGER VOICE.
HAVING A BILL TO ESTABLISH.
A BASELINE CABALLERO ON RARE
DISEASE WILL KEEP A STRONG.
LONGER VOICE ALL PAIN FOR
FIGHTING RENDON SEES.
HOW THEY ALSO FAMILIES TO GET A
FACTOR THEY NOTE? EIGHT TO FIND
THE BEST PRACTICE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
IT BREAKS MY HEART THAT NEARLY
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ARE AFFECTED.
BY READ THE SCENE I ALSO BELIEVE
DIRECT TO SEE THAT THAT DURING
COUNCIL.
WILL BE THE START TO RACE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
PREGNANCY THEN PROBABLY WILL
SUPPORT TO PROMOTE.
MORE FAVORABLE ENVIRONMENT
ACCESS TO TREATMENT.
INDIVIDUAL.
LIVING LIVER DISEASE.
I PROBABLY KNOW THAT THIS BILL
AND THE RATE IS SEEN.
AND I THINK I WILL HAVE THE
OUTSTANDING.
TENSION.
CREATING EIGHT FRAME MORE OF
THEIR FAITH.
ALREADY SEES PATIENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO ANGELA RAMIREZ HOMES
FOUNDER PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY FOR RARE DISEASES ARE
CAL RARE WHEN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE SICKLE
CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THE BILL.
DO IT BECAUSE GROUP GARCIA --
MOTHER OF NICOLAS GARCIA TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD WITH DUCHENNE
MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY IN SUPPORT
ALSO CURE DO XIN IN SUPPORT.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF PARENT
PROJECT MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY THANK
YOU.
SIR ANYONE ELSE. THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- SPOTS A THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
IT DOES ENJOYED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU MY WITNESSES
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
WITNESSES WELL PROCEED CREATE
THAT -- THE WE HAVE A MODE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
AGUILAR CURRY A SECOND BY MISTER
SANTIAGO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA.
THE MOON MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS.
I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOUR BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IS THE
FIRST ONE OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU LET'S KEEP IT GOING ON
ALL RIGHT I GOT TO MARK YOU DO.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB.
TWELVE FORTY NINE AND I WANT TO
BEGIN -- AS MY WITNESSES ARE
COMING FORWARD BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IN MOSCOW FORM I WANT
TO THANK THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE CHAIR FOR THEIR
WORK -- I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS TO FIVE
WORKED ON THIS BILL AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THEIR INPUT THAT YOU
SEE THE MOCK UP BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WHICH PROVIDES A FOUNDATION FOR
PROGRAMS TO BUILD UPON IN THE
FUTURE.
AB TWELVE FORTY NINE REPRESENTS
AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
CONTAIN SKYROCKETING HEALTHCARE
COSTS EMPLOYERS THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES STRUGGLE TO CONTAIN
COSTS AND OBTAIN THE BEST
QUALITY OF CARE.
THERE IS A GROWING MOVEMENT
ACROSS THE NATION A PAIR AND
PLAYER HEALTH BENEFIT PLANS WITH
ORGANIZED INTEGRATED PROVIDERS.
IN A MORE ALIGNED RELATIONSHIP
TO PRODUCE BETTER CARE AT LOWER
COST THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE TWO
PILOTS ONE IN THE SOUTHERN
PORTION OF THE STATE AND THE
OTHER IN THE NORTHERN SECTION.
THAT WOULD OPERATE FOR A PERIOD
OF FIVE YEARS THE PILOTS WOULD
INCLUDE RISK BEARING PROVIDERS
THAT ARE MONITORED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
FOR FINANCIAL SOLVENCY IN
OPERATIONS.
SELF FUNDED EMPLOYER PLANS WOULD
USE REST BASED PAYMENT
MECHANISMS WITH THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR SERVICES
RATHER THAN PURE FEE FOR SERVICE
COMPENSATION.
AT THE END OF THE PERIOD THE
PARTICIPANTS WOULD REPORT ON THE
OUTCOMES CAN FORM THE
LEGISLATURE -- ON PROMISING
MODELS OF HEALTH CARE FINANCING
AND DELIVERY A STUDY BY THE UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PREDICTED THAT THIS TYPE OF
MODEL.
COULD REDUCE HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES BY AN ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED AND TEN BILLION DOLLARS
OVER TEN YEARS IT ALSO PROVIDES
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMERS LAYING
OUT A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMPONENTS
SUCH AS ACCESS TO SPECIALISTS.
PRESCRIPTION BENEFITS IN A
COMPLAINTS PROCESS THAT MUST BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
CONTRACTING PARK PROCESS FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAMS.
BIRDS COMBATING THE RISING COST
OF HEALTHCARE REQUIRES A NEW WAY
OF THINKING AND THIS PILOT
PROJECT.
AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL CAN
CHANGE THE WAY WE APPROACH
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
BECAUSE HE OF THREE WITNESSES SO
YES THE MINUTES EACH OR YOU HAVE
SIX MINUTES TOTAL SO.
SEARCH REMEMBER SCOTT WHICH I'D
LIKE TO DEFER FIRST TO GEORGE
MCGREGOR REPRESENTING.
MY CLIENT VIVA VOLUNTARY
EMPLOYEE BENEFIT ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS MADE UP OF CTA CSEA A.
F. T..
AND SIXTY FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FEVER IS
LIKE YOUR SISTER'S KIDS IT'S A
LITTLE THEY'RE JUST A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
A I REPRESENT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TEACHERS
CUSTODIANS BUS DRIVERS.
CONSUMERS OF HEALTH CARE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING THEM HIGHER
VALUE AT LOWER COST.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE STRUGGLE
WITH EVERYDAY LIFE IN THIS AREA
AND THEY NEED AS MUCH HELP AS
THEY CAN GET.
DEALING IN THE AREA OF HEALTH
CARE WHICH IS ONE OF MY CLIENT.
SPECIALIZES IN DOING. HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
BARGAINING UNITS SIXTY FIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE HAVE -- FORM SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WE HAVE OVER THIRTY
MILLION MEMBER MONTHS OF MEDICAL
COVERAGE -- UNDER OUR BELT THE
BOARD BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
OUT OF ALL OF THAT THERE IS A
BEEN ONE PHYSICIAN BANKRUPTCY
THERE ISN'T AN ONE MEMBER.
BUILD FOR CLAIMS WE INTERVENE ON
BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS AND WE
HAVE AN IDEA FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PLAN DESIGN WHICH
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE.
BY IMPROVING THE QUALITY LEADING
HIGH PERFORMING PHYSICIANS
ACTORS PHYSICIANS AND GETTING A
LOT OF MIDDLE MAN OUT OF THE WAY.
ON TO THAT CONCLUSION WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF OUR TEST PILOT
PROJECTS PAYING OFF.
OUR LAST ONE WAS THE DEVELOPMENT
OF PERFORMANCE NETWORK.
USING THE OFFICE OF PATIENT
ADVOCATE DATA.
THAT MEASURES THE QUALITY OF
PHYSICIANS GROUP WE INCENTIVIZE
FOR MEMBERS TO GO TO HIGH
PERFORMING GROUPS.
GROUPS ABOVE 90% COMPLIANCE WITH
APPROVED MEDICAL PROTOCOL.
THE FIRST YOU SAVINGS FOR THIS
POPULATION WAS FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OR 11% OF PREMIUM.
THERE ARE CURRENT PROVISIONS OF
THE KNOX KEEN ACT WHICH PROHIBIT
US.
FROM MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
NEXT GENERATION AND THE BILL
WERE ASKING YOUR SUPPORT ON
WOULD GIVE US THE ABILITY IN A
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS.
AND THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
TODAY PROBABLY CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL WITH A VIVA. FOR FOR
THOSE OF YOU ARE AWARE.
OUR TRUST FUNDS TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE TO OUR MEMBERS.
DO SO IN ONE OF TWO WAYS.
EITHER PURCHASE PRODUCTS OFF THE
SHELF FROM AGE YOU MOST.
OR SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WE
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH PROVIDER
GROUPS IN HOSPITALS.
BUILDER -- NETWORKS.
BEEN DOING IT FOR FORTY SIX
YEARS.
SUCCESSFULLY BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT ON A FEE FOR
SERVICE BASIS.
PROVIDER GROUPS LIKE THE ONES
REPRESENTED BY MISTER BARCELONA.
ARE PROHIBITED FROM DIRECTLY
CONTRACTING WITH US ON A
CAPITATED BASIS.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE US GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE GREATER
SAVINGS TO BE ABLE TO DESIGN OUR
OWN BENEFIT DESIGNS. TO UTILIZE
TO TAKE OUR OWN UTILIZATION DATA
AND MANAGE TO BRING THE BEST
COST OUTCOMES.
THERE'S BEEN TWO OBJECTIONS TO
THIS BILL THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY HEALTH ACCESS AN ORGANIZATION
ALL OF MY UNION STRONGLY SUPPORT.
FEW OF THEM SUPPORTING THIS BILL
EVEN SIT ON THE BOARD. ONE IS
THAT THE BILL DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH IN REGARDS TO CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THESE HEALTH CARE TRUSTS ARE
MANAGED BY THE UNION LEADERSHIP
OF THE LOCAL UNIONS FROM YOUR
DISTRICTS. TO SUGGEST THAT THEY
DON'T LOOK AFTER THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THEIR MEMBERS AND
DO THE VERY BEST THAT THEY CAN
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE PROTECTED
IN EVERY WAY.
JUST SIMPLY ISN'T THE CASE I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT.
SECONDLY THERE'S BEEN AN
OBJECTION SAYING THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE ADEQUATELY IN
THE EVENT THAT YOU HAVE A
PROVIDER GROUP LIKE A HOSPITAL.
GO INSOLVENT.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
NGUYEN A SELF INSURED TAFT
HARTLEY TRUST FUND.
GOES OUT AND DIRECTLY CONTRACTS
UNDER FEDERAL LAW WE MUST
INDEMNIFY ALL OF THOSE PROVIDERS.
THAT ARGUMENT IS THE REST OF
HARRY'S.
IT DOES NOT EXIST.
WE HAVE TO INDEMNIFY THE
PROVIDERS.
PLEASE VOTE YES IN THIS VERY
INNOVATIVE PILOT PROGRAM.
KITTY CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HELD OUR SALONA FOR
AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE BILL AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEC BREMBO HERE ON BEHALF OF
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATIE DEXTER VICE PRESIDENT
LIMóN GIRLS SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
AND VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS BEAVER STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL SO WHAT PROVINCE INCHES
OF HEALTH AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
HELL FOR HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE MISTER WHICH IS
KIND WORDS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE WORK ORGANIZATION DOES.
WE WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT FROM
THE BEGINNING OUR POSITION HAS
BEEN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WE
WERE NOT OPPOSED TO DIRECT
CONTRACTING WE HOWEVER WANTED TO
ASSURE.
THAT THE PHYSICIAN GROUPS THAT
WERE ALSO PARTY TO THIS PILOT
PROJECT WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE KNOX KEEN ACT.
THOSE HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
AS WE UNDERSTAND THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU THAT IS WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD ACCOMPLISH.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
VERSION THAT COMES BACK FROM
COUNSEL TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
CLEAR.
THAT THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
MANY OF WHICH WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
AND MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE SUPPORTED OVER
THE YEARS WILL CONTINUE TO BE IN
PLACE.
OUR BEEF IS IF WE HAVE ONE IS
NOT WITH THE V. BOOK OR THE
TRUST FUNDS.
IT'S WITH A PHYSICIAN GROUPS WHO
HAVE OFTEN FAILED TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THEY SHOULD HAVE.
AND SO WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS AS THE BILL MOVES FOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS EXCUSE
ME NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS -- WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THE VERSION
OF THE BILL THAT IS IN PRINT --
THE REASON THAT WE OPPOSE -- THE
BILL IN PRINT IS BECAUSE IT DOES
EXEMPT ENTITIES OPERATING IN TWO
PILOT COUNTIES FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THE KNOX KEEN ACT.
WHICH WE VIEW -- AS YOU KNOW
PUTTING ARE FULLY LICENSED
MEMBER HEALTH PLANS AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE -- VIS
A VIS OF THOSE OTHER ENTITIES
NOW THERE ARE AS THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS STATED AND THE AUTHORS
ACCEPTING EXTENSIVE AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE OUTLINED I'M IN THE
ANALYSIS -- WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE YET SO WE'D LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO DO THAT -- WE
MAY MAINTAIN OUR OPPOSE POSITION
OR WE MADE CHANGES BASED ON A
REVIEW OF THAT LANGUAGE.
AND SO -- WE RETAIN A RIGHT TO
DO SO -- AND I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU KNOW THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL FOR GIVING US CONSIDERABLE
TIME GOING OVER -- THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AND THE THE LANGUAGE --
BUT WE'RE WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE
CURRENT VERSION LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDED VERSION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
STEPHANIE WALK INS ON THE HAVE
AN ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE DO APPRECIATE THE TIME OF THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR OF GOING
THROUGH THE BILL WITH US WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS AND POTENTIALLY.
REMOVING OPPOSITION BUT THIS
TIME WE'RE SUPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THIS WATER.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T WORK?
AT OUT AT THE END OF FIVE YEARS
WE'LL WE'LL HAVE THAT DATA THEN --
MISTER BONTA AND WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS IS.
NOT GONNA BE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION ON HEALTHCARE COSTS I
MEAN THAT THE IDEA BEHIND THAT.
THE IS THIS PART PROBABLY ANY
PILOT PROGRAM -- INCLUDING THE
PROVISIONS WE HAVE ON DATA
COLLECTION WOULD BE TO REPORT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND AND
AND PROVE WITH THIS.
DATA WHAT THIS PROGRAM DID OR
DID NOT DO AND IF IT DIDN'T
DELIVER.
THAT THENWE KNOW BUT WE'VE
TRIED SOMETHING THAT I THINK IN
A WEATHER IS THE UC BERKUS I
MEAN I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THIS YEAR WHO.
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
WORK BUT ASSUMING NOT AND IT'S A
SOLUTION THAT WE WON'T THE
LEGISLATURE WON'T CONTINUE 2%.
GREAT THANK YOU.
AND I WILL TEACHERS COVERED BY
THE RUN PLANS BE MANDATED
DEPARTS PARTICIPATE THE PILOT OR
IS IT IS IT.
NOT MANDATED [inaudible]
CONCERNS.
IT'S A COLLECTIVE WORKING
PROGRAM AND IT'S VOLUNTARY IF
THE TEACHERS.
DON'T WANT TO SELECT A PLAN THAT
SIMPLY CHOOSE A DIFFERENT.
PLAN IT'S COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IS A MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S A REALLY
INNOVATIVE APPROACH.
TO REDUCE COSTS AND BOB WILL
HAVE A LOT OF BENEFITTED WILL
KNOW WHEN THE DATA COMES BACK IF
THAT'S TRUE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW AS WELL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- THIS IS
A THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH
AND AS WE STRUGGLE -- TO CONTROL
COSTS OF HEALTH -- I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THIS THIS APPROACH -- AND
THAT DOES EXACTLY THAT AND CAN
BE A MODEL FOR FUTURE PROGRAM SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD -- THE BILL DOES
ENJOY TO PASS -- RECOMMENDATION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S BEEN HEAVILY
AMENDED OBVIOUSLY -- AND THAT
WILL BE IN PRINT -- VERY SOON
FOR EVERYONE -- IT HAS A MOTION
FROM MISS BURKE A SECOND FROM
MISS -- MISS KOREA WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
MEAN I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
I THINK THIS HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY BE A GAME CHANGER I'M
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT THE STATUS
SHOWS.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE A HUGE
SUCCESS AND I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE BE VERY PROUD OF
WHAT THIS INCEPTION POINTS OUT
WITHOUT RESPECT TO REQUEST AN
IBM THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
HI.
I WORK. FOR HI CARILLO HI
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS.
FROM MOST AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOU HAVE TEN VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT ON A ROLL TO AROUND. ONE
MORE YEAH ONE MORE.
SO GET OVER CONFIDENT HERE OKAY.
I KNOW I EXACTLY I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MENTAL HEALTH IS AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF HEALTH CARE THAT IS
OFTEN OVERLOOKED ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN AND MOMS WERE WE CAN
MITIGATE -- MORE SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS THE BILL -- THANK YOU
ASKED ME MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SIX IN LIGHT OF THAT ARE
CUT THIS SHORT WOULD ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
INCREASING PREVALENCE OF MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS AND MOMS AND
CHILDREN -- AND WITH ME I HAVE
KELLY CAVE MATERNAL HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH NOW AND MELANIE
THOMAS OF PSYCHIATRISTS WITH
UCSF WILL GIVE A BRIEF TESTIMONY
AND BE ABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KELLY
O'CONNOR QUE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH NOW.
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS SUCH AS
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY AFFECT
NEARLY HALF A MILLION CHILDREN
THE HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW MOTHERS
IN CALIFORNIA EACHYEAR.
AS YOU KNOW SUICIDE RATES ARE
REACHING EPIDEMIC LEVELS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
OUR CHILDREN AND MOTHERS ARE NOT
IMMUNE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS A
SHORTAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN PARTICULAR
PSYCHIATRISTS.
THE KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
REPORTS OF THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRIC SHORTAGE
AREAS IN THE NATION.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX SIX
ADDRESS OF PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
BY BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF
FRONT LINE PROVIDERS INCLUDING
PEDIATRICIANS AND OBSTETRICIANS.
TO ASSESS AND TREAT THE MOST
COMMON MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS.
AS HIGHLIGHTED IN A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FROM THE CENTER FOR
YOUTH WELLNESS FOUNDED BY
SURGEON GENERAL DOCTOR IN THE
NINETEEN BURKE HARRIS.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE NATION
BY FOCUSING ON CHILD AND FAMILY
MENTAL HEALTH.
AS WE BEGIN SCREENING ALL
CHILDREN FOR TRAUMA.
AND SCREENING -- MOTHERS FROM
INTERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO NEED
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WILL MOST DEFINITELY INCREASE.
WHEN EARLY INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IS NOT AVAILABLE OR
SENSIBLE TO MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN'S?
FALCONS CAN BE DEVASTATING. FOR
EXAMPLE MARKET A SAND OF ALL OF
ONTARIO CALIFORNIA EXHIBIT SIGNS
OF DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY DURING
HER SECOND PREGNANCY.
DESPITE REPEATEDLY ASKING HER
DOCTOR FOR HELP.
SHE NEVER RECEIVE SERVICES.
AFTER DELIVERY HER SISTER HER
SYMPTOMS WORSEN.
WHEN SHE FINALLY RECEIVED A
REFERRAL TO A PSYCHIATRIST AT
TWO MONTHS POSTPARTUM?
SHOULD WE THREE WEEKS FOR HER
APPOINTMENT.
DURING THOSE THREE WEEKS FOR
SYMPTOMS INTENSIFIED THE POINT
WHERE SHE HAD THOUGHTS OF
HARMING HERSELF.
AND OTHERS.
IF MARKETS OBSTETRICIAN HAD BEEN
ABLE TO CONSULT WITH THE
PSYCHIATRIST DURING HER
PREGNANCY.
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN EMPOWERED TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT MARQUITA FOR
MATERNAL DEPRESSION AVOIDING
OVER HERE SIGNIFICANT SUFFERING
FOR HER FOR HER AND HER FAMILY.
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES ARE
COUNTING ON YOU TO PASS AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MELANIE THOMAS AND A PRACTICING
PSYCHIATRIST AND A FACULTY
MEMBER AT UCSF.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THE PROBLEMATIC SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
INVOLVE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX
IS MODELED AFTER THE TELEPHONE
PROVIDER TO PROVIDER
CONSULTATION PROGRAM.
IN MASSACHUSETTS REFERRED TO AS
THE MASSES HEAT MASSACHUSETTS
CHILD PSYCHIATRY ACCESS PROGRAM
CALLED MAKE PAPPA MAKE PAP FOR
MOMS.
THE MID CAP PROGRAMS HAVE PROVEN
OUTCOMES WHICH ARE PUBLISHED IN
THE ABSTRACT TRICKS IN
GYNECOLOGY JOURNAL JUST LAST
YEAR.
THE JOURNAL NOTES THAT A
PROVIDER TO PROVIDER TRIAGE AND
PSYCHIATRIC CONSULTATION MODEL
IS A QUOTE FEASIBLE ACCEPTABLE
AND SUSTAINABLE APPROACH TO
INCREASING ACCESS TO EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENTS FOR MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN.
FRONT LIGHTER FRONTLINE PROVIDER
TRADE ORGANIZATIONS ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE IN EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND TREATMENT.
AND THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS GUIDELINES NOTE THE
PEDIATRICIAN SHOULD LEARN WHAT
PSYCHIATRIC CONSULTATION IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM IN THEIR STATE.
EARLY TREATMENT BY THESE PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS IS CRITICAL TO
MITIGATE THE LONG TERM EFFECTS
OF UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS.
INCLUDING CHRONIC DEBILITATING
DISEASE AND SOMETIMES SUICIDE.
FURTHERMORE MANY OF OUR MOMS AND
CHILDREN IT WOULD ACTUALLY
PREFERRED TO CONFRONT AND
ADDRESS THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS
WITHIN THEIR ESTABLISHED PRIMARY
MEDICAL HOME.
IN MY PRACTICE I HAVE WEEKLY IF
NOT DAILY EVIDENCE FOR THE
IMPACT THAT IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
A PSYCHIATRIST CAN MAKE FOR
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
PATIENTS THEY SERVE.
JUST YESTERDAY AN OBGYN CALLING
CONTACTED ME ABOUT AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD PATIENT.
WHO HAD JUST DISCOVERED THAT
SHE'S PREGNANT ALREADY IN HER
THIRD TRIMESTER AND WAS QUITE
DEPRESSED?
I WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE REAL TIME
CONSULTATION RESULTING IN THE
OBSTETRICIAN FEELING EMPOWERED
TO FURTHER ASSESS AND THEN OFFER
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR THIS
YOUNG MOM.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE SITUATIONS
ARE ALL TOO COMMON AND OUR
CURRENT APPROACH IS FAILING THE%
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS A
SUPPORT PLEASE.
CUSTOMER CALLING WITH TWENTY
TWENTY MOM AND NAPA MOMS AND
SUPPORT.
LISA CUT OFF WITH YOUR STATE TO
A PROGRAM IN SUPPORT.
BETH STEVEN TENNESSEE THE
CALIFORNIA SECTION FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN'S HEALTH
OBSTETRIC AND NEONATAL NURSING
WERE IN SUPPORT.
BROUGH PRESERVATION CHILD
PSYCHOLOGIST AND BOARD MEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY MOM.
DOCTOR PATRICIA ROBERTS AND
GIVING OB CARE FOR FORTY THREE
YEARS TO THE WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO DESPERATELY NEED THESE
SERVICES AS PART OF MY JOB AT
UCSF A MATERNAL FETAL MEDICINE
SPECIALIST?
I TRAVELED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REAL COUNTIES WERE
OFTEN PREGNANT WOMEN OR TAKEN
OFF THE MEDICATIONS BECAUSE THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS ARE STILL
SCARED TO CONTINUE IT.
AND THEN THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
FIND PSYCHIATRY HELP POST PARTUM
WE DESPERATELY NEED THIS VIDEO
HEALTH.
IS IN TUNE WITH THE NEXT
GENERATION.
AND THEY WILL BENEFIT
TREMENDOUSLY I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY MAC MILLAN
BEHALF OF MARCH OF DIMES THANK
YOU. THIRTY ONE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN CANYON PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS -- I'M
SO SORRY I'M SORRY [inaudible]
I CAN'T.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER ALLEY
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS -- AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW
CAPS MEMBER COMPANIES CURRENTLY
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND MEDICATIONS --
AND THAT INCLUDES MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH -- IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR.
A NEW REQUIREMENT WENT INTO
EFFECT REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO HAVE A PROGRAM
IN PLACE. FOR A WOMAN TO DEAL
WITH MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH WHEN
ONE CALLS THEIR THEIR PLAN WITH
AN ISSUE IN THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
UP AND RUNNING NOW -- ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
REVIEW BOARD CHIPPER. 75% HEALTH
PLANS CURRENTLY HAVE AN EASY
CONSUL PROGRAM AVAILABLE FOR
PHYSICIANS TO ACCESS THAT THEY
NEED.
TO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
ECON SOUL PROP PROGRAM THAT MY
MEMBERS CURRENTLY UTILIZE AND
THIS BILLS THAT REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS TO HAVE SOMEBODY.
OUR READERS AND HOUSE TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE AND SO WE JUST
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE USE OF OF RESOURCES
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
IN THE STATE. TO HAVE
PSYCHIATRISTS AVAILABLE --
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR PHYSICIANS
TO CALL -- WITH QUESTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT DIFFERS FROM PLANTS ARE
CURRENT PROGRAMS IMPLANTS OR
THAT PLANTS CURRENTLY HAVE IN
PLACE -- AND SO FOR THIS REASON
WE JUST WE JUST DO NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SEVENTY ONE
CAN SOME WE HAVE A THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE TO OUR OPPOSE WE APPRECIATE
LAST YEAR WE WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO COME
UP WITH WHAT WE FELT LIKE WAS A
GOOD PLAN OF ACTION. FOR THE
PLANS TO COME UP WITH INTERNAL
PROCESSES THAT THEY WOULD
PROVIDE -- TO PROVIDERS SO THAT
WE COULD MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAD
APPROPRIATE ACCESS WITH BEST
PRACTICES IN PLACE.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A LITTLE
PREMATURE WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW IS THE MEMBERS ARE JUST IN
THE PROCESS OF PUTTING THOSE IN
PLACE WE'D LIKE TO SEE.
WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES ARE AND
MAYBE BEGIN A CONVERSATION GOING
FORWARD ABOUT?
WHAT CAN BE IMPLEMENTED WHAT
THEY'VE SEEN WHAT THE OUTCOMES
THAT THEY'VE SEEN PROVIDING
PROVIDERS WITH MORE INFORMATION
AND ACCESS SO FOR THOSE REASONS
TODAY WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL?
FOR MUCH OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WOULD
SHARE THE CONCERNS OF CAP
NECKLACE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS.
KAREN CIRCUITS YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHERE [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
NOW BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
APOLOGIZE SO.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
QUEEN.
THIS ROSA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS -- ISSUE FOR SEARS
ARE THERE STILL SOME DIALOGUE
GOING ON ARE YOU STILL
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM THE
THE OPPOSITION AS FAR AS TRYING
TO BRING SOME RESOLVE TO IT YEAH
WE ARE -- MISTRESS WERE WE'VE
WORKED REALLY WELL LAST YEAR --
TOGETHER AND I THINK WE GOT TO A
GOOD PLACE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT WE MADE SOME.
IT STOPS AND DEFINITELY A GREAT
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
OPPONENTS AND AS WE MOVE FOR
WITH THE BILL THANK YOU AND
OTHER SUPPORT TODAY AND AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING THE
RESULTS OF SOME OF THAT ONGOING
DIALOGUE GRAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MISS ROBERSON AND THANK YOU WAS
MAJOR BRING THIS BEFORE AND KNOW
THAT THIS IS AN AREA THAT YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR MANY YEARS
I'M HAPPY TO SPILLED SPORT YOU
TODAY -- THE BILL DOESN'T DO IT
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISS AGUILAR CURRY A SECOND
FOR MISS CARILLO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAN
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TONIGHT -- THEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU VERY AYE
BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE [inaudible]
HI CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING LIMóN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WATER.
YOUR FIVE LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU MISTER THANKS VERY
MUCH.
NEXT MISTER O'DONNELL. ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WHICH WILL
FACILITATE THE DELIVERY OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BY ENSURING
THAT AVAILABLE MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDS ARE USED EFFECTIVELY.
WE KNOW THAT YOUTH WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL TO ENGAGE
IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
RISK TAKING BEHAVIORS.
SCHOOLS RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS BUT GENERALLY LACK
ACCESS TO THE NECESSARY FUNDING
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
COMMISSION OVERSEES THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT OR MH ACE MH
ACE M. H. S. A. WHICH FUNDS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL THROUGH A 1% TAX.
ON PERSONAL INCOMES ABOVE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
A PORTION OF THE MH AS A FUNDS
ARE TO BE USED FOR PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
AND MANY CASES SCHOOLS ARE
UNAWARE OF THE UNAVAILABILITY OF
THESE FUNDS OR HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO ACCESS THEM TO MEET THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
OF THEIR STUDENTS THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS. TO SUPPORT COUNTIES IN
ADDRESSING KEY MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES INCLUDING SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH.
THIS BILL ALL THOSE ALSO
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP TOOLS TO INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
A MENTAL HEALTH EXPENDITURES
ACROSS OUR STATE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO UNDERSTAND MORE
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE. TO MEET LOCAL
NEEDS FINALLY AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX WILL ESTABLISH AN INNOVATION
INCUBATOR. TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TO INNOVATIVE COUNTY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS DOCTOR.
TOBY EWING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THANKS VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- TO BE DOING ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE'S NO HEALTH
COMMISSION -- THIS IS A A BILL
THAT REALLY PUTS IN PLACE THREE
STRATEGIES THAT WE THINK ARE
VERY IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE THAT WE
NEED OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
FIRST IT REQUIRES THE COMMISSION
TO PUT IN PLACE A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY -- STRATEGY WE'VE
BEGUN THAT WORK BUT IT'S WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS VERY LIMITED TO
THE M. HSA PORTION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CERTAIN MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM THAT'S ABOUT 25% OF OUR
SYSTEM WE KNOW VERY LITTLE.
ABOUT THE OTHER THREE QUARTERS
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
BUT IN ADDITION TO HAVING US --
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO INFORM
YOU AND THE PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT WORKING IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
IT ALSO EMPOWERS THE COMMISSION.
TO PUT IN PLACE STRATEGIES TO
DRIVE IMPROVEMENT.
BY FIRST SUPPORTING OUR ABILITY
TO FACILITATE INNOVATION ACROSS
COUNTY SOMETHING THAT WE STARTED
BUT THAT WE HAVE LIMITED ABILITY
TO DO IN THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
UPON THAT.
AND AND IN MANY WAYS MORE
IMPORTANTLY -- IT WOULD PUT IN
PLACE STRATEGIES FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE COUNTIES WE
SPENT TIME LAST YEAR TALKING
WITH CITY COUNTY AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS ABOUT THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES FACING OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND WHAT MANY OF THOSE OFFICIALS
SAID IS THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
PUT IN PLACE A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STRATEGY THAT CAN
HELP THEM BUILD UPON SUCCESSES
IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE AND
EXTENT OF SUCCESSES TO OTHER
AREAS.
SO WE REALLY LIKE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT COMBINES THE
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO REALLY
OUTLINED WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT WORKING.
BUT ALSO TO PUT IN PLACE THE
STRATEGIES FOR IMPROVEMENTS IN
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
VERY MUCH OTHER SUPPORT TONY TO
CARE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OLGA SHILOH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. EIGHTY ONE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT.
I DIDN'T GET A LETTER IN BUT
IT'S ON THE WAY.
THANK YOU.
IS THE CHAIR ON THE LITTLE IN
BETWEEN HERE CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND HOW THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL WORK
AND WE HOPE TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU.
VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THE NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THE BILL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF MISTER MISTER
O'DONNELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THAT'S WHEN I VOTE.
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY
MISTER FLORA AND MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES?
AFTER CURRY.
HEY HURRY I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RAMOS ROSS I RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
IF YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES WITH A
LOT OF MEMBERS THAT ARE OUT AND
ABOUT SO WILL BE THE BILL ON
CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
MR.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I WILL FIRST PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR PER SHARE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL TO
EXPEDITE MEDI CAL APPROVAL FOR
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS.
THESE ARE HEALTH CENTERS THAT
ARE GENERALLY LOCATED ON A
CAMPUS THAT PROVIDE PREVENTIVE
AND PRIMARY CARE SERVICES --
HOWEVER DESPITE THE LARGE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WERE ELIGIBLE OR
CURRENTLY COVERED BY MEDICARE.
ONLY A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THESE
HEALTH CENTERS ARE AND ROLLED
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS THIS PROVIDES
THIS POSES A BARRIER TO STUDENTS
WHO HAVE TO GO OFF CAMPUS TO
FIND A MEDICAL PROVIDER.
IN ADDITION STERN HEALTH CENTERS
ARE PERMITTED TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS TO
FAMILY PLANNING AND TIME
SENSITIVE PREGNANCY SERVICES.
BUT TO BECOME A PROVIDER OF
THOSE SERVICES THE CENTERS MUST
FIRST AND ROLE IN MEDICAL.
CURRENT LONGER THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
CURRENT LAW ESTABLISHES A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY TIME FRAME
BUT OFTENTIMES THAT PROCESS
TAKES NINE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA CREATED A
FAST TRACK ENROLLMENT PROCESS
FOR QUALIFIED PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY PUT
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS ON PAR
WITH SIMILARLY SITUATED
AFFILIATE PRIMARY CARE CLINICS
REQUIRED APPLICATIONS TO BE
PROVED WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
WITH THAT I WANT TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAUREN
CAM HANNAH I'M THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER COORDINATOR OF
STUDENT HEALTH SERVICES AT
COLUMBIA COLLEGE.
A PAST PRESIDENT OF AND CURRENT
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF THE
HEALTH SERVICES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I SPEAK FOR THIS ASSOCIATION
WHICH REPRESENTS MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FORTY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER DIRECTORS AND STAFF FROM
OUR ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ARE ORGANIZATIONS MISSION IS TO
SUPPORT AND FOSTER STUDENT
ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTH SERVICE
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
OUR WORK ADDRESSING PHYSICAL
MENTAL AND SOCIAL HEALTH IS
CRITICAL TO THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS
OF MORE THAN TWO POINT ONE
MILLION.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO BE THE
SPONSOR OF AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR PROVIDING A
FAST TRACK MEDI CAL AND FAMILY
CLAPPING ROLE IN THE PROCESS OF
ABOUT THIRTY DAYS. FOR
PARTICIPATING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY HEALTH SERVICE
PROGRAMS WILL INCENTIVIZE
CURRENT NON PARTICIPATING
COLLEGES TO ENGAGE IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS
THIS REMOVES A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO PROVIDING CARE NOT
LEAVING DESPERATELY NEEDED
REIMBURSEMENT OPPORTUNITIES ON
THE TABLE FOR SERVICES WE
ALREADY PROVIDE.
MEDIC CALIBAN WE PACKED OUR
CRITICAL FUNDING STREAMS FOR OUR
PROGRAMS WHICH STRUGGLE WITH AN
UNSTABLE FUNDING MODEL.
AS A SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT DOES
NOT RECEIVE STATE OR FEDERAL
BASELINE CATEGORICAL FUNDING
MAINTAINING BEST PRACTICE MODELS
IS CHALLENGING WITH FLUCTUATING
STUDENT HEALTH FEES WHICH ARE
NOW TWENTY ONE DOLLARS PER
SEMESTER PER STUDENT.
DUE TO VARYING ROLAND NUMBERS
THOSE FEES VARY WE HAVE I'M
GUARANTEED GRANTS I'M GUARANTEED
GENERAL FUND OR EQUITY FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS SHORTENING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FROM UPWARDS
OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND THE
COMPLICATIONS THAT TIME FRAME
PRESENTS TO ABOUT THIRTY DAYS.
WELL INCENTIVIZE MORE CENTERS TO
PARTICIPATE AND RECEIVE VITAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
PRIMARY CARE AND PREVENTIVE
SERVICES ON THEIR CAMPUSES
ESPECIALLY PREGNANCY RELATED AND
FAMILY PLANNING.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
POTENTIALLY REPRESENTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE A HEALTH
CENTER PROGRAM.
IN A SCENARIO OF UNSTABLE
FUNDING AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR
MAY ENCOURAGE THEM. TO SEE A
PATH TO INITIATE THIS VITAL
SERVICE.
AGAIN HSA CCC GLADLY SPONSORS AB
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR TERMINATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DEBORAH ROME BURKE I'M THE OWNER
AND FOUNDER OF DJ ARE HEALTH
LONG CONSULTING WHICH IS A
BOUTIQUE LAW FIRM THAT
SPECIALIZES IN HEALTH CARE
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE.
OUR CLIENTS INCLUDE MANY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS INCLUDING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS THAT OPERATE AFFILIATE
PRIMARY CARE CLINICS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM.
WE ALSO CONSULT WITH GROUPS LIKE
THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA ON POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES
RELATED TO MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT
AND LICENSURE.
SO I'M HERE TODAY SOLELY AS A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT AND HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN A
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KIM CRAIG ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN SUPPORT.
I ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SHANNON HOVIS NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LATINAS
FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SONYA COACH IVAYLO CAMPUS
ORGANIZER FOR THE JUST CARE
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF FORTY FIVE
STUDENTS FROM UC DAVIS THAT WERE
HERE EARLIER AND HAD TO LEAVE
BACK FOR CAMPUS -- ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LIBBY BENEDICT OF REPRESENTING
THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TO ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE -- THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DEUCE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THE MOST MEMBERS I GEAR CURRY.
SECOND BY MISTER RAMOS WHICH
LIKE CLOSE I JUST APPRECIATE ALL
FOLKS WERE HERE EARLIER ONE ABLE
TO STAY GIVEN THE INCREDIBLE
LINK THAT THIS YEAR IN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THEM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES AGUIAR-CURRY THANK A THREE
AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FLORA NO.
THE MOST.
MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
WALDRON. THREE WE HAVE -- THREE
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF MEMBERS.
SOMEWHERE IN THE BUILDING.
AND I'M SURE THEY'LL COME BACK
AT SOME POINT SO.
YOUR NEXT BILL SIR GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
AB SIXTEEN ELEVEN TO END
SURPRISE BILLING AND EMERGENCY
ROOMS ON THE FIRST START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
DILIGENT WORK WITH OUR OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS.
WHICH I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT TODAY.
RECENTLY POLICY MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC LEARNED ABOUT MANY MANY
STORIES OF PATIENTS AND
EMERGENCY ROOMS IN MY CITY AND
OTHERS WHO'VE BEEN CHARGED WITH
EXORBITANT BILLS DESPITE HAVING
HEALTH INSURANCE. ONE IS IF YOU
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE YOU'D
THINK THAT IF YOU NEED EMERGENCY
ROOM CARE YOU BE COVERED.
TURNS OUT THAT HAS NOT BEEN TRUE
IN.
MANY OF OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE
BROUGHT TO THE WRONG HOSPITAL
YOU COULD BE SURPRISED BY
EXORBITANT SURPRISE BILLS
BILLING.
THE BILL BEING SENT TO YOU FOR
THE BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT A
HOSPITAL WANTS TO PAY WHAT
INSURANCE HAS PAID.
IF YOU'RE INCAPACITATED OR
UNDERGOING A LIFE THREATENING
CONDITION YOU DON'T HAVE THE
WHERE WITH ALL TO DECIDE WHAT
HOSPITAL TO GO.
TO WHEN YOU'RE IN THE AMBULANCE
YOU DON'T HAVE A CHOICE OF REAR
TRANSPORTED.
TO BUT UNTIL THE STORY SURFACED
WE THOUGHT THE PRACTICE ABOUNDS
BILLING HAD BEEN ADDRESSED BY A
DECADE OLD CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT CASE.
AND A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WE PASSED AB.
SEVENTY TWO TURNS OUT THERE ARE
STILL MAJOR HOLES IN THE LAW
POTENTIALLY IMPACTING MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH DIFFERENT
TYPES OF INSURANCE. SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE INSURANCE
UNDER FEDERALLY REGULATED SELF
INSURED PLANTS.
UP TO A MILLION WHO HAVE PLANS
THAT ARE REGULATED BY CDI.
OUR BILL WOULD PROTECT PATIENTS
IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES FROM
SURPRISE BOUNCE BILLING RELATED
TO EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS.
INSURED PATIENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR INSURANCE WOULD ONLY --
WITH THEIR CO PAYMENT OR
DEDUCTIBLE WHEN RECEIVING
EMERGENCY CARE EVEN IF THE
HOSPITAL IS OUT OF NETWORK.
HOSPITALS WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO SEND THE PATIENT AN
EXORBITANT BILL AND WAR SEND
THEM TO COLLECTIONS FOR ANYTHING
BEYOND THE CO PAYMENT OR
DEDUCTIBLE. TO RECOUP OTHER CASA
HOSPITAL WOULD HAVE TO WORK IT
OUT WITH THE INSURANCE COMPANY
OUR BILL ALSO PROPOSES
STANDARDIZING THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
SO THAT THERE IS SOME
PREDICTABILITY.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE WERE MEANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO
PROVIDERS AS THAT ISSUE WAS
HANDLED IN PREVIOUS LEGISLATION.
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT SOME
TECHNICAL DRAFTING ISSUES AND I
AM COMMITTED TO REMOVING DOCTORS
OUT OF THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY A MINUTES TAKEN IN
THIS COMMITTEE WILL REMOVE THE
MEDICARE RIGHT FROM THE BILL
WHICH MEANS THE INITIAL PAYMENT
TO ANY HOSPITAL WILL BE THE
AVERAGE CONTRACTED RATES FOR
THAT REGION.
AFTER A MEDICAL EMERGENCY THE
ONLY THING A PATIENT SHOULD
WORRY ABOUT IS HOW TO GET BETTER
NOT WHETHER HOSPITAL BILL COULD
LEAD TO FINANCIAL RUIN.
WITH THAT APPRECIATE OUR
WITNESSES WERE HERE SIR FLOCKS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND BETH CAPELL WITH
HEALTH ACCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE.
BEST HELL ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
TEXAS CALIFORNIA PLEASED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT MY MORE NORMAL
ROLE OF THIS MEASURE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM BALANCE BILLING
WHEN THEY GO TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM.
THAT MAY BE OUT OF NETWORK.
AS OUR AUTHOR MISS CHIU SAID WE
HAD THOUGHT THAT THE PROSPECT
DECISION PROTECTED MOST
CONSUMERS BUT WE HAVE DISCOVERED
OVER THE YEARS THAT EVEN
CONSUMERS WHO CANNOT BE BALANCE
BUILD CAN IN FACT BE BILLED.
AND TAKEN TO COLLECTIONS EVEN IF
THEY'RE AMONG THE TEN OR TWELVE
MILLION OF US WHO HAVE COVERAGE
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
IN ADDITION AS YOU MENTIONED
THERE SEVEN MILLION OTHER
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE COVERAGE
REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE OR THERE ARE FEDERAL
FEDERALLY REGULATED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
WHO DO NOT HAVE PROTECTION ON
FROM BALANCE BILLING INDEED THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT EXPRESSLY
REQUIRES COVERAGE FOR EMERGENCY
CARE AND THEN?
EXPLICITLY ALLOWS BALANCE
BILLING FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND LAST THERE IS A STATE LAW IN
PLACE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS.
THIS IS THAT BUILT TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS.
AND WE WANT TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
NOT ONLY.
WHEN THEY GET THAT INITIAL BILL
AND MAKE SURE THEY ONLY -- THEIR
CO PAY AND DEDUCTIBLES EXACTLY
THE SAME LANGUAGE WE HADN'T AB.
SEVENTY TWO BUT ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT THE REQUIREMENT THAT
EMERGENCY CARE BE COVERED IS NOT
USED TO DRIVE UP PREMIUMS IN AN
UNTOWARD WAY.
HENCE THE USE OF THE AVERAGE
CONTRA ACTED RATE FOR THAT
SERVICE FOR THAT HEALTH PLAN FOR
THAT REGION AS THE INTERIM
STANDARD.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT
ALSO CLARIFIED THAT HOSPITALS
CONTINUE TO RETAIN THE AUTHORITY
TO ARBITRATOR LITIGATE AS THEY
CURRENTLY DO AGAINST HEALTH
PLANS.
THESE PROTECTIONS GO HAND IN
HAND WITHOUT.
WITHOUT THE SECOND PART OF IT
THE PROTECTION FROM CONSUMERS
BEING BALANCED BUILD COULD HAVE
OTHER UNTOWARD.
IMPACTS ON OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL -- AND I
WANTED TO BUILD A LITTLE BIT ON
WHAT -- HEALTHAXIS WAS SAYING
I'M GLAD THAT WE HAVE A GROWING
CONSENSUS AND YOU'LL HEAR THIS
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT WE NEED
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
PATIENTS FROM SURPRISE BILLS IN
THE ER.
I WANTED TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION CONCERN AROUND THE
DEFAULT PAYMENT RATE.
AS I SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN
EVERY DOLLAR THAT IS SPENT ON
HEALTHCARE IS A DOLLAR THAT
COMES OUT OF THE POCKET OF A
WORKER FROM A PATIENT AT
TAXPAYER OR AN EMPLOYER.
AND HEALTHCARE IS A LOT LIKE A
BALLOON IF YOU SQUEEZE ONE END
OF THE BALLOON AND PROTECT
PATIENTS FROM SURPRISE MEDICAL
BILLS IT'S GOING TO BLOW UP THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE BALLOON.
AND THOSE THAT OTHER SIDE OF THE
BALLOON IS OUR PREMIUMS.
FROM 200-022-2000.
SIXTEEN THE AVERAGE HOSPITAL
PRICES PAID INCREASED 2100%.
THOSE ARE PRICES THAT ARE
DRIVING OUR PREMIUMS WE NEED
SOME KIND OF PROTECTION A VERY
REASONABLE BALANCE SO THAT WHEN
WE'RE PROTECTING PATIENTS WERE
PROTECTING THEM IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
BUT WE'RE ALSO PROTECTING THEM
WHEN THEY GO TO PAY THEIR
MONTHLY PREMIUM.
AND SO THIS BILL I THINK THANKS
TO THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS HAS REACHED A
REASONABLE BALANCE WHERE WE
PROTECT PATIENTS WE MAKE SURE
HOSPITALS ARE ABLE TO OPERATE
AND KEEP TREATING PATIENTS.
BUT WE ALSO PROTECT THE
EMPLOYERS THE WORKERS THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING THE INCREASING COST
OF HEALTHCARE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT.
LINDA TO NARROW ITS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
PERSON I COULD ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CITY AND COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IS
PART.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICK LOUISE
US ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS WE
HAVE A SUPPORT OF IF AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE THINK THE UNDERLYING POLICY
IS VERY IMPORTANT LOOK FOR THE
BILL MOVING -- THE AUTHOR IN THE
U. SPONSORS HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN
WITH US ABOUT ON DISCUSSING
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUE THAT MY
MEMBERS OF RACE BUT LOOK FOR TO
HAVING THOSE TALKS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEVENTY WALKEN'S ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE TO HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR THE DEMOS FOR
IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACK SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO WE HAVE A THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GEN FLOOR IN BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEVEN SCHULTZ ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY WHITEN SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
JOHN WINGER ON THE F. AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
APOLOGIZED LOG IN OUR LETTER AND
ON TIME BUT WE HAVE A SIMILAR
POSTURES CAP ANAK LOOK IN OUR
SUPPORT FOR MEDI THANKS.
THANK YOU.
EVERY ARE MERITS ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IS IT IT IS EVENING.
SOON CATHERINE ALSO IT'S GOT
RISEN CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION -- WE LIKE OTHERS AT
THE TABLE AS THIS SUPPORTERS
MENTIONED AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF IN SUPPORT OF OF REMOVING THE
PATIENT FROM THE MIDDLE.
OF THE BALANCE BILLING --
SITUATION OUT WE WOULD DO
BELIEVE THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN
HOSPITAL THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE BILL THEY'RE
GOING TO RECEIVE THEY SHOULD
WORRY ABOUT THE CARE THEY'RE
GOING TO GOT.
AND THE SIMPLEST WAY TO DO THAT
IS TO LEAVE THE BILL -- TO JUST
REMOVE THAT PREVENT PROVISION --
AND NOT CONTINUE NOT TO INCLUDE
THE DEFAULT RATE WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE DEFAULT RATE FOR
HOSPITALS -- AS WE SAW IN
PREVIOUS COMMITTEES AB SEVENTY
TWO MADE SOME I'D CHANGES IN THE
SYSTEM CREATED DEFAULT RATE AND
UNFORTUNATELY CRATED -- SOME
ISSUES FOR PROVIDERS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT OUR FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS AND SYSTEM SO WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE DEFAULT RATE
COULD HAVE.
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE HOSPITALS
AS IT ROLLS FORWARD.
WE AS AS WE STE -- SAID THOSE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES COULD
CREATE AT A RATE THAT COULD
DECREASE OVER TIME I'M IN -- FOR
FOR OUR HOSPITALS WERE 38% OF
THEM ARE IN THE RED THAT'S ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOSPITALS WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES OF THAT -- WE
DO HAVE A WELL ESTABLISHED
SYSTEM. TO MANAGE THE RATE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT RELIES ON THE
REASONABLE AND CUSTOMARY
STANDARDS DEVELOPED OVER YEARS
OF COURT CASES -- AND THAT IS
USED CURRENTLY BETWEEN OUR
INSURERS AND OUR HOSPITALS THESE
ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED ENTITIES
AND WE BELIEVE CONTINUING THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE CONTINUITY
WHILE STILL GETTING THE PATIENT
OUT OF THE MIDDLE.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT TAKING THE
BENCH MARK MEDICARE RATE OUT --
WAS -- HELPFUL BUT THE AVERAGE
CONTRACT RATE REMAINING --
UNFORTUNATELY COULD CONTINUE
COULD DISCOURAGE HEALTH PLANS --
FROM CONTRACTING ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS I'M AND WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT -- OUR
HOSPITALS NEGOTIATE DISCOUNT
RATES BASED ON PATIENT VOLUME
BROUGHT BY THE PLAN -- AND WE
WILL IN THIS BILL COULD ALLOW
THOSE HOSPITALS I'M RIGHT IT
COULD DISCONTINUE THAT -- SORRY
COULD DISCONTINUE THE INCENTIVE
FOR PLANS TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND NEGOTIATE THOSE RATES BY
DRIVING THAT RATE DOWN --
UNFORTUNATELY SIX ELEVEN ALSO
INCLUDES POST STABILIZATION
RATES UP TO THE POST ABLE
EDUCATION SERVICES THESE OF THE
SERVICES AFTER THE PATIENT IS
STABILIZED AND THEN OFTEN MOVES
INTO THEIR OWN PLAN WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THOSE
CONTRACTED.
OR NON CONTRACTED RATES COULD DO
AS WELL -- AS WELL AS IT DOES
INCLUDE A RISA PLANS AS
MENTIONED AND WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LEGALITY OF
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH
CONGRESS TO ADDRESS THAT SOME
BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
STRANGELY ENOUGH IN DC -- AND WE
ARE WORKING ON THOSE EFFORTS AS
WELL THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE OF PIECES WELL AS THERE
AREN'T PROTECTIONS FOR PROVIDERS
AND THEY WERE SO PLANS AND WE
CONCERT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR ABILITY. TO FOR PROMPT
PAYMENT EXCEPT TRACK I'M THAT WE
ENJOY A THROUGH THE RICH DE MHC
SYSTEM SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS
WE CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED -- AND
LESS THE DEFAULT RATE IS TAKEN
OUT OF THE BILL THANK YOU --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IS HERE TO HELP WITH
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE PALES
REPRESENTING. TEN HOSPITALS WE
HAVE THIRTEEN HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHERE A
MAJOR PROVIDER OF SERVICES TO
MEDI CAL POPULATION ONE OF THE
LARGEST IN THE STATE -- AND WE
DO A PLAY A LOT IN THE SELF
INSURED SPACE THAT JUST TO BE
CLEAR THESE ARE -- STATE EXAM
PLANNED SO MUCH OF WHAT.
YOU DO HERE AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
THEY ARE COMPLETELY EXEMPT FROM --
NOT ALL SELF INSURED PLANS ARE
THE SAME SUMMER VERY
SOPHISTICATED OPERATORS.
IN WORK VERY MUCH OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH PLAN THEY JOIN NETWORKS
THAT HEALTH PLANS ALREADY HAVE.
PAYMENT IN THOSE SITUATIONS CAN
BE SEAMLESS IN OTHER SITUATIONS
HOWEVER IT'S MUCH DIFFERENT
WHERE WE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE A
PATIENT COM PRESENT.
SHOW WAS THE CARD THAT THEY'RE
PART OF THIS -- NETWORK THERE WE
GO THEN COLLECT FROM THE PAIR
AND THE PAY REFUSE TO PAY OUT
THAT WHAT WE BELIEVE TO BE A PRE.
NEGOTIATED RATE SO THIS IS STILL
SORT OF A BLACK BOX FOR US IN
THERE THEREFORE WE'RE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE RATE
WHAT'S LEFT OF THE RATE SETTING
PORTION OF THE BILL.
LIKE THE PREVIOUS WITNESSES WE
ARE VERY WILLING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM FOR THE PATIENT WE WILL
AGREED TO GIVE THE PATIENT THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THEY HAVE.
UNDER KNOCKS KEEN AND WE WILL
ACTUALLY TAKE THAT OBLIGATION ON
OURSELVES SO THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO GO FIND THE PAIR.
FIND OUT WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE
PAID IF THEY WERE IN NETWORK.
BILL THEM JUST FOR THAT AND THEN
COLLECTED THE REST OF THE FUND
FROM THESE THE EXEMPTS SELF
INSURED PAIR -- BUT WE STOP
SHORT OF THAT WE DON'T WANT THAT
WE WE WHILE WE'RE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO GET THE PATIENT THOSE
TYPE OF PROTECTIONS.
WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
ESSENTIALLY A FREEBIE TO WHAT
WOULD BE THE EXAM -- HEALTH AND
TO THE HEALTH HEALTH INSURER
THAT'S TAKES ADVANTAGE OF THE
SERVICES SO AGAIN -- WE'RE FINE
WITH THE PORTION THAT TAKE THE
PATIENT OUT OF THE BILLING
DISPUTE AND OFFER THEM THE SAME
PROTECTIONS.
AS CURRENT LAW BUT WE ARE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE RATE
SETTING PORTION OF THIS BILL
GIVEN THIS PAYERS PROFILE AND
FOR THOSEREASONS WE STILL
REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
OTHER SET OFF.
SHERMAN MEMBERS TOTAL SLOPE OF
THE UNITED HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE CO MISS CAUGHT AND OF MR
FULL ONTO PURPOSES ARE COMMENTS
WE REMAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU.
SEAN FLANIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
HOSPITAL CORPORATION OF AMERICA --
ABOUT FOUR HOSPITALS AND JOSE
LOS ANGELES AND RIVERSIDE -- WE
SHARE THE SAME COMMENTS AS THE
OPPONENTS.
OF HIS BILL AND OR OPPOSE IN
THIS MESSAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PERCENT SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
LINES OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE
AND STANFORD HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED POSITION.
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
SEE KNOWN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
RESTAURANTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
SPRINGING UP SOME OF THE THE
COMMENTS IN THIS YOU KNOW IT
SEEMS TO BE A A BILL THAT'S
MOVING.
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
HOWEVER THERE STILL SEEMS TO BE
A LOT OF DISCUSSION OVER THE
RATE SETTING -- ANDTHE
DIFFERENT DEFAULT RATE THAT'S
THERE.
IS THEIR CONTINUING DIALOGUE --
RATE SETTING WOULD BE AT MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
RING SOME TYPE OF STABILITY TO
THOSE AREAS.
QUESTION IS ABSOLUTELY -- ET ME
START BY GIVING A LITTLE HISTORY
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS COMMITTEE
IN OUR LEGISLATURE HAD A VERY
INTENSE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH.
SURPRISE BOUNCE BILLION IN THE
NON EMERGENCY CONTACTS AND CAME
UP WITH THE STRUCTURE THAT WAS
EMBODIED IN AB -- SEVENTY TWO
WHICH IS THE MODEL THAT WE
ATTEMPTED TO EMULATE FOR THIS
BILL -- AND SO WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS TO PROTECT THE PATIENT BUT
ALSO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS SOME
PREDICTABILITY AS TO WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT THE PAYMENTS
WOULD BE -- WITH THE CHANGES
THAT THE CHAIRMAN HAS ASKED AND
AND BY THE WAY I WOULD SAY THAT
WHEN WE STRUCTURED IT WE
STRUCTURE TO TO GIVE THE
HOSPITAL'S MORE THAN WHAT WAS
PROVIDED IN AB.
SEVENTY TWO WITH THE CHANGES
THAT -- DOCTOR WOULD HAS ASKED
US TO TAKE THAT WE HAVE AMENDED
AND THIS COMMITTEE WE'VE EVEN
MOVE FARTHER -- CLOSER TO WHERE
I THINK THE HOSPITAL'S WANT TO
GO I AM ABSOLUTE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS WILL
LIKELY NEED TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION IN PART
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD.
LITERALLY AS I SAID BEFORE IN MY
CITY ALONE THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE.
BILLS AFTER -- AFTER AN ACCIDENT
PEOPLE WHO ARE INSURED HE WENT
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM WHO HAD A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE -- BUT
YOU KNOW AND ULTIMATELY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
SEVEN MILLION INDIVIDUALS WHO
WHO MAY LIKELY FALL INTO THIS
SITUATION AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS
IT FOR THAT BUT THAT THE QUICK
ANSWER QUESTION IS YES IT.
IS THANK YOU IN A AND I DO SEE
THE PROMISE OF IT AS FAR AS THE
BILL IN AND AND AND THOSE.
COSTS COMING TO THE PATIENTS
THEIR WHEN THEY SEE THAT BILL
COMING ORWARD IT'S MORE ON THE
RATE SETTING ASPECT OF IT THAT I
THINK THERE SHOULD BE -- MORE
DIALOGUE ON AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING THAT -- COMING UP IN
THE FUTURE AND GETTING UPDATES
ON IT -- YOU KNOW TODAY IS IS IT.
IT'S LOOKING LIKE -- I WILL BE
SUPPORTED BUT I WANT TO SEE SOME
OF THAT DIALOGUE GOING ON A
KEEPING ME UPDATE OR MY OFFICE
UPDATED.
AS FAR AS HOW FAR WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD ON THE RACING COMPONENT
OF IT THE THE ASPECT IN THE
PREMISE AS FAR AS THE PATIENT
SEEN.
OUR THIS AMOUNT AFTER BEING
TREATED IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE'VE ALREADY THAT'S A PART THAT
I AGREE -- THE PART THAT WE WANT
TO LOOK AT IS THE RATE SETTING
AND LOOKING AT THAT DEFAULT AND
THEIR MEMBERS THAT WERE OFFERED
AS FAR AS TAKING TAKING THAT
BENCHMARK IN THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS OUT.
THING GOES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT CONTINUING TO LOOK
AT THE DIALOGUE MOVING FORWARD.
GREAT AND ONE OTHER THING I WANT
TO MENTION -- WE'VE AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT QUOTE IF
DISSATISFIED EITHER PARTY MAY
PURSUE ANY RIGHT REMEDY OR
PENALTY ESTABLISH UNDER ANY
OTHER APPLICABLE LAW SO IN OTHER
WORDS.
WE ENVISION IF THERE ARE ISSUES
THAT THESE COULD BE RESOLVED IN
A DIFFERENT SETTING BUT OUR HOPE
IS AGAIN THIS CREATES A
STRUCTURE -- TO RESOLVE THESE
ISSUES QUICKLY BUT AGAIN POINT
WELL TAKEN AND I WILL ABSOLUTELY --
MAKE SURE THAT I KEEP YOU
INFORMED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALSO REMEMBER. FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'LL BE
VOTING FOR YOUR BILL TODAY --
I'M A STRONG PROPONENT OF STRAW
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF PROVISIONS
TO PREVENT -- PROHIBIT BALANCE
BILLING PROTECT PATIENTS FROM
UNEXPECTED BILLS.
I DO HAVE CONCERNS OF THE RAPE
BILLING -- PIECE OF THE BILL
HOWEVER THEN AMENDMENTS ARE NEW
AND I REALLY WANT TO SPEND SOME
TIME WITH MY LOCALS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THOSE BEFORE.
I MOVE ONCE ONCE WE GET TO THE
FLOOR I WILL HAVE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION AT THAT POINT.
I WILL ADD YOU TO THAT LIST
THANK YOU.
WE CAN WE CAN HEAR YOUR VOICE
[inaudible]
FOR CLEARLY.
I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE
POINT ANYTHING I JUST WILL THANK
YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
CONSIDER A CONVERSATION ON THE
RATE SETTING OUT I'LL JUST A
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE -- JUST JUST COMMENT
OR QUESTION YOU KNOW QUESTION
HERE AND OBVIOUSLY WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOU IN THIS BILL IS
NOW SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT IN
IN A COUPLE OF AREAS.
SO I HEARD FROM MISTER PALES
REGARDING TEN HOSPITALS IN THAT
THE DESIRE TO TAKE THE PATIENT
OUT OF THIS AND SOUNDS LIKE THE
HOSPITAL THEN GOES AFTER WHOEVER
TO GET PAID.
IS THAT THE SAME GONNA BE THE
SAME FOR ALL FOUR HUNDRED AND
SOMETHING OTHER HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA WAS THAT COULD BE
JUST PECULIAR -- TO MISTER TO
MISTER THERE.
THIS IS [inaudible]
LANCE.
SO AND SO AND IF WE IF THERE IS
NO RATE COMPONENT.
HOW AND HOW DO YOU TAKE THE
PATIENT OUT TO PROTECT THE
PATIENT?
HOW DO YOU SO OUR OUR HOSPITALS
WOULD GO AFTER THE INSURERS I
THINK THAT QUESTION WE HAVE IN --
TENANTS AMENDMENTS IS HOW YOU
FIGURE OUT WHO THE INSURER IS IF
THE PATIENT ISN'T AVAILABLE TO
TELL YOU THAT SO I THINK WE NEED
TO WORK THROUGH THAT TECHNICALLY
AND I THINK WE'VE.
SEEN OTHER BILLS IN THAT SPACE --
BUT WE NOW GO AFTER.
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE IF WE HAVE A
PLACE WHERE WE'RE NOT BILLING --
THE PATIENTS WHICH THERE ARE
THERE ARE THERE'S EXISTING LAW
THEN WE GO TO THE INSURER AND
USE THE CURRENT SYSTEM TO WORK
THAT I THINK I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHICH PATIENTS WERE TALKING
ABOUT HERE AND THE ARREST SO WE
WOULD GO AFTER THE PATIENT
PROVIDES US WITH THEIR PLAN
INFORMATION WE WOULD GO AFTER
THAT BUT IF WE CAN'T BILL THE
PATIENT AT ALL.
THEN I GUESS I HAVE THE SAME
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU FIND OUT WHO THE
INSURED IT SURE IS?
OTHER THAN THE PATIENT JUST
LETTING YOU NOW.
THE SERVICE AND THEN AND IN THIS
CAPACITY I THINK THERE'SWAYS TO
DO THAT.
YEAH SO I THINK GENERALLY THE
THE WAY WE ENVISION OPERATE AND
BY THE WAY THIS IS THE WAY WE
OPERATE CURRENTLY.
IS WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL HAVE
TO FIND OUT FROM THE PATIENT.
WHO THAT -- PAYER AS WE WILL
FIND THE PAIR WE WILL FIND THE
POLICY WE'LL FIND OUT WHAT
RIGHTS THE PATIENT HAS.
UNDER THAT POLICY RELATIVE TO
EMERGENCY ROOM COVERAGE WE WILL
BAND JUST BILL -- THAT PORTION
THAT WOULD BE SPECIFIED IN THEIR
POLICY IN OTHER WORDS IF THERE
POLICY PROVIDES FOR AN IN
NETWORK CHARGE NOT TO EXCEED.
SEVEN FIFTY DOLLARS THAT'S ALL
WE WOULD BILL.
AND THEN WHAT WAS WE DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THAT BECAUSE WHAT
WE WANT TO STILL BE ABLE TO DO.
IS GO AFTER THE PAIR FOR EVER
AMOUNTS WE BELIEVE ARE CURRENTLY
DRIVEN BY THE GUIDELINES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AB SEVENTY
TWO IN THE DEFAULT RATE SENT SET
THERE.
IS THAT MATIN VARMINT YOU TALK
ABOUT KNOCKS KEEN REGULATED
PLANS.
SO THOSE THOSE HALF OR OR
PROVIDER SO THERE THERE YOU
HAPPEN NETWORK OUT US ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR A FOR EXAMPLE
A RISA PLAN THERE'S NO NETWORK
ADEQUACY REQUIREMENTS SO WITHOUT
THAT STICK.
WE WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
DEFAULT RATE IS.
IS EFFECTIVE IN ENSURING THAT
THERE'S CONTRACT CONTRACTS GOING
BOTH WAYS WHICH ULTIMATELY ON
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE PATIENT.
SKIP.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY.
UM SEVERAL POINTS MUD BUT TO
WOVEN TOGETHER HERE LET ME SAY
IT THAT WAY -- MOST AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW BETTER THAN WE
WE'VE DISCOVERED THAT MOST
BILLING DONE.
IN HEALTH CARE IS DONE
ELECTRONICALLY AND IS DONE BY A
HANDFUL OF COMPANIES.
THERE IT IS POSSIBLE TO KNOW IF
YOU KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THE
PATIENT WHO THEIR COVERAGE IS
THROUGH SO I THINK THAT'S A
WORKABLE PROBLEM BUT WE ARE
ALWAYS WILLING TO SIT DOWN AND
WORK THROUGH PRACTICAL PROBLEMS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE DEFAULT RATE
I THINK YOUR QUESTION WENT TO
THE ISSUE OF WHAT IS THE LEAST
IN A PIECE THE ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DISCOVERED IN AB SEVENTY TWO
THIS IS IN FACT.
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF LUCK
TRYING TO BILLING GOING ON
ALREADY IN THE BILLING COMPANIES
WITH RESPECT TO THE DEFAULT RATE
IS WE'VE INVOKED AB SEVENTY TWO
THE RATE THERE WAS A HUNDRED THE
GREATER OF A 125% OF MEDICARE OR
THE AVERAGE CONTRACTED RATE.
WE ARE PROPOSED TO USE THE SAME
METHODOLOGY FOR THE AVERAGE
CONTRACTED RATE HERE WHICH IS
THE AVERAGE CONTRACTED RATE. FOR
THAT SERVICE FOR THAT HEALTH
PLAN FOR THAT GEOGRAPHIC AREA WE
ARE OF COURSE ALWAYS WILLING TO
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATION --
WITH THE OPPOSITION ABOUT YOU
KNOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD AS OUR
AUTHOR HAS SENT.
I'M STILL AND IN OBVIOUS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND IT'S IT'S
COMPLICATED I'VE.
LOOK I WE LIVE TO AB SEVENTY TWO
THIS IS LIKE THE GIFT THAT KEEPS
ON GIVING QUITE FRANKLY --
BECAUSE IT IT IS HAS BECOME
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED AND THERE
ARE OTHER CHALLENGES AND AND NOW
WE'RE NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
THIS ASPECT OF IT RELATED TO
EMERGENCY CARE -- I'M JUST STILL.
MAYBE IT'S LATE AB I MY BLOOD
SUGAR IS LOW -- ALL OF THOSE
THINGS BUT I'M STILL A LITTLE
PUZZLED THAT YOU KNOW I I GUESS
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
THAT.
EVERY HOSPITAL IS GOING TO DO
LIKEWISE.
REGARDLESS AND TAKE THE PATIENT
OUT OF THIS THAT'S THAT WILL
THAT WOULD BE THE INTENT YES
EXACTLY INTENT BUT IT BUT WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW THAT ALL ALL
HOSPITALS WILL ACTUALLY DO THAT.
I I THINK THAT TO BOTH --
SPONSORED BOTH THE SPONSOR AND
THE OWES PERSPECTIVE AND THEN ON
PREVIOUS WORK WE'VE DONE -- I
DON'T KNOW MY HOSPITALS ALL OF
THEIR ELECTRONIC SYSTEMS BUT THE
IDEA WOULD YOU YOU KNOW THERE'S
DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT IF THE PATIENT.
HAS INSURANCE.
SO AND IF THEY DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE AND THERE'S CHARITY
CARE POLITIES POLICIES THAT THEY
CAN THEN VISIT BUT IF THERE
THERE'S WAYS TO FIGURE I THINK
WE WOULD WORK TO FIND THOSE WAYS
OUT I I JUST CAN'T SPEAK FOR
EVERY ELECTRONIC SYSTEM IN THAT --
TO TO ASSURE YOU TODAY THAT THEY
COULD LOOK AT ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS LIKE TEN IT DOES BUT I'M
SURE MANY OF THEM BEHIND ME
RIGHT NOW ARE NODDING THAT THEY
DO THAT ALREADY.
I GUESS BECAUSE THE INTENT OF
THE BILL WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE
IS TO GET THE PAY IS NOT MAKE
SURE THAT THE PAIN WE ARE OUT OF
THIS AND AND SO -- SO I HEAR
THAT ONE HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
KIND OF DOES THAT ALREADY.
YEAH SOUNDS LIKE IT I JUST
DIDN'T HAVE ASSURANCE FROM EVERY
SYSTEM AS I WALKED UP HERE THAT
THEY HAVE THE SYSTEM BUT I I
HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING THAT
THEY HAVE THEY COULDN'T FIGURE
IT OUT SO TO GET THE PATIENT ON
THE METAL.
I THINK OUR BIGGEST STRUGGLE
LIKE WE SAID IS THAT DEFAULT
RATE SO THEN WHEN SO NOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE HOSPITAL NOW
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEIR
REGIONAL RATE IS -- FOR THE PLAN
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
BUILDING IS GOING TO BE IN A
SIMILAR KNOWLEDGE I THINK THERE
IS A MYTH METHODOLOGY FOR THAT
AND AND I THINK OUR CONCERN IS
THAT IT'S GOING TO DRIVE THREE
TIMES BUT WE WE DON'T HAVE TO
REHASH THAT.
ONE SO OKAY WELL.
BUT ALSO CASH OBVIOUSLY THERE
ISN'T ANY RESIDUE AYE I KNOW THE
AUTHORS COMMITTED TO AND I KNOW
THAT THEIR WE CONTINUE COULD
DISCUSSIONS.
AND I PLAN TO FOLLOW THEM VERY
CLOSELY.
SO -- SO I THEBILL DOES HAVE A
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDATION --
DOUBLE OR QUESTIONS.
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION YET AS
FAR AS OF MOTION.
OKAY MOTION BY MISTER MCCARTY
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO -- MADAM
SECRETARY.
WELL WELL WAIT A SECOND.
MR TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I'M SORRY IT'S HOURS ARE.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION THE COMMITTEE --
ALSO VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR YOUR INVOLVING OF THIS --
OVER THE RECESS LAST WEEK WHAT
WE ABOUT TRAVELING -- AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION -- TO
TO THE HOSPITAL WORLD I ACTUALLY
HAD THIS VERY CONVERSATION WITH
MR PASSED YESTERDAY I THINK WHAT
TEN IT IS DOING IS A GOOD MODEL --
AND IT WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW IF
IF OTHERS WOULD BE ABLE -- TO TO
ABIDE BY THAT BUT VERY MUCH LOOK
FOR TO OTHER CONVERSATIONS I
WOULD JUST SAY THE END OF THE
DAY WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE ON IS THAT THE
POTENTIAL SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO COULD BE IN
THIS SITUATION BECAUSE THEY GET
INTO THE WRONG.
AMBULANCE AND UP IN THE WRONG
EMERGENCY ROOM THEY HAPPEN TO
HAVE THE WRONG INSURANCE THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW THEM TO GET
COVERAGE THAT'S WERE TRYING TO
HELP HERE AND I KNOW WE ALL
AGREE ON THAT AND OUR HOPE IS --
IN THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS
WE CAN FIGURE OUT THE OTHER
DETAILS TO IT TO GET THE STOCK
SO WITH THAT VERY MUCH.
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WITHOUT MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WHAT WOULD I MAYES?
MAYES NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
I CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING Là M<c.cyan></c>
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THE I. IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS.
PROMISE I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ.
FIVE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
OLDER.
YES SEVEN VOTES WILL BE THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
WHAT?
NOT SEEING IT MISTER KILEY WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
FORTY EIGHT A. B..
SIXTEEN NINETEEN DOT TO EVER
.
TALK TO EVER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT I WALKED IN AT THE
OPPORTUNE TIME.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING IN A
COMMITTEE FOR QUORUM ALL DAY --
AB SIXTY NINETY MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT. SIXTEEN NINETEEN MENTAL
HEALTH CAREERS UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES FUNDING.
AND AB SIXTEEN NINETEEN
APPROPRIATES TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF REDUCING THE
SHORTAGE OF ANNA DISPARITY IN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACROSS
THE STATE.
WELL ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE IN CALIFORNIA WAS BOLSTERED
BY THE PASSAGE OF THE ACA MANY
PATIENTS ARE STILL LEFT UNSERVED
DUE TO THE DRASTIC SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
CURRENTLY PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA THE NUMBER BECOMES
EVEN FEWER WHEN IDENTIFYING
MENTAL HEALTH.
PROVIDERS OF COLOR THAT GREW UP
IN LOW INCOME OR RULE
COMMUNITIES STUDIES SHOW THAT
STUDENTS WHO GREW UP IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SET UP.
PRACTICE IN THE AREA WHERE THEY
BECOME PHYSICIANS DENTIST OR
OTHER HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AB SIXTY NINETEEN CAPITALIZE ON
THIS TRAIN BY CREATING AN
OUTREACH PROGRAM TO ATTRACTED
RECOUP STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
AN UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
AND TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSION AND INCREASING
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO GIVE BACK
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE WITH ME JEFF AUSTIN DON
WHO'S A CO DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME I'M JEFF OXEN NINE AM --
HAS SERVED AS THE CO DIRECTOR
THE FUTURE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION THE
COMMERCIAL COMMISSION WAS FUNDED%
BY THE STATE'S FIVE LARGEST
HEALTH FOUNDATIONS AND SPENT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
DEVELOPING RECOMMENDATIONS TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT AND
EMERGING HEALTH WORKFORCE NEEDS
THE COMMISSION WAS CHAIRED BY
JANET POLITICIAN OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UC SYSTEM IN
LLOYD DEAN THAT CEO OF DIGNITY
HEALTH AND HAD.
TWENTY FOUR THIS TEAM LEADERS
INCLUDING ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD --
THE COMMISSION COMPLETED ITS
REPORT WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
AND FILL GAPS BY TWENTY THIRTY
IN THE REPORT WAS COMPLETED IN
FEBRUARY.
THE COMMISSION DID NOT TAKE A
POSITION ON LEGISLATION AND I'M
NOT HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
COMMISSION I'M HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE.
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE BASED ON MY
WORK WITH THE COMMISSION.
AND MY OVER THIRTY YEARS OF WORK --
LEADING A NEW STATEWIDE HEALTH
PIPELINE PROGRAM FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS GETTING IN THE HEALTH
CAREERS AS WELL AS BEING A
FACULTY MEMBER AT UC BERKELEY
AND A STATE WIDE.
HEALTH WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
COALITION LEADER -- BECAUSE OF
THE SEVERE AND GROWING SHORTAGES
IN OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK
FORCE THE COMMISSION PRIORITIZED --
MEETING OR MENTAL HEALTH WORK
FORCE NEEDS AS ONE THE TOP --
THREE PRIORITIES AMONG ALL THE
DIFFERENT HEALTH PROFESSIONS.
AND WE APPLAUD AND THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING ACTION TO ADDRESS
THIS BEHAVIOR HEALTH CRISIS.
IT WILL NOT SELF CORRECT AND WE
NEED SIGNIFICANT ACTION
INVESTMENT NOW IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR FUTURE NEEDS -- THESE THIS
CRISIS HAS BEEN AROUND FOR A
LONG TIME IT'S ONLY WORSENING --
WE HAVE SEVERE SHORTAGES SUPPLY
DISTRIBUTION -- DIVERSITY --
CHALLENGES THAT ARE ONLY
PROJECTED TO WORSEN THE NEXT
DECADE AND BEYOND.
WE ONLY HAVE TWO THIRDS OF THE
PSYCHIATRISTS.
THAT WE NEED OVERALL.
I ALSO HAVE GROWING NEEDS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL WORK OTHER
MANY OTHER AT THERAPISTS. EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSION
SHORTAGE AREAS -- AND THE NEED
IS GREATER THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
BUT IN PARTICULAR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THE INLAND EMPIRE.
A LOS ANGELES IN IN ALL OF THE
RURAL AREAS AND DIVERSITY IN
CULTURAL LINGUISTIC COMPETENCE.
ARE REALLY A KEY CHALLENGE --
ONLY 5% OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN THE
LA AREA FOR EXAMPLE ARE LATINO
ALMOST 50% OF THE POPULATION.
AN AFRICAN AMERICANS NATIVE
AMERICANS AND MANY OTHER
POPULATIONS ARE DEFINITELY UNDER
REPRESENTED -- SO THE THE BOTTOM
LINE HERE IS THAT WE HAVE ALMOST
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS YOU
AREN'T GETTING THE TREATMENT
THAT THEY NEED IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH -- ARE FAR CANCER
FOUNDATION A POLL IN JANUARY
IDENTIFIED THAT. NINE OUT OF TEN
PEOPLE.
SAY THE GETTING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT A POLICY PRIORITY.
AND HAVE THE CALIFORNIANS DON'T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE ENOUGH WORKERS
IN THERE CAN BE SO THIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS REALLY.
A CRITICAL TO BUILD THE PIPELINE --
STARTING K. THROUGH TWELVE
COMMUNICABLE EDGE FOR YOUR
COLLEGE TO ENABLE STUDENTS TO
GET INTO THE SELF CAREERS AND BE
THAT FUTURE HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COME BACK AND SERVE IN
THE AREAS THAT THEY ARE FROM.
A FINAL EXAMPLE DOCTOR
IMMEDIATELY MON RUCKER IS THE
PRODUCT OF PIPELINE PROGRAMS.
LIKE THE ONES BEING PROPOSED
HERE.
WHO IS NOW A CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST
AND?
SHOWS.
TO COME BACK AFTER COMPLETELY
WRECK WRAP UP OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS GREAT THOSE QUICK THOSE
OKAY.
YOU KNOW SO.
ANYWAY.
EASY EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE REALLY
WANT.
THIS IS A COMEBACK CONCERT FOR
THIS.
THIS IS FOR THIS IS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO
WITH OTHER WITNESSES -- IN
SUPPORT [inaudible] FOR THANK
YOU.
RENDON MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES HERE WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THEY WERE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAME NUMBER COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE DID HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISTER FLORA WOULD DO WE
HAVE A SECOND.
OF SECOND FROM -- REPUBLICAN
LEADER WALDRON AND THE DOCTOR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE JUST SIMPLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAH I VOTE
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT EFFORT TO
RECRUIT INDIVIDUALS INTO THIS
FIELD AND I THINK WE ALL BENEFIT
FROM HAVING THEM.
SERVE THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES A
GIVEN THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU DOCTOR.
AT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
PROCREATION WOULD.
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE ANGER HURRY.
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE CARRILLO.
FLORA.
FLORA I LIMóN MCCARTY.
THE I NAZARIAN ROSS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WE GOT FIVE THOSE WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THIS ON CALL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MOVING ON
TO MISTER FRAZIER -- ON ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE AND MISTER
FRAZIER JUST BECAUSE OF THE TIME
AND KNOWING THAT FOLKS IT'S
WAITED FOR A LONG LONG TIME FOR
YOUR WITNESSES -- MAKING SURE
THAT -- WE DON'T WE ARE TOO LONG
WINDED -- THIS THIS EVENING.
BUT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MR MAYS I ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND
I'LL PARAPHRASE MY FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF NOTES.
OF MR MEMBERS.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE WILL
ALLOW SOLANO COUNTY TO CONSTRUCT
AND OPERATE TO BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES ON THE COUNTY'S
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES
CAMPUS.
THIS WOULD FACILITATE SURE
HOSPITALIZATION STAYS WHILE
PROVIDING MORE SUPPORT OF
DISCHARGE PLACEMENTS ARE CURRENT
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT SYSTEM
DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH.
COMMUNITY PLACEMENTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS READY TO LEAVE
LOCKED FACILITIES AND IF A LOCAL
BETTIS FOUND THERE'S LITTLE TO
NO INTEGRATION OF CRITICAL
SERVICES TO PROPERLY MONITOR
SUPPORT THEM.
AND SUPPORT THEM WITH THE GOAL
OF PREVENTING RELAPSE RE
HOSPITALIZATION.
AND POTENTIAL RING CAR SICK.
REINCARNATION.
AND I WILL NOW SHARE IT WITH MY
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I I'M
DOCTOR BILL MUCH CASH ON THE
HEALTH OF SERVICE ON A COUNTY
WHERE I OVERSEE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS IN THE UP THE
MEDICAL CLINICS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE CARE AT PRESENT FOR
PERSONS WHO HAVE SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESSES IS SILENT IN IS
FREQUENTLY VERY FRAGMENTED --
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL PATIENTS
AS A GROUP REQUIRE A CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FROM OUTPATIENT TO
BOARDING CARE TO AUGMENTED
BOARDING CARE TOO IMPATIENT. TO
CRISIS STABILIZATION.
IN ADDITION CLIENTS WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESSES ALSO NEED
INFORMED COORDINATED PHYSICAL
CARE AS WELL AS PROPERLY CASE
MANAGE SOCIAL SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
SUCCESSFULLY KNOW THE COMMUNITY.
AT THE PRESENT TIME THE ELEMENTS
ON THE CONTINUE OF AN OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE GENERALLY OPERATE AS
ISOLATED ENEMY AS ISOLATED
ENTITIES.
IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM ALSO VERY
OFTEN RESULTS IN A FAILURE TO
ASSURE PROPER PHYSICAL CARE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CLIENTS AND AS A
CONSEQUENCE.
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL PATIENTS
TYPICALLY DIE OF TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EARLIER THAN
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESSES IN THEIR DEATHS
ARE LARGELY FROM PREVENTABLE AND
MANAGEABLE CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE BY
SUMMER FRAZIER PROVIDES FOR A
UNIQUE PILOT TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
CLIENTS IN A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND COORDINATED
FASHION.
WITH FUNDS PROVIDED BY THIS
PILOT SOLANO COUNTY PROPOSES TO
BUILD A MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY
THAT OFFERS BOTH BOARDING CARE
AN AUGMENTED BOARDING CARE
SERVICES FOR UP TO THIRTY TWO
CLIENTS IT'S THEM ON THE SAME
CAMPUS.
AND WHICH WE OFFER AT THE
PRESENT TIME OUTPATIENT HEALTH
TREATMENT CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES SUCH AS
MEDICARE ON FOOD ASSISTANCE.
PRIMARY CARE AND DENTAL HEALTH.
IN CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES HELP
THESE CLIENTS NAVIGATE HOUSING
OPTIONS AND ACCESS THE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED SO IN
ESSENCE.
THE PILOT WILL PROVIDE FOR MOST
OF THE CONTINUUM OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE TO BE PRESENT ON OUR
CURRENT CAMPUS.
WHICH IS ALSO THE SAME CAMPUS
WHERE WE WILL BE ABLE TO
COORDINATE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND THEIR NEED FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THEN IN ADDITION
WITH THE INVOLVEMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL MAKE IT.
A POINT TO ASSESS THE
FEASIBILITY AND THE SUCCESS OF
THE COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED
CARE MODEL THAT SPRINT THAT'S
PROPOSED BY THIS PILOT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH JIM OTHER
WITNESS.
YES GOOD EVENING I'M SEEING
PERSONS ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR AT SOLANO COUNTY THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HERE.
ARE THE THE AS MENTIONED THE
PROPOSAL IS TO ADD THIRTY TWO
UNLOCKED BOARDING CARE BEDS --
ON OUR COMPREHENSIVE SERVICE
LIGHT WHICH WE THINK BEST.
BRIDGES THE GAP BETWEEN LOCKED
TO CARE AND COMMUNITY
INDEPENDENCE OR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
MINUTES BOARD HOUSING IS ALSO A
HUGE NEED AND WHEN THAT IS
ACTUALLY BEING WORKED ON IN OUR
JURISDICTION ACROSS THE COUNTY --
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF NO PLACE
LIKE HOME FUNDS -- BUT WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BEFORE PEOPLE
CAN GET TO THAT SPACE IS A SKILL
BUILDING TO BE ABLE TO LIVE MORE
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND TO GET EXTRA SUPPORT IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH RECOVERY SO THAT
THEY CAN GO ON TO LIVE FULL AND
MEANINGFUL LIVES.
SO THIS WOULD BE SIXTEEN BEDS
THAT WE WOULD CONSIDER AUGMENTED
BORDEN CARE SETTING WHICH IS
BASICALLY A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
FOR PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND THEN SIXTEEN BEDS THAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED A LOWER LEVEL OF
KERR.
REGULAR BOARDING CARE -- WITH --
WITH A LIGHTER -- STAFFING.
RATIO -- SO WHAT WHAT WE THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
CONCEPT IS THAT IS VERY FLEXIBLE
WITHIN THE SYSTEM OF CARE SO IT
CAN IT CAN MEET THE NEEDS
BETWEEN THE ACUTE AND THE
COMMUNITY.
AND N. A FLEXIBLE WAY AND AS
WELL AS PREVENT.
LIFT USING.
AS A STEP DOWN FROM THE CUTE HI
HIGHLY RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENTS --
OR AS A PREVENTION TO THAT LEVEL
OF CARE THAT SO WE SEE IT
HAPPENING IN BOTH IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS FOR INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION.
AND THE PLAN THAT PRINCIPLE
REALLY IS SUPPORTED.
BY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
REQUIRES OF US TO KEEP PEOPLE
OUT THERE PLEASE RESEARCH OF
LEVEL OF CARE POSSIBLE.
SO -- WE THANK YOU FOR OUR
CONSIDERING THIS BILL AND ARE.
OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS FANTASTIC
WILL MOVE TO ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
SEE NOW WILL COME BACK TO A
MEMBERS OF FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
FLOOR I THINK THAT SECOND WAS
MISS CARILLO OR THE IS THAT
RIGHT MISSING.
THE OKAY WELL FANTASTIC --
MISTER FRAZIER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT
MAYES HI MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE CARRILLO.
I FLORA FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
SEVENTIES WAS WE GOT SEVEN VOTES
FOR NOW WILL LEAVE THOSE THAT
THE ON CALL AND I'M SURE WILL BE
A PROBLEM GET NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU OLD MEMBERS FOR YOUR
MARATHON WORK -- THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER I'M MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SIX AB --
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE DAILY.
AND MR DAILY THIS ALSO HAS A
SUPPORT SUPPORT --
RECOMMENDATION I GET IT ALL
RIGHT I GET IT [inaudible]
MOVE THE THANK YOU.
I KNOW I LIKE HIS ROOMMATE IS.
MY FAVORITE COMMITTEE -- I WILL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE.
TO EXPERT WITNESSES SO IN CASE
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR IF
YOU NEED ANY ADDITIONAL
BACKGROUND.
THANK IF YOU DO HAVE ANY -- ANY
COMMENTS YOU CAN BE VERY VERY
BRIEF LIKE I'M NOT SURE A NEEDED
I AM I WAS LISTENING CAREFULLY --
BASICALLY THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ADOPT BEST PRACTICES
FOR RECOVERY HOUSING -- RIGHT
NOW IN OUR STATE THERE'S NO
AUTHORITATIVE SOURCE OF
INFORMATION FOR FINDING RECOVERY
RESIDENCES THAT ARE SAFE FOR
ESIDENTS AND COMMUNITIES ALIKE.
BY ADOPTING BEST PRACTICES FOR
RECOVERY RESIDENCES OUR STATE
WILL TAKE A SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARD INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
SAFE RESIDENCES FOR PEOPLE.
SEEKING RECOVERY SERVICES.
MY TWO WITNESSES ARE SHERRY
DAILY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS NO RELATION BY
THE WAY DIFFERENT SPELLING OF
DAILY.
SHE SPELLS AT THE CHICAGO WAY.
AND RYAN HAMPTON A RECOVERY
ADVOCATE WHO IS HIMSELF AND
RECOVERY FROM OPIOID ADDICTION.
SO THAT IS THE ESSENCE OF THE
BILL -- BEST PRACTICES ARE WHAT
WE ARE SEEKING.
AND IF THE WITNESS IS SUPPORT
JUST WANNA BE QUICK THAT WOULD
BE GREAT EMMA PASSES BACK OVER
TO THE CHAIR.
GREAT HE'S TOUGH SO GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
RYAN HAMPTON I'M A PERSON
RECOVERY FROM A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER I'D LIKE.
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY --
I PROMISE I WILL BE BRIEF -- IT
IS AN HONOR TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
IMPACT THE AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
NINE WILL HAVE ON CALIFORNIANS
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
AND I MUST SAY IT IS LONG PAST
TIME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM OF BROKE
SOBRE HOMES IN OUR STATE.
WELL AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE
IS NOT A COMPLETE FIX TO THE
PROBLEM IT IS A POSITIVE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE A SAFE
RECOVERY RESIDENTS SAVE MY LIFE
BUT I AM ALSO HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE MY FRIEND TYLER DIED OF
A HEROIN OVERDOSE -- IN A SOBER
HOME BECAUSE THERE WAS NO NO
LOCKS AND ON SITE BECAUSE THE
HOME STAFF WORK TRAINED TO DEAL
WITH OVERDOSES MY FRIEND.
LOST HIS LIFE.
COMMON SENSE MEASURES LIKE
NALOXONE ETHICAL STANDARDS AND
PROTECTIONS FOR PROOF FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO RECOVER ARE
CRUCIAL IF WE WANT TO SAVE LIVES.
MY FRIEND'S DEATH WAS 1100%
PREVENTABLE AND AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY NINE BEGINS TO ADDRESS
THE CHANGES WE NEED IN ORDER TO
ENSURE.
THAT RECOVERY HOMES ARE SAVING
LIVES NOT ENDANGERING THEM WE
MUST HAVE BEST PRACTICES IN
RECOVERY HOUSING IMPLEMENTED.
AS I SIT HERE CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING EXPLOITED AND LOWERED INTO
UNSAFE RESIDENCES.
FAMILIES HAVE NO WAY OF
IDENTIFYING SAFE RELIABLE
OPERATORS AND OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO LOSE OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER YEAR TO
OVERDOSE DEATHS.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THIS IS A
CRISIS AND THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THIS COMMITTEE HAS A MANDATE TO
DO THEIR JOB AND PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE.
WE HAVE GOT TO END THIS
EXPLOITATION AND ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A WAY TO TELL THE
REPUTABLE FROM THE PREDATORY
WITHOUT THESE MEASURES IN PLACE
WE WILL CONTINUE. TO LOSE PEOPLE
LIKE MY FRIEND TYLER.
PEOPLE WHO ACCESS CONTINUING
CARE.
ASK FOR HELP IN GOOD FAITH AND
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THEIR SAFETY
NET IS STRONG SAFE AND READY TO
CATCH THEM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SHERRIE TAYLOR SEE CAP I WON'T
TALK OF A SPORT SPORT THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST -- OPPOSE
THIS LEGISLATION FOR THE SAME
REASON WE USUALLY OPPOSE THESE --
BILLS THAT THE TEMP -- TO DEFINE
TO RESTRICT -- THE RECOVERY
RESIDENCES -- THE SCOPE OF THE
OF THE RESTRICTIONS THAT THIS
BILL PUTS ON RECOVERY --
RESIDENCES PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARILY BROAD CREATES A
VAST SCHEME OF CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS OF A PRIVATE ENTITY.
AND REALLY LAUNDERS BY REQUIRING
DH CS TO AND TO ADOPT THEM
AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
TO REPORT THE LACK OF COMPLIANCE
TO DH CS IT ALLOWS THE REALLY
THE PUBLIC SHAMING -- OF
RECOVERY RESIDENCES THAT HAVEN'T
MET THE THE REQUIREMENTS WITH
THE ULTIMATE RESULT IS THAT WE
LOSE THOSE RESIDENCES.
AS BEING AVAILABLE -- FOR FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ACTUALLY
NEED THEM BUT IMPORTANTLY I I
THINK AS YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY
BEFORE THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
THE BOAT BILL -- IMPOSES ON
INDIVIDUALS IN NON CERTIFIED
RECOVERY RESIDENCES RESTRICTIONS
THAT ARE NOT IMPOSED ON FAMILIES --
OR GROUPS OF A SIMILAR SIZE --
OUR POSITION IS BANNED WHERE A
HOUSEHOLD WHERE TWO OR MORE
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES CHOOSE
TO LIVE TOGETHER -- THEY MAY NOT
BE SUBJECTED TO REQUIREMENTS OR
CONDITIONS THAT ARE -- IMPOSED
ON A HOUSEHOLDS CONSISTING OF
PERSONS WITH -- WITH
DISABILITIES BOTH -- REQUIRED BY --
THE FAIR HOUSING ACT THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
WE HAVE CURRENTLY A SEVERE
HOUSING SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA I
DON'T NEED -- TO TELL YOU ALL
THAT AND THERE'S A DRAMATIC NEED --
FOR SOBER LIVING PAT CERTAINLY
IN THE STATE AS WELL WE THINK
THE EFFECT OF THIS BILL WILL
EXASPERATED -- THOSE --
DEFICIENCIES AND AND MAKE IT
ACTUALLY EASIER FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NIMBY THEM OUT OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR THAT
REASON WE POST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THE BILL DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION MISTER
DALY WHICH YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WHILE I
RESPECT THE CONCERNS OF THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS --
ORGANIZATION I THINK THERE'S TOO
MUCH AT STAKE -- ON THIS SUBJECT --
WITH ADDICTION AND THE GROWING
PROBLEM OF DICTION IS TOO MUCH
AT STAKE NOT TO HAVE -- AT LEAST
MINIMAL STANDARDS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER FLORA SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHERE.
WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
I FLORA FLORA AYE LIMóN
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
THIS AREA RAMOS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
HI.
YES SEVEN VOTES WITH THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU TO IT TO ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY -- LET'S SEE THIS OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- BESIDE YOUR
KERR. TO GET DOWN THERE FOR
MINIMUM DOWN.
MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
SEC.
KEVIN MOTION MOTION AND A SECOND.
SURE THAT THERE'S WITH THE
MESSAGE OF THE MOST RISK.
THEY DO IT THE SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SEVEN FOUR FOUR
CREATES TRUE TELL HEALTH PARITY
SO THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
REGARDLESS OF THE LOCATION AND
PROVIDERS CAN EXPAND THE REACH
TO SERVE THOSE THAT MAY BE OUT
OF RANGE.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
NONDISCRIMINATION STATUTES IN
EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE THAT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER IS
REIMBURSED FOR SERVICES
DELIVERED TO AN ENROLLEE TO
TELEHEALTH IF THOSE SAME
SERVICES ARE COVERED WHEN
PROVIDED IN PERSON.
THIS BILL DOES NOT EXPAND ANY
SERVICES THAT ARE COVERED IT
ONLY ADDRESSES THEM MODALITY USE
IT TO PROVIDE THOSE COVERED
SERVICES.
BY UPDATING TELEHEALTH
DEFINITIONS AND CONTRACTING Là
AB SEVEN FORTY FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS OR WHO HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS OF ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE.
I'M GOING TO PASS IT OFF TO MY
SUPPORTERS NOW WHO CAN SPEAK OF
THE CURRENT SITUATION WITH TELL
HEALTH AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANY DURBIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BELL I'M
JUST BRIEFLY IN 200-011-8415 WAS
PASSED TO ESTABLISH THE
TELEHEALTH ADVANCEMENT ACT TO
REVISE AND UPDATE EXISTING LAW
TO FACILITATE ADVANCEMENT OF
TELEHEALTH HAS A SERVICE
DELIVERY MODEL. FOR THE MANAGED
CARE AND MEDICAL PROGRAM ONE OF
THE MAIN GOALS OF THAT
LEGISLATION WAS TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICES PROVIDED THREE TELL
HEALTH WOULD NOT BE TREATED ANY
DIFFERENTLY BY PAIRS -- THAN
THOSE PROVIDED IN PERSON.
UNFORTUNATELY AT TODAY AS A
RECENT STUDY BY THE CENTER FOR
CONNECTED HEALTH POLICY HAS
SHOWN ALL PAIRS DO CONTINUE TO
LIMIT TELEHEALTH REIMBURSEMENT
IN SOME WAY SUCH AS TYPES OF
SERVICES REIMBURSED.
AND MODALITY USE WITH ONLY FEW
OFFERING COVERAGE FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF TELEHEALTH MODALITIES --
OUT OF THAT STUDY STATED IT IT
MAKES CLEAR THAT THERE'S A BROAD
MISCONCEPTION THAT BECAUSE
PRIVATE HERE LAWS ARE IN PLACE.
THAT WERE ACTUALLY ACHIEVING THE
PROMISE OF THOSE PARITY BENEFITS --
WITH IN PERSON CARE AND SO THERE
FOR EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY FOUR
SEEKS TO PROVIDE THAT CLARITY BY
STRENGTHENING THAT EXISTING LAW
PROPERTY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WHAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I'M DAN PETERSON
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR
SUTTER LAKESIDE HOSPITAL.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SUTTER
HEALTH IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR I SUTTER
LAKESIDE HOSPITALS A TWENTY FIVE
BED CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL
PART OF THE SUTTER HEALTH
NETWORK AT TWENTY FOUR HOSPITALS.
OUT WE'RE LOCATED IN LAKE COUNTY
WERE THE ONLY CERTIFIED STROKE
CENTER TRAUMA CENTER LAKE COUNTY.
LAKE COUNTY RECENTLY RANKED
FIFTY EIGHT OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
ON OUR OUR STATES COUNTY HEALTH
RANKINGS.
WE HAVE 25% OF OUR RESIDENTS
UNDER THE NATIONAL POVERTY LEVEL.
NOW WE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
CHALLENGE COUNTY -- WE HAVE MANY
CHALLENGES AROUND HEALTH
PARTICULARLY AROUND ACCESS TO
CARE AND ACCESS TO SPECIALTY
CARE IN PARTICULAR I CAN TELL
YOU SOMEONE TRYING TO RECRUIT
PHYSICIANS TO THE AREA -- IT IS
NO EASY TASK AT PARTICULAR GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE COMMUNITY IN
THE RURAL AREA -- I EXPECT I
EXPERIENCE THIS LACK OF
SPECIALIST FIRST HAND SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WITH MY ONE YEAR OLD
SON -- WHO IS DIAGNOSED OF THE
GASTROINTESTINAL ISSUE? FOR
WHICH WE HAD TO TRAVEL THREE
HOURS TO SAN FRANCISCO -- FOR
ROUTINE INTRODUCTORY
APPOINTMENTS WHICH COULD HAVE
EASILY BEEN HANDLED THROUGH
TELEHEALTH THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT
THE NATURE OF THIS APPOINTMENT
THAT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN --
THROUGH THE EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES OUT WE WERE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE MEANS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THE MAJORITY MY
COMMUNITY DOES NOT -- IN
ADDITION TO THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THAT.
THAT PREVENT ACCESS TO CARE --
WE WERE DEVASTATED IN OUR
COMMUNITY WITH THE WILD FIRES
LAST LAST FALL IN RIGHT
CALIFORNIA -- WE EVACUATE OUR
HOSPITAL FOR TWO WEEKS DUE TO
THE MEDICINE -- COMPLEX FIRE.
AND DURING THIS TIME.
WE WERE ABLE TO FORTUNATELY LEAN
UPON THE SUTTER HEALTH NETWORK
OF FOURTEEN THOUSAND AFFILIATED
CLINICIANS -- TO PROVIDE VIDEO
VISITS ANOTHER TELEHEALTH
SERVICES TO MANY OF OUR PATIENTS
AND THEIR GREATEST TIME WE NEED.
WE MADE THE CONSCIOUS DECISION
TO DO SO NOT KNOWING WHETHER OR
NOT.
THESE PEOPLE WOULD BE REIMBURSED
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY DID AT
THAT TIME.
THAT IS NOT AN EASY DECISION
MAKE BUT IS IT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR OUR COMMUNITY AT
THE TIME I SIMILARLY FEEL A. B.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR IS THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER SUPPORT.
NEAR MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL CESSATION IN SUPPORT.
KIM CRACK ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GARY COOPER ON BEHALF OF CAL
GERMAN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI KELLY MAC MILLAN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN'S CARE SPECIALLY CALL
THE SENSE.
THANK YOU.
RENTS SPENCER PAP THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
SPORT THANK YOU.
HI MELISSA CORTEZ ROTH ON BEHALF
OF AUTISM SPEAKS AND THE CENTER
FOR AUTISM RELATED DISORDERS I'M
A LITTLE BIT OF A TWEENER WE
HAVE A SUPPORT OF AMEND POSITION.
AS DRAFTED THE BILL RIGHT NOW
WOULD NOT INCLUDE CERTAIN
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROVIDERS WHO COULD YOU DO TELL
HEALTH SERVICES -- THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT LICENSED BY
THE STATE WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND EXPECT TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE [inaudible]
ZURICH OPPOSITION
.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER ONLY WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS -- AND CAP MUST IMPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IT WILL
INCREASE RESULT IN AN INCREASE
AND CONSUMER PREMIUMS AND OUT OF
POCKET EXPENSES -- IN OUR
OPINION THIS BILL SIMPLY IS NOT
NECESSARY -- TELEHEALTH IS
ALREADY ALLOWED IN HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS BUILD TELL HEALTH
INTO THEIR NETWORKS WITHIN THE
EXISTING STATUTE REGULATIONS.
THESE EXISTING STATUTORY
REGULATIONS ALSO INCLUDE
CONSUMER PROTECTION REGARDING
TELL HEALTH SERVICES -- PATIENTS
CANNOT BE COERCED INTO USING
TELEHEALTH BY THE PROVIDER OR
HEALTH PLAN AND THERE IS PAYMENT
PARITY PAYMENT PARITY MEANING
COPAYMENTS DEDUCTIBLES.
ARE THE SAME FOR TELEHEALTH AS
AN IN PERSON VISIT.
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES COMPANIES.
EXCUSE ME CANNOT DO ALLOW FOR
THE USE OF TELEHEALTH FOR THEIR
ENROLLEES IN INSURANCE IS
DEFINED IN STATUTE.
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS HAVE
THE AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO CREATE A ROBUST ROBUST
NETWORK OF PROVIDERS.
IN IN BUILDING THESE NETWORKS
TELL HEALTH PROVIDERS ARE USING
CURRENTLY CONTRACT HEALTH PLANS.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILLS THAT
CIRCUMVENTS THE PROVIDER
CONTRACTING PROCESS BY DICTATING
WHAT THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
TELEHEALTH SERVICES SHALL BE.
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS ARE TYPICALLY
INAPPROPRIATELY DETERMINED IN
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS WHEN
CONTRACTING WITH PROVIDERS FOR
SERVICES.
MULTIPLE FACTORS ARE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION BY THE PLANT AND
THIS BILL FAILS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE REDUCTION OF
FACILITY ADMINISTRATIVE AND
OTHER.
OVERHEAD COSTS WHEN COMPARED TO
TELEHEALTH.
AND SO IT AS I PRESENTED WITH
EARLIER.
BILLS EARLIER TODAY WE JUST
DON'T SUPPORT.
ON ANY BILLS ARE GOING TO
INCREASE THE PREMIUMS ARE --
COPAYMENTS FOR PARMALEE THANK
YOU. SEVENTY ONE CAN FINALLY
HAPPENED THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WITH ECHO
MANY OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE I THINK OUR MEMBERS
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT TELEHEALTH WE
SEE IT AS A VITAL.
INNOVATIVE OPTION FOR PATIENTS
TO GET THEM A LOT OF TIME.
A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY WITH PEOPLE
WITH FAMILIES AND OTHER OPTIONS
TO USE THAT UNFORTUNATELY THIS
BILL REALLY DOES MANDATE
CONTRACT NEGOTIATION TERMS IN
STATUTE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO ALSO POINT
OUT THAT IT DOES PREVENT US FROM
SO SOURCE CONTRACTING SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS DO YOU USE THIRD
PARTY VENDORS THEY'RE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE BETTER RATES WITH
THOSE VENDORS PROVIDE THESE
VITAL SERVICES.
WHICH THEN EQUATES TO LOWER
PREMIUMS FOR OUR MEMBERS SO YET
AGAIN IN A TIME WHEN WE ARE
INCREDIBLY PRICE SENSITIVE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT.
THESE OPTIONS OF NEGOTIATING
THESE PRICES DO. FOR WAR AT THAT
CONSUMERS WITH LOWER PREMIUMS
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT CAPITA
CLICK.
HERE.
KAREN SIR KISSING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN A BOOK IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
COMES FROM COMING.
MIKE I GUESS MY QUESTION IS I'M
I I GUESS I'M STILL A LITTLE
PUZZLED AS TO WHY.
YOU THE HEALTH PLANS FEEL THIS
IS GOING TO INCREASE COSTS.
ON THE WAY THAT THE BILL WAS
DRAFTED ACCORDING TO THE CHEAPER
BUT NOW SAYS DO THE INCREASE
UTILIZATION TELL HEALTH SERVICES
AT THE RATE SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL.
IT'S ANTICIPATED INCREASE
PREMIUMS BY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AN OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES FOR
ENROLLEES FIFTY MILLION.
SO THIS INCREASED UTILIZATION
MIGHT BE FROM PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
APPEAL TO ACCESS A DOCTOR.
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN A REALLY
POOR COMMUNITY.
OR THEY CAN'T THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO DRIVE TO THREE
HOURS LIKE OUR HOSPITAL CEO DID.
SO.
IS THIS NOT POTENTIALLY.
KIND OF A DIAL OF CARE.
I'M I THINK OUR MEMBERS WOULD
ABSOLUTELY SUGGEST THE THE
INTENT IS NOT TO DENY CARE NOT
TO GIVE PEOPLE ACCESS I MEAN WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT TELL HEALTH
KIDS.
I THINK THE CONCERN WOULD BE FOR
US IS THAT AS WE NEGOTIATE THE
CONTRACTS.
SO SAFE WE USE A THIRD PARTY
VENDOR AS AN OPTION WERE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE A BETTER CONTRACT IN
THE CONTEXT THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GUARANTEEING THEM A CERTAIN SET
OF ENROLLEES.
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE AWAY THAT
FLEXIBILITY FOR US TO DO THAT
AND TÁI S. TO AN ESTABLISHED
RATE.
VERSUS US BEING ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE A SECONDARY RATE WITH
THE PROVIDER AND SO THAT THAT'S
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL REALLY DOES LIMIT
OUR ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE RATES
AND AND LOWER RATES FOR
CONSUMERS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
WELL -- SO THERE'S NO IN THE
BILL LANGUAGE AB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR ACTUALLY SET THE TELEHEALTH
RATE REQUIRE THAT THE RATE BE --
THE SAME AS AN IN PERSON RATE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE TELE
HEALTH PARITY IT DOES NOT
DICTATE RATE FOR SERVICES.
SO.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU AGREE TO
DISAGREE YEAH REGULATORS.
YOU KNOW IT'S YOU KNOW I IF
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE PEOPLE IF
PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE HEALTH CARE.
WHY NOT YEAH THERE MIGHT BE A
PRICE INCREASES? FOR CRIME ANY
SIX EVERYBODY DESERVES TO HAVE
HEALTH CARE.
THANK YOU PRIME ANY SIX THAT'S A
THAT'S A THAT'S A NAGS THAT'S AN
EGG.
THING YOU KNEW IT.
LARA TO SIX TWENTY FIVE AT NIGHT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT FOR US.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IF YOU'RE
FROM LOS ANGELES?
YOU TO RURAL DICTIONARY BECAUSE
WE GOT THE URBAN DICTIONARY WILL
GIVE.
YEAH.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS WHEN.
HE WAS CHAIR OF THIS ONE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SEEMS TO ME.
FOR THE FOR THOSE OF US THAT
THAT REPRESENT RURAL AREAS THAT
ARE UNDER SERVED THEY DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS.
ANY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE. TO
TO BE ABLE TO TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO THOSE PROVIDERS IS GOING TO
BE -- HELPFUL AND SO MAYBE THE
BILL ISN'T PERFECT CONTINUE WORK
BUT I'M TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY SO.
THANKS FOR BEING A FORD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ANYWAY ANYONE ELSE.
JUST JUST AS WAS THERE BOB THIS
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
I HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE WORKING --
IN THE IDEA.
YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY I CAN
UNDERSTAND WANTING TO GET THE
INSURANCE COMES ONE TO GET A
BETTER CONTRACTED RATE BUT IT.
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S NOT
AGREEMENT ON WHAT YOUR BILL.
OR NOT IF YOU'RE NOT YOU GUYS
ARE NOT BOTH ON THE SAME PAGE SO --
YOU KNOW I I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY THIS WORKED ON THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO THINK -- ARE.
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM LAKE
COUNTY THE CAME ALL THE WAY HERE
HE'S HE'S HE'S SEEN THIS HAPPEN
RIGHT HE SPENDS HIS TIME DOING
THIS -- I WOULD REMIND ALL OF
YOU THAT ARE SITTING UP HERE
THAT NATIONAL DOT DISASTERS
HAPPEN.
AND THIS BILL IS LIKE A VISION I
THINK THAT WE ALL SHOULD BE
REALLY HAPPY THIS TYPE OF BILL
GOES THROUGH.
BECAUSE WE NEVER KNOW WHAT THE
NEXT NATURAL TO DISASTROUS AND
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE OUR PEOPLE
HAVE HEALTH CARE THEY ARE AXIS
WHETHER IT'S FLOOD FIREOR NEXT
EARTHQUAKE.
IT WILL HAPPEN IN ONE OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES IS SITTING HERE IT'S
NOT JUST THE RURAL AREAS SO TELL
HEALTH IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I REALLY IT WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF A LOT OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHICH WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER RAMOS --
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WHAT I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AFTER CURRY I BIGELOW.
BONTA.
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CARILLO I FLORA.
FLORA NONVOTING Là MON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS REBELS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE.
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
HI.
GIVE TEN VOTE YOUR BILL IS OUT
AND UP I AM MY OWN UP THERE WITH
YOU.
I THOUGHT SO.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S ONE MAKE SURE.
ANOTHER ONE SEE WE NUCLEAR
DICTIONARY OUT HERE SO -- OUR
NEXT MR FLORA -- I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T SEE YOU THERE.
MR CALLING.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX WHICH SEEKS TO
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS BY AUTHORIZING
LOCAL EDUCATION.
AGENCIES INCLUDE INCLUDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- LOCAL PLAN
AREAS TO PROVIDE EARLY PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT SERVICES -- TO MEDI
CAL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS MAKE
DIRECT CLAIMS FOR FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS THE RATE THE ACSI
THIS WILL BE A BRIEF
PRESENTATION FOR THE SAKE OF FOR
THE BREVITY OF YOUR FRIEND TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AS L.
ET.
AL YEAH IS SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLANNER IS A SELF AS AN
EARLY PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT AS THE
P. S. D. T..
NOW THIS SIZE ONE OF TWO BILLS
THAT -- THE CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE PATRICK
O'DONNELL AND I OR JOINTLY
OFFERING -- IN RESPONSE TO AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE HAD A
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND CONVERSATIONS WITH
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS AND
PARENTS IN MY DISTRICT ONE TOPIC
THAT CONSISTENTLY ARISES.
AS AN AREA OF NEED AS MENTAL
HEALTH AND STUDENT WELLNESS A
REVIEW OF THE RESEARCH ON THE
TOPIC DEMONSTRATES WHY THE
PROBLEM HAS BECOME SO CUTE.
YOU'VE SUICIDE RATES ARE RISING
NEARLY EVERY YEAR AND ARE NOW AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX IN A WORLD WHERE IN
RURAL CAROL CALIFORNIA WHERE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE MOST
LIMITED.
THE SUICIDE RATE IS OFTEN TRIPLE
THE STATE AVERAGE FURTHERMORE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST RECENT HEALTHY
KIDS SURVEY FOUND THAT 34% OF
ELEVENTH GRADERS EXPERIENCE
CHRONIC SADNESS AND 16% HAVE
SERIOUSLY CONTEMPLATED SUICIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT APPEAR TO BE PREPARED TO
RESPOND TO THESE ALARMING TRENDS.
ACCORDING TO STANFORD
UNIVERSITY'S MOST RECENT GETTING
DOWN THE FACTS OF THE A MENTAL
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS. FORTY
RENTS OUT OR NEAR THE BOTTOM
NATIONALLY FOR STUDENT ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. ONE
MAJOR BARRIER TO IMPROVE IN THIS
IS THAT ELOISE AND SELF WAS
CURRENTLY HAVE VERY LIMITED
ACCESS TO EAT T. S. T. T.
FUNDING.
WELL DISTRICTS AND LEDS ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO DELIVER SERVICES
COVERED BY UPS TV THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO WAY FOR ELEAZAR
SELF AS TO DIRECTLY ACCESS THOSE
DOLLARS.
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS READ RECEIVE FUND
DISTRIBUTIONS TO PROVIDE
CHILDREN WITH THE PST T.
SERVICES BUT ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
WORK WITH ELEAZAR SELF AS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AT SCHOOL SITES
OR THROUGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS CREATES AN UNNECESSARY
HURDLE FOR MANY ELEAZAR AND SELF
WAS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE STATE
SHIFTED 1100% OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WANTS ABILITY
FROM COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO ELLIE ACE NOW IN
MAKING THIS CHANGE.
THE STATE SHIFTED MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION A FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS TO THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT SIDE OF THE STATE BUDGET.
TO SERVE THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF STUDENTS BUT DID NOT PROVIDE
ELEAZAR WITH DIRECT ACCESS TO
EAT P. S. T. D. FUNDING.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE EPS
DD FUNDS IN THE STORE AT THE
BEEN PART OF THE FUNDING SOURCE
TO SERVE STUDENTS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
AS A RESULT STATE FUNDS ARE
OFTEN USED FOR SERVICES PROVIDED
BY ELEAZAR L. SELF AS THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN FUNDED
FEDERALLY THREE PST T..
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES AN ALLEY A
INCLUDING SELF AS WHICH IS NOT
CONTRACT WITH A MEANT COUNTY
WHICH DO NOT CONTRACT WITH THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLAN TO
MAKE A DIRECT CLAIM FOR FEDERAL
EPS DD FUNDING THROUGH THE ACS.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
DOLLARS THE L. E. WOULD NEED TO
PUT UP MATCHING FUNDS -- FOR THE
EXPENDITURES I HAVE MET WITH ME --
THIS -- THIS EVENING LARA WASCO
FROM THE BALL FROST GROUP AS
WELL AS A TONY TO GROW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD EVENING -- CHAIR MEMBERS
LARA MOSCOW WITH THE BALL FROST
GROUP AND I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- HAS
THE AUTHOR INDICATED -- ELEAZAR
DO NOT HAVE DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
EASY PST T. FUNDS IT DOESN'T
CAUSE A HURDLE -- WE BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE -- IN THE RIGHT
POSITION TO SERVE ALL OF THE
STUDENTS AT THE SCHOOL SITE WE
MAY NOT HAVE ALL THE
PROFESSIONALS ON SITE.
BUT WE ARE HIRING MORE AND MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS AS WELL AS
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY COUNSELORS --
TO HELP PROVIDE ALL OF THESE
SERVICES THE KEY PART IS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING COMING FROM.
SOME OTHER FUNDING SOURCE WERE
USING PROP NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS --
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE USE FOR
THE GENERAL ED POPULATION --
WE'RE REQUESTING A YOUR I BET ON
THIS BILL IF YOU HAVE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY. TWENTY TWO ZERO THEY HAVE
ASSOCIATES SO STATION OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS CTA'S WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS.
AT THE SCHOOL SITE WE MET
SEVERAL TIMES WITH STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ASKING FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND INVOLVEMENT.
THE MARCH FOURTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT BY OUR STATE
AUDITOR CITED DO DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DEFICIENT.
DEFICIENT OVERSIGHT OF THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS THROUGH WHICH
90% OF THE CHILDREN AND MEDI CAL
AND ROLL.
THE REPORT RECOMMENDED A VARIETY
OF ACTIONS FOR D. H. C. S. TO
INCREASE.
CHILDREN'S USE.
A MEDI CAL PROVIDED PREVENTIVE
SERVICES AND THEREBY IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF CHILDREN AND REDUCE
LONG TERM HEALTH CARE COSTS.
ALLOWING LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO MAKE CLAIMS DIRECTLY
TO DH CS FOR E. P. S. D. T.
SERVICES WILL BENEFIT STUDENTS
AT ALL LEVELS AND IS THE REASON
CDA SUPPORTS AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX AND URGES AND
I BOTH.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OLDER SHILOH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
CHRIS LIKE HILLS HERE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
SELF ADMINISTRATORS.
VIDEO BORN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
NO TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- I HAVE SOME COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS AND IS THE THIRD
TIME THAT SOMEONE'S ATTEMPTED TO
DO THIS BILL -- I'M KIND OF
AMBIVALENT ABOUT THE BILL QUITE
FRANKLY -- ON THE ONE HAND I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED -- ACTUALLY
I WAS THE ONE WHO COMMISSION THE
AUDIT THAT WAS REFERENCED BY.
BY BY HER BUT THAT ACTUALLY THAT
ONLY YOUR POINTS WERE GERMANE TO
THE AUTO SIDE OF TAKE EXCEPTION
WITH YOU ON BUT RIGHT NOW WE PST
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED TO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS.
THAT'S HOW IT'S DONE -- COUNTIES
RECEIVE DEDICATED REALIGNMENT
REVENUE FOR THIS -- FOR THIS
PURPOSE I KNOW THIS BILL LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES COULD ALSO
USE PROP NINETY EIGHT MONEY
WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT -- TO
BUILD THE ACS THROUGH FEE FOR
SERVICE OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN STRUCTURE.
SO MONEY IS SUPPOSED TO GO FOR
EDUCATION WOULD GO FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND MEDI CAL.
AND THAT WERE ALREADY FUNDING
WITH REALIGNMENT REVENUE.
I UNDERSTAND SCHOOLS HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW AND
ENCOURAGE THAT -- THAT REQUIRES
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES BE
PROVIDED BUT I'DLIKE TO SEE A
FIX ON THE ISSUE.
AT ADDRESSES WHY SCHOOLS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS DON'T
CONTRACT NOW.
THAT WOULD BE MUCH SIMPLER.
RATHER THAN SET UP A SEPARATE
BILLING STRUCTURE.
IN WHAT'S ALREADY A FRAGMENTED
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM
TRUST ME AS SOMEONE WHO BILL
MEDI CAL.
IT'S NOT EASY.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE EASY I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS IS REALLY THE
SOLUTION O HAVE SCHOOLS DO THIS.
QUITE FRANKLY AND SO I I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT.
BUT I THINK WHAT WE'D REALLY
LIKE TO SEE IS THAT SCHOOLS AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE COUNTIES
ACTUALLY WORK THIS OUT THE RIGHT
WAY -- BUT THAT'S THAT THAT'S
GONNA BE MY POSITION ON THE BILL
TONIGHT SO.
ANYBODY ELSE THE ACCOUNT
[inaudible]
RESPOND.
IF I MAY ADD MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE THE CONCERN I
THINK WHAT WE'RE FINDING WITH
EXPERIENCE IS THAT -- THE
ADDITIONAL HURDLE THAT IS
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW IS
SERVING AS A BARRIER TO ON
WALKING FEDERAL FUNDS -- THAT
THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE TO
ACTUALLY HELP KIDS ARE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS BUT IF IF
YOU'LL ALLOW ME I'LL DEFER TO MY
WITNESSES WATERSHED A LITTLE
MORE COLOR WHITE ON THAT.
CHAIR UNFORTUNATELY WHEN --
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH WORK COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT AGREED.
THEM BASICALLY THERE IS NO
APPEALS PROCESS SO.
IF THERE IS NOT AGREEMENT
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AGREE ON THE
YOUR IN -- DIRECT OF FEES YOU'RE
GONNA CHARGE OR WHETHER -- THE
STAFFING IS GOING TO BE OR ALL
OF THOSE AREAS THAT YOU LOOK AT
AN ANIMAL YOU.
THEN THERE IS NO APPEALS SO
BASICALLY THE TWO AGENCIES WALK
AWAY AND UNFORTUNATELY THE KIDS
IN THE MIDDLE ARE WHAT'S HURT.
I AGREE WITH I THOUGHT I WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE BETTER
PARTNERSHIPS BUT WE HAVE HEARD
OF UNFORTUNATELY VERY HIGH
INDIRECT COSTS BEING CHARGED BY
SOME COUNTIES OR PROPOSED TO BE
CHARGED BY SOME COUNTIES.
WE'VE HEARD OF ALSO THE
REQUIREMENT THAT.
VENDOR CERTAIN VENDORS BE USED
TO COME INTO THE SCHOOLS THAT
ISN'T THAT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE IT MAY NOT BE COST
EFFECTIVE FOR THE DISTRICT TO TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THAT -- SO
FROM A SCHOOL DISTRICT
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE AND HOW WE CAN USE THOSE
BEST TO SERVE THOSE STUDENTS.
I'M WORDY USING PROP NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS TO SERVE THOSE
KIDS IN THIS AREA UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE NOT GETTING THAT EXTRA
LITTLE MATCH TO GO WITH THE MEDI
CAL.
AND THE REASON WHY YOU PST TEA
IS SO CRITICAL FOR SCHOOLS IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABLE TO BILL FOR
CERTAIN SERVICES RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT DAY -- SERVICES
ADVANCED COUNSELING SERVICES AND
OTHERS THAT ARE NOT ALLOWED
UNDER THE ONLY A BILLING PROCESS
THAT SCHOOLS CURRENTLY USE SO
BASICALLY WHEN YOU HAVE THOSE
HIGH COST PROGRAMS THAT I JUST
LISTED.
THOSE HIGH DOLLARS WHICH COULD
BE UP TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT ARE COMING OUT OF YOUR
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO UNFORTUNATELY I AGREE THAT
THE TWO AGENCIES AREN'T WORKING
IT OUT THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
AGENCIES THAT DO HAVE AMMO USE
AND THEY SEEM TO BE GOING WELL
BUT THERE IS NO RECOURSE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO GO FORWARD.
AND GET ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IF
THEY CAN AGREE WITH OUR COUNTY.
SO I I GUESS I GUESS MY YOU
KINDA ILLUSTRATED MY POINT A
LITTLE BIT -- WHY ISN'T THE BILL
FOCUSED ON THE AN APPEALS
PROCESS WHY ISN'T THAT BECAUSE
SETTING UP A SEPARATE BILLING
SYSTEM TRUST ME BE CAREFUL WHAT
YOU WISH?
FOR IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT.
AND YOU MIGHT FIND THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY WORSE THAN WHAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH NOW BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO SPEND MONEY ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO TRY TO
BILL MEDICARE ON THESE
COMPLICATED CASES.
WE'VE HAD HEARINGS ON MENTAL
HEALTH -- THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
AND FROM THIS COMMITTEE AND
QUITE FRANKLY -- IT'S DIFFICULT
ME WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE
PAPERWORK AND TRY TO FIND WAYS
TO MAKE TO EXPEDITE SERVICES WE
HAD A BILL ABOUT THAT EARLIER
TODAY.
I DO I JUST THINK I THINK THE
BILLS AIMED AT THE WRONG PLACE
QUITE FRANKLY TO SET UP A
SEPARATE BILLING SYSTEM -- TO DO
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WHEN THE
PROBLEM APPEARS THAT THE THE THE
THE THE TO PETE THE TWO PARTIES
DON'T WANT TO DO THIS SO WHY
ISN'T THIS BILL FOCUSED.
ON A PROCESS AN APPEALS PROCESS
SO THAT THE TWO PARTIES CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHY WHY IS
THE FOCUS JUST SEEMS WRONG AND
SO THAT'S WHY CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL.
DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT.
I'M.
WE HAVE A TRIED IN IN PRIOR
VERSIONS OF THE BILL THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION OF APPEALS PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DIDN'T GO
FORWARD EITHER.
SO I YOU KNOW I I I I AGREE WITH
YOU AND I AGREE THAT THE BILLING
PROCESS IS A DIFFICULT THING IT
IT DIFFICULT IS IT WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTAND HUGE UNDERTAKING IT
WOULD IT WOULD AND I THINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY IS GOING TO
CAUGHT THE YOU'RE.
GOING TO FIND IT WOULD COST YOU
MORE -- THEN YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO COST I DON'T THINK
YOU'LL SOLVE THE PROBLEM YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE -- AND I JUST
I'M SYMPATHETIC I HAVE HUGE
ISSUES WITH THIS IN MY DISTRICT.
I HAVE I HAVE HUGE HUGE
CHALLENGES AND I GET IT I GET IT
BUT I THINK THE THE THE SOLUTION
IS ACTUALLY COOPERATION.
BETTER CORPORATION AND LIKE THE
BIKE I SAID THE BILL PROBABLY
SHOULD BE MANDATING AN APPEALS
PROCESS THAT'S FAIR FOR ALL.
RIGHT IN IN PART OF THE THE IF
YOU DON'T MIND ME RESPONDING NOT.
WHEN I WAS SENATOR BELL IN THE
AUDIT CAME FORWARD THERE WAS A --
AUDIT RECOMMENDATION THAT --
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BE MANDATED TO PARTNER
IN THESE SERVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY SENATOR BUILDING
GO FORWARD WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION HE LOOKED AT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TRY NOT TO
CREATE A MANDATE.
I MEAN WE'D BE WILLING TO GO
FORWARD WITH THE MANDATE BUT
WITH THAT KILL THE BILL IN THE
IN APPROPRIATIONS CAUSING A NEW
MANDATE -- IT HELPED THAT THINK
THE MANDATE IS ACTUALLY ASKING
THE TWO ENTITIES TO WORK
TOGETHER I SO I WOULD I JUST
HAPPY WITH THE MANDATE I JUST
DON'T I JUST DON'T BELIEVE AS
I'VE SAID I DON'T BELIEVE THIS
ACTUALLY SOLVES THE PROBLEM THE
WAY YOU'RE TRYING.
THE WAY YOU'RE LOOKING FOR I
THINK YOU'RE.
POTENTIALLY CREATING A MUCH
ANOTHER PROBLEM THAT'S OF A
DIFFERENT MAGNITUDE SO.
SO THAT'S MY POSITION AND THAT'S
WHY I'M NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY SO -- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION -- MY MISTER
FLORA SECOND BY MISTER MAZEN.
BELIEVE THE MOTION IS -- TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS -- WILL -- Là
MADAM SECRETARY CALLED COVER.
WHAT?
WOULD NOBODY'S MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AFTER CURRY NOT VOTING BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA -- I LOW MOAN.
NO NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAMOS NOW VOTING RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THOSE WITH THE BILL ON TOP
[inaudible]
MR
.
FOR YES THE SERGEANTS TO CALL
THEM IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS WAS START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THE CHAIR
IN THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
HERE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
LICENSE SUBSTANCE ABUSE RECOVERY
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO OFFER
AND PROVIDE SERVICES IN AN
OFFSITE OUTPATIENT FACILITY.
I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE SO
WE'LL JUST -- MAYBE TURN IT OVER
TO MY EXPERT WITNESSES WE HAVE
SURE DALY SENIOR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OF CORPORATE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA SORT OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS.
AND DR MEGHAN MARKHAM EXECUTIVE
CLINICAL DIRECTOR FOR A BETTER
LIFE RECOVERY.
THANK YOU I'LL MAKE IT QUICK
THIS BILL COMES FROM THE LAND OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ASSEMBLY BILL -- THIRTY ONE
SIXTY TWO BY SOME OF ONE
FRIEDMAN WAS PASSED LAST YEAR IT
REQUIRED SOME TRANSPARENCY SO
THAT IMPATIENT WOULD LIST ALL OF
THE PLACES WHERE ANY TYPE OF
TREATMENT WAS GOING ON AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT
FOUND IT UNABLE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED SO BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT PUT A CERTIFIED.
OUTPATIENT WHICH IS NOT LICENSED
ON A LICENSE SO WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO REPAIR THAT DAMAGE SO THAT --
INPATIENT WHO OFTEN WILL HAVE A
LIKE A SIX BED WITH.
WITH WOMEN AND ONE MIGHT HAVE
CHILDREN THAT SHE'S TRYING TO
UNITE WITH ONE MIGHT HAVE A
TRAUMA ISSUE ANOTHER ONE MIGHT
BE -- TRANS GENDER OR LESBIAN
AND THEY WOULD ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT MIGHT MEET
THEIR NEEDS NOW THEY'RE TRAPPED
WITHIN THEIR THE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES DUE TO THIS.
I'M TECHNICAL PROBLEM PLASTERS
BILL.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
HI MY NAME'S DOCTOR MAKE IN
MARKHAM A BOARD CERTIFIED
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I'M ALSO
JUST HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SAME NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF MISTER FLORA.
YOUR BILL ENJOYS A TO PASS AS
AMENDED WRECK OF RECOMMENDATION
APPROPRIATIONS AND YOU'VE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS.
THANKS YES WE ARE -- WHICH I TO
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL PRETTY GOOD -- WE NEED A
MOTION FOR STUFF I'M SORRY WE
GOT ONE NOW.
AND A SECOND OF AYE MISC MISSILE.
SO MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
A TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY I AGREE I
BIGELOW BONTA.
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO.
I FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. NINE YOUR BILL IS
OUT.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU --
ANOTHER MEMBERS MISS CAREER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLAY
.
SOMEBODY LEFT THEIR SUITCASE.
OKAY THIS TODAY [inaudible]
PARDON ME.
ARE MY EXPERT.
IN THE HOUSE.
MOVE THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY TALKING POINTS A GOOD
MORNING.
BUT GOOD EVENING.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB IS
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WHICH MAKES
IT NECESSARY.
REFORMS TO THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY WHEN A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP OF KURDS TO ADDRESS
ISSUES WITH TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THE
CONTINUED THE CONTINUITY OF CARE
FOR NURSING HOME RESIDENTS AS
WELL AS THE EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS. FOR WORKERS --
DURING THIS PROCESS I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING CERTIFYING AND
ENFORCING.
REGULATORY STANDARDS RELATED TO
THE QUALITY CARE PROVIDED IN
SKILLED NURSING HOME FACILITIES
AND OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF FORMS AND
DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE TO OPERATE A NURSING
HOME.
THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP APPROVAL
PROCESS MAY TAKE AT LEAST FOUR
MONTHS OR LONGER.
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT PRACTICES
CONTRIBUTE TO THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN NURSING HOME IN
THE STREET.
LEAVING RESIDENTS THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THE NURSING HOME STAFF
VULNERABLE TO ABRUPT CHANGES IN
OWNERSHIP IN OPERATIONS.
THAT NOT ONLY DISRUPT THE
QUALITY OF CARE BUT IT PUTS A
STRAIN ON CARE GIVERS WORKING
WORKING CONDITIONS.
AB A SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL DO
THE FOLLOWING THREE THINGS.
IT WOULD -- IT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT A LICENSEE NOTIFIED THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ALL RESIDENTS AND
REPRESENTATIVES NO LATER THAN
NINETY DAYS PRIOR TO THE SALE OF
TRANSFER.
IT WORK -- CLARIFY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTITIES THAT
ACT AS MANAGEMENT COMPANIES AND
IT WOULD REQUIRE A SIXTY DAY
RETENTION.
PERIOD OF STAFF WITH NO
REDUCTION IN WAGES TO ALLOW THE
RESIDENTS TO EXPERIENCE A
CONTINUITY OF CARE.
AND PREVENT DISRUPTIVE TURNOVERS
HERE WE NEED -- TO TESTIFIED
TODAY.
IS STOSSEL LAMPERT WITH SCO YOU
LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN AND CORY
BOOKER RUBIO CARPOOL.
HI A MEMBER OF A CA YOU TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND A NURSING HOME
WORKER FROM THE RICHMOND AREA.
PLEASE THANK YOU I THANK YOU SO
THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
RACHEL EFFORT -- AND SO.
NURSING HOMES OFTEN USE ARE
COMPLEX MANAGEMENT RELATIONSHIPS
THAT PARTITION OFFICERS ASPECTS
OF OPERATIONS ADMINISTRATION
LICENSURE AND OWNERSHIP AND
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO -- PRIOR
NOTICE OF ANY OF THESE CHANGES
REQUIRED TO BE SENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OR ANY OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS OR ANYONE WHO WOULD
BE.
AFFECTED BY THOSE CHANGES --
THESE LAYERED RELATIONSHIPS
INTRODUCED A LAPSE IN OVERSIGHT
WITH REGARDS TO WHO IS RUNNING
CALIFORNIA SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN
TIME -- IN THAT LEAVES SURVEYORS
WORKERS RESIDENTS CONSUMER
ADVOCATES UNION REPRESENTATIVES
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WONDERING.
WHO DO WE -- ENFORCE QUALITY
STANDARDS WITH -- WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR UPHOLDING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
WHICH OUR LAWS WHO WE CHARGE IS
RESPONSIBLE RESIDENTS WELL BEING
OR THE FAILURE TO ENSURE HIGH
QUALITY CARE. ONE OF THE LARGEST
NURSING HOME -- OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY IS
OPERATING -- EIGHTEEN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES -- THAT HE
SUBMITTED A CHILD FOR IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND THEY'VE BEEN PENDING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT EVER SINCE
THEN -- THE SAME YEAR THAT HE
SUBMITTED THOSE CHAO'S HE ALSO
HAD THREE HOMES SUFFERED
TERMINATIONS OF THEIR META
MEDICARE AND MEDICAL
CERTIFICATIONS AS WELL AS
LICENSE.
SUSPENSIONS FROM THE STATE --
AND HE'S ABLE TO OPERATE THOSE
FACILITIES USING THE PRIOR --
OWNERS LICENSE -- THROUGH AND
HE'S USING AN INTERIM MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENT WITH THE PRIOR OWNER.
ARE CURRENTLY WE ALSO HAVE
AWESOME MEMBERS IN FRESNO WHEN --
STOCKTON WHO UNDER THE SAME
OWNER -- ARE.
SUDDENLY GETTING NOTICED THAT
OWNERSHIP IS CHANGING OVER BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHO IS
GOING TO BE TAKING OVER THE
FACILITY -- NOTICE WAS REALLY
SIDE IN THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY
REALLY HEARD ABOUT IT WAS BEING
TOLD THAT THEIR PAYCHECKS WOULD
BOUNCE IF THEY TRIED TO CASH
THEM IN SO THEY SHOULD HOLD ON
TO THEM AND WAIT.
FOR A PAYCHECK THAT COME CAME IN
THAT WOULD BE GOOD AND SO THEY
ENDED UP GETTING PAID LATE AND
THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEIR NEXT
PAYCHECKS ARE GOING TO BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME SORT OF
INSTABILITY -- SO WITH THIS BILL
WERE ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS A LOT
OF KEY PROBLEMS THAT OUR MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN EXPERIENCING IN TERMS
OF INSTABILITY AND JUST THE LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY AROUND.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WHEN CHANGES OF
OWNERSHIP ARE HAPPENING AND SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT BY CODIFYING
SOME STABILITY AND WHATEVER
TRANSITION MAY TAKE PLACE WILL
ALLOW -- WORKERS TO PLAN AHEAD
HAVE SOME JOB SECURITY -- AND
HAVE RESIDENTS BE ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE CONTINUITY OF CARE
AND PLAN AHEAD FOR THEIR FUTURES
AS WELL WITH PERMANENT UP TO
DATE INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO
THEM REGARDING WHOSE CARE THE
RESIDING UNDER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
COREY BUCKLE RUBIO I'M CURRENTLY
IS CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT AT
THE NURSING HOME FACILITY
LOCATED IN SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN A CNA FOR TREES AND
I'M A PROBLEM MEMBER OF S. YEAH
YOU LOCAL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
FAILING TO PROTECT BOOK
RESIDENTS AND NURSING HOME
WORKERS WHEN IT FACILITIES BEING
SOLD TO A NO THOUGH PRE.
TO LAST YEAH WELL THE SEE AN
ACTIVE FACILITY IN HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WINTRY SUDDEN CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP WE BECAME AWARE OF THE
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP AFTER HE
DIED BALL DOWN DURING THE
TRANSITION PERIOD.
SO WE HAVE CUTS OF BETWEEN WHO
CARRIES OUT DO YOU DO YOU DO NEW
OWNER -- THE OLD OWNER BECAUSE
OF THE NEW TERMS AND CONDITIONS
THE NEW OWNERS WERE OFFERING.
THERE WAS A MASSIVE TURNOVER OF
STAFF WHO LEFT THE FACILITY.
IT WAS A FIFTY BED FACILITY AND
THE NEW OWNERS ARE TRYING TO
TURN IT INTO EIGHT SEVEN TWO ONE
BED FACILITY.
DURING THE TRANSITION I WOULD
WALK ON THE NIGHT SHIFT AND BE
THE ONLY SEE ANY ON THE FLOOR
FOR THE ENTIRE NINE FOR ALL
FIFTY BIDS.
OF COURSE THE REQUIRED LEVEL OF
CARE CANNOT BE GIVEN TO PATIENTS
UNDER SUCH CIRCUMSTANCES.
THERE WAS AN AGGRESSIVE INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF PATIENTS TO
FEEL THE SEVEN TWO ONE BIDS BED
THERE WAS NOT A COMMENSURATE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CDNAS
ANOTHER STUFF NEEDED.
SOME PROVIDING YOU LEVELS OF KID.
THIS RESULTED OF CODES IN THIS
WELCOME NOT BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE A LEVEL OF QUE WE WANT
AND WE KNOW WE A COUPLE OF GIVEN.
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOU ON
BEHALF OF NURSING HOME WORKERS
LIKE ME TO SUPPORT AB SIXTY
NINETY FIVE BECAUSE RESIDENTS IN
NURSING HOME WORKERS WHO ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS.
SHOULD BE PROTECTED AND DESERVE
STABILITY AND SMOOTH TRANSITION
WHEN A TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
SUPPORT.
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
CLOUDY ACCOUNTS AND I AM A CNA --
DOWN NURSING HOME FACILITY
EMPLOYS A COUNTY AND I'M A
MEMBER OF A CA YOU.
AND I SUPPORT THE SAW.
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES -- PERSON LIKE TO
START BY SAYING THAT WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT -- THE THE INTENT
AND MANY OF THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL THAT -- ESSAY YOU IN
THE AUTHOR WANT TO PUT FORWARD
AND WE'VE EXPRESSED THAT SUPPORT
TO THE AUTHOR STAFF AND TO THE
SPONSORS -- WE SUPPORT THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF PUTTING
SOME TYPE OF A TRANSPARENCY AND
CLARITY OF CRITERIA AND THEN.
THE ITEMS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING SURE THAT --
THAT THERE ARE RETENTION
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL A NUMBER
OF ITEMS IN THE BILL THAT AND I
THINK THE CORE ITEMS OF WHAT I
SEE ARE YOU WOULD LIKE AND I AM
THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE AND ART
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT A PROCESS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IT -- THE CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP PROCESS THAT WE FEEL
IS COMPLETELY BROKEN -- THE AND
NOW SAYS POINTS OUT THAT RIGHT
NOW THE AVERAGE TIME THAT IT
TAKES FOR AN OWNER TO CHANGE
OWNERSHIPS IS FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY TWO DAYS AND THAT'S THE
AVERAGE -- IT'S UNSPEAKABLE THAT
THAT ARE OWNERS THAT WANT TO
TAKE OVER FACILITY THAT ACTUALLY
ARE GOOD GOOD OWNERS AND WANT TO
DO THAT -- AREN'T ABLE TO DO
THAT IN A TIMELY PROCESS AND AND
WE BELIEVE THAT'S HONESTLY
REALLY.
THE LARGEST PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW -- AND SO
WEWOULD VERY MUCH LIKE AND WE
FED HAVE WE'VE EXPRESSES TO
SPONSORS WE EXPRESS IS THE
AUTHOR THAT WE VERY MUCH WANT TO
WORK WITH THEM.
AND TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE SOLVE
THIS BROKEN PROCESS WHEN WE HAVE
OWNERS THAT ARE WAITING -- UP TO
FOUR YEARS I MEAN THE FOLKS JUST
TESTIFIED TO THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE -- ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT'S
WAITING THREE YEARS IF IT'S A
KNOW IT NEEDS TO BE A NO QUICKLY --
SO THE CURRENT OWNERS CAN FIND
ANOTHER PERSON TO TAKE OVER THAT
FACILITY -- WE THINK THAT THE
PROCESS AND NEEDS TO BE FIXED
AND WE WOULD HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
DO THAT -- AS WE ALL KNOW WE WE
HAVE AN AGING POPULATION WE HAVE
A LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM THAT'S
THAT'S FRAGILE THAT NEEDS -- THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE OWNERS A
QUICKLY IF THERE'S A STRUGGLING
FACILITY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO STEP IN AND TAKE
OVER THOSE FACILITIES.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO ALL
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO FIND A A
SOLUTION -- TO REQUIRE CITY PH
TO COME UP WIH A GOOD
TRANSPARENT A DECISION MAKING
PROCESS THAT MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY IS -- INFORMED AND
AVAILABLE TO TAKE OVER OWNERSHIP --
WE NEED IT -- SO WE AT THIS
POINT ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL BUT AM VERY MUCH HOPE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OFTEN THE SPONSORS ON THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE TO ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL -- BUT WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON SOME
AMENDMENTS WE DO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH A NOTICE BEING
PROVIDED WE THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE LENGTH OF
TIME.
WE ALSO HAVE ONE MORE CONCERNED
WITH WE WOULD LIKE TO REYES AND
THAT IS WE THINK THE DEFINITION
OF MANAGING THE BILL IS BROADER
THAN IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE AND I
THINK IT WILL IMPACT.
SOME OF THE CONTRACTING
ARRANGEMENTS THAT MANY OF OUR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES -- GO
THROUGH TODAY SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS ON THE BILL GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- THE BILL WOULD
ENJOYS A TO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION -- WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK.
WITH THE SUPPORTERS IN
OPPOSITION TO COME.
TO AN AGREEMENT ON THIS BILL AND
WHAT WORKS.
BEST AS STATED WE DO HAVE AN AN
AGING POPULATION AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTED INCLUDING SOMEONE ON
ON THIS COMMITTEE WHO.
ARE TURNING OLDER EVERY DAY
[inaudible]
OUCH [inaudible]
THE BRIDGE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
HAVE A YOU SHOULD YOU SHOULD
AWAITED.
MEN SECRETARY THE THE THE
MEASURE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
[inaudible]
I WITH [inaudible]
MAYES NO.
MAYES NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND YOUR CURRY I BIGELOW
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
CARILLO HI.
I FLORA.
LOW.
LEVEL HI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA.
I WAS THERE AND I RAMOS.
REBEL SIDE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
MONTERO AYE WALDRON.
ENTER.
YOUR OLDER COLLEAGUES HAVE
APPROVED. ONE THANK YOU --
MISTER WE'RE GONNA LET MISTER
SANTIAGO TO GO NEXT WEEK -- IF I
IS -- IF HE'S READY.
OKAY I THINK YOU.
AND THEN MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR KNOWS
BILL LONG DAY -- BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL AND ALL OF THE
BRIEF THANK YOU.
SELECT SIX UP THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORKING YOU
COMMITTEE STAFF.
WHICH I IN IN SHORT AB TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD ESTABLISH OUT
REACH TEAMS TASK WITHOUT
REACHING FOR THE HOMELESS
POPULATION -- WITH A HISTORY OF
MENTAL ILLNESS ONE AND AND ABLE
TO ACCESS MEDICAL CARE THE BILL
WOULD ALSO APPROPRIATE SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION IMPROVE SERVICES
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS UNDER
CONSERVATIVE -- MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
HAVE WITNESSES WILL ALSO BE
BRIEF THANK YOU.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME'S MULLIN WHEN YOU'RE
LISTENING HERE TODAY AS A MEMBER
OF SEE I YOU LOCAL.
SEVEN TO TWENTY ONE I CURRENTLY
WORK FOR THE ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAM UNDER LAWRENCE
Là FOR LA COUNTY -- DOING OUR
REGION DETERMINE AND LINKAGE TO
RESOURCES -- FOR INDIVIDUALS FOR
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL.
ALMOST HALF OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT I WORK WITH ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
BECAUSE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS --
IN BECAUSE THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
SOMETIMES HARD TO LOCATE I WORK
ALONG SIDE -- HOMELESS I REACH
PROGRAMS WHO HELP FIND THESE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE STREET.
THESE HOMELESS ARE REACH
PROGRAMS HAVE ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION WILL MAKE THE WHICH
MAKES IT EASIER FOR THEM. TO
TRUST.
US ONCE WE ARE INTRODUCED BY
THEM. FOR EXAMPLE IN ONE CASE
THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS
REFERRED TO OUR PROGRAM.
IN WAS EXHIBITING PARANOID
SYMPTOMS WAS WILLING TO WORK
WITH OUR AOTI TEAM AFTER BEING
INTRODUCED BY HOMELESS ARE EACH
WORKER.
WHO HE HAD BEEN WORKING WITH FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS?
DUE TO THIS ESTABLISHED RAPPORT
WITH THE HOMELESS I REACH WORKER
THE INDIVIDUAL WAS MORE TRUSTING
OF OUR TEAM AND EVENTUALLY
ALLOWED US TO HELP HIM WITH
GETTING CONNECTED TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
INCLUDING GETTING PLACE IN A
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM.
IN OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN OUR
CLIENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
CONNECTED TO SERVICES
VOLUNTARILY WE'VE HAD. TO GO THE
PETITION ROUTE AND GET THE
MANDATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
HOWEVER IF THEY CONTINUE TO TO
COMPENSATE AND GET HOSPITALIZED
EVENTUALLY END UP GETTING
CONSERVE.
IN THE FOUR YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS PROGRAM I'VE HAD
TWO DIFFERENT CLIENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN CONSERVED ON TWO DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS.
ONE OF THESE CLIENTS WHAT'S
HOMELESS.
GOT CONSERVE AND BECAUSE HE GOT
BETTER IN THAT YEAR.
THE JUDGE DID NOT RENEW HIS
CONSERVATORSHIP HOWEVER SHORTLY
AFTER THE CONSERVATORSHIP WAS
TERMINATED HE WAS BACK TO LIVING
ON THE STREETS AND GETTING WORSE.
HE EVENTUALLY GOT REFERRED BACK
TO OUR PROGRAM HOSPITALIZED IN
CONCERT FOR A SECOND TIME WITHIN
LESS THAN A YEAR AFTER HIS FIRST
CONSERVATORSHIP HAD BEEN
TERMINATED.
BECAUSE OF THE WORK I DO I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT BOTH ELEMENTS OF
THIS BILL ARE. ONE THE NECESSITY
FOR AFFIRMATIVE OUT REACH TO
INDIVIDUALS WERE LIVING ON THE
STREETS. TO CONNECT THEM WITH
SERVICES AND RESOURCES INCLUDING
HOUSING.
AND TO THE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
LEGAL PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S OFFICE
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SERVICES I THE LAR LAS
RESORT FOR PUBLIC CONSERVATISM
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE MOST AT
RISK AND UNABLE TO HELP.
GET HELP VOLUNTARILY.
THIS BILL WOULD TARGET OUR REACH
TEAMS TO THOSE COUNTIES OF
GREATEST NEED AND AND WOULD HAVE
TO POPULATION STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
AS WELL AS THAT KNOWLEDGE TO
INCREASE IN CASE LOADS.
AT THE PUBLIC GUARDIAN'S OFFICE
AND MAKE SURE THAT.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE BEING
REFERRED FOR CONSERVATORSHIP ARE
ADEQUATE.
HE SERVED BY THE SYSTEM.
I CONTINUE TO SEE FIRSTHAND HOW
BOTH ASSERTIVE.
OUT REACH AND CONSERVATORSHIP
WHEN APPROPRIATE CAN HELP SAVE
LIVES BY CONNECTING PEOPLE WITH
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
SERVICES.
NOT ON MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUALS
IN CRISIS [inaudible]
UP.
SO IT IS IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT THE THE I. YOU IS PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TO BELT OUT
OUR STATE'S RESPONSE THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BY INVESTING
MORE.
IN HOMELESS OUR REGION PUBLIC
GUARDIANS THANK YOU.
MICHELLE CABINET WITH A CA YOU
CALIFORNIA AND WE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MISSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SONORA BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
WOULD GO I'M SORRY MR MCCARTY.
I THANK YOU THAT MR SUBJECT I
KNOW YOU WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
LAST YEAR AND A BIT MORE BOLD --
THE PROPOSAL.
AND DIDN'T QUITE GET AS FAR AS
YOU WANT TO GO -- LAST YEAR BUT
THIS IS THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND RIGHT OUT
HERE ON THE STREETS SACRAMENTO
SO -- YOU KNOW PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
KEEP AT IT THE OF THE RECEPTOR
AMENDMENTS CORRECT YES OKAY
THANK YOU JUST DOUBLE CHECKING --
THE THERE IS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO THE MOTION BE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH I TO CLOSE.
SURE THANK YOU AND JOSE BRIEFLY
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BUILT -- TO ME.
PART OF IT -- WHAT WAS THE FACT
THAT WHEN WE LEARNED A LOT IN
THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO DO LAST
YEAR AND THERE WAS SOME HOLES IN
OUR ARGUMENTS AND?
AT THE END -- WE FELT WE COULD
GO TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT WE
FELT TO TABLE IT IN INSTEAD DO A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME AND IDENTIFY A BETTER
WAY -- TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT WE WANTED TO TAKING
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET.
AND GIVEN THE CARE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY NEED THIS IS A MUCH
BETTER WAY I THINK -- SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOBLE BUT
LET'S LEAVE PROCESS WORKED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT A
MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GOT CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I FLORA.
LIMóN.
<c.cyan>WI THE LOAN I MCCARTY.</c>
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO.
TERRIBLE I AND WALDRON.
WE HAVE TWELVE VOTES YOUR BILL
IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
THE BILL.
EXCEPT IN THE COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE HELP ON AS
WELL.
AB TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT REQUIRE
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS AND
INSURERS. TO REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
OR DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
APPROVAL AND DENIAL RATES. FOR
THE THIRTY MOST YOU'D LIKE
SERVICES AND TREATMENTS THAT
REQUIRE A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM A PROVIDER.
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS AND
INSURERS REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR MANY TREATMENT
OPTIONS INCLUDING TEST THEIR
PRES REFERRALS AND SURGERIES.
I'M NOT OF TIME SECOND.
IT TAKES LARGER PROCESS THESE
REQUEST CAN YOU CORD DAY'S WORK
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL IS
BRAND MCCARTY.
HI GOOD EVENING -- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDON
MARCHING WITH CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION -- SPONSORING -- AT
AB TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT ON I WANT
TO THANK SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF -- FOR HELPING OUT WITH
THE BILL AS WELL AND THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS -- THE DATA
THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED WILL HELP
INFORM STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND BEGINNING TO
TAKE PLACE.
ON A STATE LEVEL TO STREAMLINE
THE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION PROCESS.
INTO ANY EIGHTEEN AN AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SURVEY FOUND
THAT 91% OF PATIENTS WHOSE
TREATMENT REQUIRES A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION EXPERIENCE DELAYS
AND TREATMENT.
AND 20% OF THOSE EXPERIENCED
SERIOUS ADVERSE EVENTS DUE TO
THOSE DELAYS.
AT NEARLY TWO ACTUALLY MADE THIS
BILL IS A NEEDED STEP WHICH WILL
ENSURE ANY DECISION MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PRIORITIZATION
PROCESS DOWN THE LINE IS DATA
DRIVEN AND EFFECTIVE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB.
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
OTHERS A SUPPORT I'M SORRY.
I'D IMAGINE REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF PLASTIC SURGEONS AND
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
ALL IN SUPPORT.
THE KIDS.
STEVEN SCHULTZ ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GARY COOPER REPRESENTING CALDERA
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF P.
A.'S IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE WHAT IT OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NICKEL RESOURCE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
WHEN WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT
WE DO APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE?
BEING PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS --
IN AN EFFORT TO LIMIT THE BILL
BUT REGRETTABLY -- WE STILL
MAINTAIN OUR OPPOSE POSITION --
MEMBERS THE THIS BILL IS --
ANOTHER IN A LONG LIST OF NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS ON
PLANS IT OF INTERNET USE THIS
YEAR AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WILL DO LITTLE TO PROMOTE ACCESS
TO COVERAGE OR IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY.
ON IT IS A HEALTH PLANS --
MISSION IF YOU WILL TO ENSURE
THAT ENROLLEES ARE BEING
DELIVERED THE RIGHT CARE AT THE
RIGHT TIME FROM THE RIGHT
PROVIDER.
IN A WORLD OF FINITE RESOURCES
PREMIUM DOLLARS MUST BE INVESTED
ACCORDINGLY.
MEDICAL IN UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT TOOLS ARE VITAL TO
PROMOTING SAFE EFFECTIVE IN
SMART HEALTH CARE OF FOR A PLAN
ENROLLEES.
NO EXISTING LAW AND PRACTICE
DOES PROVIDED BUNDY PROTECTION
FOR CONSUMERS CURRENTLY -- IN
DEVELOPING THESE POLICIES PLANS
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS USE THE
LATEST DATA IT HEARINGS TO
MEDICAL -- BASED EVIDENCE
INFORMATION ON SAFETY CONCERNS
AND OTHER RELEVANT FACTORS TO
DETERMINE WHAT SERVICES WILL BE
SUBJECT TO AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS AND THE LIKE -- NOT
ONLY ARE POLICIES WILL VETTED
BASED ON THE LITERATURE IN
UPDATED FREQUENTLY PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THESE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND MANY
OF THE SIMILAR TOOLS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
DIRECTOR FOR REVIEW AND APPROVAL.
AND THESE ARE TO BE DISCLOSED
PROVIDERS ENROLLEES UPON REQUEST.
AUTHORIZATION IS ALSO REQUIRED
TO BE COMPLETED IN A TIMELY
MANNER -- AND PLANS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE FULL GRIEVANCE AN
APPEALS RIGHTS -- WHEN A OUR
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION -- OR OTHER
DETERMINATION -- HE'S HE'S HE'S
CHALLENGED -- IN ANALYZING THIS
BILL OF US WE ASKED WHETHER THE
NEW ADMINISTRATIVE IN PAPERWORK
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRED UNDER AB
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT ADD ANY VALUE
TO THE CURRENT PROCESS.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
ANSWER'S NO -- THE STORY THAT'S
GOING TO BE TOLD BY THIS DATA
WILL BE INCONCLUSIVE AT BEST.
ON BECAUSE IT DOES NOT CAPTURE
THE NATURE OF THE PROCESS AND
WILL BE AN ACCURATE.
NOR DOES THE BILL CONTAIN ANY
LEVEL OF SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
ON THE PART OF THE PROVIDER.
FIRST THE BILL DOESN'T CAPTURE
ANY INFORMATION THAT WOULD
INDICATE TO DENY OR DELAY THAT
WAS BASED UPON THE PROVIDER
FEELING TO PROVIDE THE PLAN WITH
THE ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO
AUTHORIZE THE CARE.
I MEAN FOR MY PLANTS PERSPECTIVE
THIS HAPPENS -- DURING THE
PROCESS.
IN MANY OCCASIONS -- IN ADDITION
THERE'S NO ACCOMMODATION FOR THE
DELEGATED NATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE MODEL.
WHERE HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT OF THOSE
SERVICES -- CAN BE DIRECTLY
MANAGED BY PROVIDER GROUPS VIA
CONTRACT.
THUS A PLAN IS GONNA HAVE TO
SURVEY ITS PROVIDER GROUPS FOR
THE INFORMATION REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL IN THE RATE OF RESPONSE BY
THOSE PROVIDERS GONNA DICTATE
WHETHER THE HEALTH PLAN CAN.
PERFORM AN ACCURATE --
INCOMPLETE SURVEY -- NO HEALTH
PLAN DATA REQUESTS ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY POPULAR AMONG OUR
PROVIDERS IN PROVIDER GROUPS.
ON AND PROVIDE A RESPONSIVENESS
HAS BEEN A PROBLEM IN PAST
EXPERIENCES WHEN ATTEMPTING TO
COMPLY WITH REPORTING MANDATES
THAT HAVE BEEN -- ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE BEST EXAMPLE
OF THIS IS THE INFORMATION
THAT'S REQUIRED TO BE COLLECTED
RIVER RELATED TO PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES -- AND IN
RECOGNITION OF THIS PROBLEM
PRIOR LEGISLATION RELATED TO
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES ALLOWS
PLANS TO DELAY PAYMENT TO
PROVIDER GROUP.
IF THERE IS A FOR FAILURE TO
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION NEEDED
TO COMPLETE THOSE DIRECTORIES.
IN THIS BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE
THAT -- SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
COMPONENTS SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
SEVENTY WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES I
WON'T -- REPEAT WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE BROUGHT IT BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT AND THE
ANALYSIS DID A WONDERFUL JOB OF
KIND OF SPELLING OUT.
SOME OF THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THROUGH A HIP OR NATIONAL TRADE
AND THROUGH THE AN AC. TO COME
UP WITH A WORK GROUP THERE
WORKING WITH PHYSICIANS
HOSPITALS PROVIDER GROUPS TO
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
HOW TO HOW TO BETTER BRING
ACCESS AND QUALITY CARE TO
INDIVIDUALS AND DO IN A FASTER
MORE PRODUCTIVE WAY AND WE THINK
THAT THAT MIGHT BE A BETTER WAY
TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE VERSES?
DOING SOMETHING ON THE STATE
LEVEL AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
THE INFORMATION IF YOU'RE NOT
LOOKING AT THE RATIONALE FOR WHY
SOMETHING WAS DENIED OR MODIFIED
YOU'RE NOT REALLY GOING TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL SCOPE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN THE
PROVIDER SYSTEM.
AND UNLESS YOU MAKE SHE'S GONNA
DO YOUR CD I IS GOING TO DO THAT
REAL HOLISTIC EVALUATION WE
THINK THIS IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE VALUE BASE TO THE
CONSUMER.
SO WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS WE THINK WE SHOULD LOOK
TO A HIP IS A NATIONAL TRADE AND
IS A LEADER IN THIS AREA AS WELL
AS AN AC.
AND SEE IF WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH.
NOT ONLY A STATE BUT A NATIONAL
MODEL IN ORDER TO HELP
PHYSICIANS AND CONSUMERS AND
PLANTS MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO CARE.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEN KNOWN BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
QUESTION BECAUSE I I GUESS I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ONE MAKE A
COMMENT I THINK I THINK WHAT.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
YOU KNOW FROM THE SPONSORS.
IS IS A FRUSTRATION OVER THE
NILES FOR CERTAIN.
ABOUT OF AT CERTAIN PROCEDURES
AND AND SO -- IN THE ABSENCE OF
OF THE DATA IT'S DIFFICULT. TO
TO TO BE ABLE TO GET A HANDLE ON
ON ON IS THAT A PERVASIVE
PROBLEM OR IS AT ANECDOTAL.
VOTE BY BY PROVIDER -- AND IF
THERE IS A DENIAL OF CARE WHEN
THERE SHOULD BE -- SHOULD BE
APPROVED -- THEN THEN MAYBE
THERE'S A MISCOMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE PLAN AND THE AND THE
PROVIDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
SO SO I'M KIND OF A BELIEVER.
ACTUALLY NOT I'M KIND OF I AM A
FIRM BELIEVER IN DATA AND I
THINK THAT SO I THINK THE
PURPOSE OF THIS IS IS TO TRY TO
FIND HIS IS JUST ANECDOTAL OR IS
THIS A REAL PROBLEM AND IN THIS
AREA AND IF IT IS.
HOW DO WE GET THE PARTIES
TOGETHER TO GET MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM
GETTING CARE?
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED.
TO BECAUSE OF THE
MISCOMMUNICATION OR OR WHATEVER.
SO I UNDERSTAND IT'S I
UNDERSTAND.
BOTH SIDES OF THIS AND I I KNOW
THAT THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WORKING THROUGH.
AS WE GO FORWARD ON THIS -- THE
BILL DOES ENJOY -- A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MISTER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE.
HE DID ACCEPT THE MINUTES SO ARE
THE BILL AS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS -- MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHEN I WHEN I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
CARILLO I GREW AYE FLORA
[inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON ONLINE MCCARTY.
PARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROSS FROM US I
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
SO THAT HAS TWELVE VOTE YOUR
BILL GOES OUT ON THE ROLE OF
OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON MR BONTA
LAST BUT NOT LEAST
.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
TODAY THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL THAT WOULD EXTEND THE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
SOMEONE IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS CAN RECEIVE TREATMENT AT
A CRISIS STABILIZATION UNIT
INSTEAD OF PREMATURELY CUTTING
OFF SERVICE BECAUSE OF AN
ARBITRARY TWENTY FOUR HOUR.
LIMIT I RESPCTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS.
BARBARA JONES FROM TENET HEALTH.
GETTING TURN MEMBERS I WILL MAKE
THIS BRIEF -- MY NAME IS BARBARA
JONES I'M WITH TEN AND HEALTH
CARE -- TENANT OWNS AND OPERATES
THIRTEEN HOSPITALS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
A SIXTY SEVEN BAD INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC UNIT -- TEN IT ALSO
PROVIDES A DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF MEDI CAL -- SERVICES AS
WELL AS SERVICES TO THE UNDER
INSURED AND UNINSURED.
ACROSS THE STATE WERE STRUGGLING
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PATIENTS AND CRISES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS FRACTURED AND THE
RIGIDITY OF THE LAW PUTS US IN A
POSITION OF TRADING OFF ONE
COMPLIANCE ISSUE FOR ANOTHER.
OUTPATIENT SERVICES ARE
RESTRICTED TO TWENTY FOUR HOURS
SO TWENTY FOUR HOURS WILL COME
AND GO AND WE ARE WITHOUT A
PLACEMENT FOR A PATIENT AND
POSSIBLY NOT HAVING RESOLVED
THEIR CRISES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED MORE
FACILITIES WE NEED MORE TOOLS
FOR PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS IN THE STATE AND THAT
TAKES TIME AND MONEY.
THIS BILL MAY NOT SOLVE ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS BUT BY PERMITTING
THE CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS
TO FLEX THEIR TIME BEYOND TWENTY
FOUR HOURS WE'RE REMOVING SOME
OF THE PRESSURE.
AND IMMEDIATELY THAT MIGHT BE
THE BEST THAT WE CAN HOPE.
FOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IMAGE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS THE CHAOS HERE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY SPORT.
THANK YOU.
SIR ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT ANYONE
OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS OUT SOUTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ASSOCIATION IS
VERY BRIEFLY WE HAD AN OPPOSE
UNLESS EMINENT POSITION SOME
CONCERNS AROUND PATIENT SAFETY
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN COMMITTEE.
BRING US A LONG WAY TOWARDS
WHERE WE WANT TO GO WE CERTAINLY
SHARE THE GOAL OF GETTING
PATIENTS ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
I THINK WE CAN GET THERE.
WITH THIS BILL SO HOPING TO GO
NEUTRAL IN THE LITTLE TIME TO
RECEIVE IMMENSE IF NOT SUPPORT
AT SOME POINT.
ANY ANY HAVE ANYONE ELSE THERE
ANY COMMENTSOR QUESTIONS FROM
THE DESK OF MISTER RAMOS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU TO YOU OFFER THOSE BRING IN
A CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS. TO
THE FOR FROM THE DISCUSSION --
IN SEMINOLE COUNTY WE WORK
FORWARD ON ON CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS -- TO SHOW
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE EMERGENCY ROOM --
OVERCROWDING AS WELL AS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO TO COUNTY
JAILS FOR THOSE THAT ARE
SUFFERING FROM CERTAIN MENTAL
MENTAL -- EPISODES OVER THERE SO
THE CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS --
SERVE THAT PURPOSE AND BEING
ABLE TO THEN GET SOMEBODY
STABILIZED -- TO WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE -- IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
DIALOGUE AROUND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION THIS IS.
AN AREA THAT I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT SO -- I LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE THE BILL DOES -- YOU
HAVE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS I
HAVE THANKS I'D SAY THAT A TOP
AND WANT TO CLARIFY THAT I DO.
YES SIR YES SO -- THANK YOU I
THINK IT'S I CAN'T REMEMBER IF
YOU DID OR YOU DIDN'T -- SO --
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
WHICH LIKE TO CROSS ASPECTS WE
ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA --
SECRETARY.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER
RAMOS -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT AS A YES WHAT I?
MAYES.
NOT VOTING MEANS NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY I AGREE I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
HI BUT I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FOR I LEVEL.
LEVINE I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZRODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WE HAVE TWELVE OF TWELVE VOTES
YOUR BILL IS OUT -- WILL LEAVE
THE DOOR OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STUFF.
OKAY SO -- WHAT WILL WE?
WERE ONLY GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE BILL'S ONE TIME SO WE NEED
TO HAVE WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR A
MOMENT FOR MISS WALDRON TO COME.
THE MEANTIME.
WE HAVE A BIRTHDAY TO CELEBRATE.
OUR VICE CHAIR.
MR MAYS I THINK -- THE FOR DAY
[inaudible]
HAVE --
AND THAT AGING
POPULATION.
WELL SOME OF LEFT WILL HAVE
SOMEBODY HELP WITH CANADA.
CLEARLY THERE'S NO BLOOD SUGAR
APPEARS SO WE NEED TO HAVE
SOMEONE CUT THAT OUT.
SO WE CAN BEGIN IN JUST A SECOND --
PATTY WILL BE RIGHT BACK WHEELS
WILL START GOING THROUGH THIS SO
WE CAN ONLY GOES WILL HAVE TO GO
TO THIS ONE TIME.
SO.
HANG TIGHT JUST ONE MINUTE.
HIS BACK.
THAT WE'RE ALL HERE WE JUST NEED
WE CAN'T DO THIS WITHOUT PATTY.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
THESE.
TO OKAY WE DON'T HAVE A POOR MAN
YOU HAVE A GOOD CONSENT.
IS THE FOURTEENTH GREEN PASSED
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR
WITH.
A BUNCH OF BILLS ON IT -- I CAN --
IT'S AB FORTY THREE AB TWO
THIRTY TWO A. B. TWO FIFTY FOUR
AB.
FIVE FIFTEEN AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AB SEVEN FORTY SIX
AB.
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT AB NINE
NINETEEN SB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE A. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AB TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN A. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO A B. FORTINO
FOR AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN AND AB
EIGHTEEN OH TWO BY THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND AB EIGHTEEN OH
THREE BY THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND WE'VE GOT LIKE. THIRTEEN
AUTHORS.
AND I MISTER SEVEN FOUR OKAY AND
AB SEVEN FOUR ONE I WAS ALSO ON
CONSENT -- SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
A MOTION -- MOTION BY MISS BURKE.
AND A CHORUS OF SECONDS.
MISTER MESS.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHEN I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GOT CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
I FLORA LARA AYE LIMóN.
LOAN AYE MCCARTY.
I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WATER HIGH.
FIFTIES HAS.
FIFTEEN ZERO SO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHT BY MISTER --
TO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
GULP LIFT THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
BONTA BONTA AYE FLORA OF FLORIDA
VOTING LIMóN [inaudible]
LOAN I THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE
[inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WATER NOW. TEN ONE THAT'S TEN TO
ONE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SYSTEM TO ONE EXCUSE ME --
ITEM NUMBER -- THREE AB FIFTY BY
MISTER KALRA PLEASE A LIFT THE
CALL OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
I BIGELOW AYE BONTA AYE BONTA
AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA FLORA AYE LEVEL.
LEMONT HIGH IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN EYEING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
ONE SIXTY SIX BY MR GABRIEL
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING I'M SORRY
YOUR HONOR BONTA.
BONTA I LIMON.
LEVINE AYE THIS AREA.
THE ONES IS THIS YES HI.
THEY'RE I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WATER NO.
12-1 THAT IS TWELVE TO ONE THAT
PASSES.
TWELVE TO ONE ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN A. B. TWO FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE LIST THE KHôNG CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
MAYES.
HI THIS TO FIFTY TO FIFTY EIGHT
JONES SAWYER [inaudible] FIVE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGAR
CURRY AYE BONTA.
AYE BONTA AYE LEVEL.
LOAN AYE MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE. FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO I REMEMBER EIGHT
WAS PULLED UP BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER -- NINE MISTER SOLACE --
PLEASE LET THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
HI.
MAYES AYE ANGER CURRY.
I BONTA.
BONSAI FLORA FLORA I LEVEL.
THE MODE AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
WALDRON.
ORDER NOW.
A MODERN AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
TEN TENNIS TENS AND TENS SENATOR
MODEL CONSENT A NUMBER ELEVEN AB
FIVE SIXTY THREE PLEASE LET THE
CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE.
BURKE I FLORA FLORA AYE LIMóN.
LOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER TEN A.
B. -- FIVE NINETY EIGHT IN
SEARCH OF A MOTION.
IT'S NOT TWELVE I'M SORRY NUMBER
TWELVE SEES ME I REMEMBER TWELVE
A. B. -- FIVE NINETY EIGHT
MISTER BLOOM IN SEARCH OF MOTION
AHEAD OF I DID HEAR MOTION BY
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THE SECOND BY MISTER FLORA. TO
DO PASSED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES THINGS
AYE ANGER CURRY I FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
LOAN AYE MCCARTY.
THE I. IN THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I RAMOS.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT MISTER
BLOOM.
FROM US I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER --
FIFTEEN AB SIX FIFTY ONE BY MR
GRAYSON.
FROM AND SECRETARY PLEASE LIFT
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WITH A CALL EXCUSE ME.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGER CURRY.
I GET CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ON LOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA NAZARIAN
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WELL -- NINE FIFTEEN AS FIFTEEN
ZERO PART OF APEC ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX FIFTY SIX
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAY.
OTHER.
MAYES MEMORY AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGAR CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING LIMóN.
LOW MOAN I MISS AREA NAZARIAN
AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING. ELEVEN ZERO
THAT'S ELEVEN DESERVE **** ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE NINE BY MISTER DEEP.
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS HELLO.
BIGELOW I BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ALONE.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
IS THERE AN ICE SANTIAGO SANTO
AYE WALDRON.
OLDER.
NINE FIFTEEN ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I BONTA BONTA AYE FLORA.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY.
FLORIDA VOTING OUT NAZARIAN
TELEHEALTH.
WE'RE GOOD SO.
AND IS THERE AN I SANTIAGO.
THE RESULT.
OF THIS OR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU BYE [inaudible]
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY ONE AB SEVEN
SIXTY THREE MISTER GRAY PLEASE --
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
FLORA.
FLORA I'LL AMONG.
THE MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON.
NINE FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER -- TWENTY THREE
A. B. SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WICKS
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE OR LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES.
IT'S NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING LEMOND.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO.
LOGIN.
TO THAT'S ELEVEN TO TO THE PET
BILL PASSES.
ELEVEN TO TWO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES.
YES MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BONTA AYE
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FOR I LEVEL.
THE MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE. FIFTEEN AS FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN MISTER
KALRA PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA AYE BONTA AYE
BURKE.
BURKE AYE FLORA FLORA EILEMA
[inaudible]
LIMóN I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON NO. FOURTEEN THAT'S
FOURTEEN TO ONE ITEM NUMBER --
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
Là M<c.cyan> NOT VOTING MCCARTY.</c>
MCCARTY AYE.
THIS AREA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
HAS -- THIRTEEN ZERO THAT PASSES.
THIRTEEN ZERO AB TEN THAT NUMBER
TWENTY NINE A. B. TEN SIXTEEN
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN PLEASE -- TEN
SIXTEEN LOW CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA FLORA EILEMA.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
THIS VERY NIGHT FIFTEEN AS
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY MR SALAS
PLEASE LIFT THE THE THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
I AGREE I BONTA BONTA AYE FLORA
FLOOR I LEVEL.
ALONE I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY INEZ AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO HAS FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY MR O'DONNELL
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO I LEVEL.
THE LOAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NINE FIFTEEN ZERO AS
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
SIX A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY ONE BY
MISTER CALDERON -- LOOKING FOR A
MOTION.
I MISSED MOTION BY MISTER MAYES
A SECOND BY MISTER FLORA.
I CAN DO THAT IF YOU'D LIKE.
ALL RIGHT THIS WE'RE GONNA STOP
FOR A SECOND.
WE'RE GONNA STOP.
MISTER CALDERON IS BILL HE GOT
SOME MARKET MUSIC [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
THAT'S ALL HE GETS.
HE'S NOT HERE.
ANYWAY.
YEAH WHERE WE WE HAVE A THE
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND
BY MISTER FLORA THE MODE THE THE
TO PASS SOME ENTERED I'M SORRY.
WE NEED TO SING OR SOMETHING --
MESSER TRIPLY CALL THE ROLL WHAT
HI WHEN I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLOOR I LEVEL.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
IS THERE AND I RAMOS.
BRELO'S AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WATER NINE
FIFTEEN ZERO AS THE TWO ZERO FOR
THE RECORD OF ANY ANY MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE WANTS WALK AT
MUSIC COULD JUST TELL ME WHAT
YOU'RE.
TELL ME WHAT YOUR REQUEST WILL
BE ABLE.
TO DO.
I'LL TRY TO GET IN TROUBLE FOR
THIS.
SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE IS GOING TO
PUT ME IN TROUBLE TOO LATE TODAY
BUT YOU KNOW I'M SORRY.
OKAY.
WE CAN'T DO THAT ON THE FLOOR
UNFORTUNATELY.
ALL RIGHT -- ENOUGH OF THAT --
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE --
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW.
HELLO I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE.
AYE IN THIS AREA [inaudible]
YES.
NAZARIAN II RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN THROUGH.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO THAT PASSES --
A. B. TWELVE FORTY NINE MISS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE BY
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAMES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
LEBRON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
PARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
IS THERE ANY.
NINE FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY AB TWELVE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BURKE.
BURKE I FLORA FLORA AYE.
WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING. FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN ZERO I'M SORRY.
1-321-308-1313 -- ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY ONE A. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE MISTER SANTIAGO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE. FIVE BURKE
AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE WALDRON.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE MISTER
SANTIAGO. TWELVE SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO OH SEVENTY FIVE WALDRON AYE
FIFTEENS.
AS FIFTEEN ZERO I DON'T NUMBER
FORTY FOUR EIGHTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY MISTER TO PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAMES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
I MON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO. ELEVEN THIRTY THREE
THAT'S ELEVEN THE BILL PASSES.
ELEVEN TO THREE I DON'T NUMBER
FORTY FIVE A. B. FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX BY MR KILEY PLEASE LET THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW.
HELLO I BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE
[inaudible]
VOTING [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
HI NAZARIAN AYE [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ THE VOTING SANTIAGO.
WHATEVER NOT VOTING. EIGHT TO
ONE DID YOU WERE NOT HERE WITH
ME I DO NOT LOADING LOADING
[inaudible]
SORRY SORRY.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX WAS COMING.
I AM VERY NUMBER.
THAT'S CORRECT NOT LOADING IS
CORRECT.
ANY EVERYBODY BEFORE WE CALL IT
ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY IT IS PASSES.
EIGHT TO ONE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THE I KNOW WE'VE DONE NO
NO NO.
WE'RE NEVER GONNA BE DONE THIS
IS THE HOTEL CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANKS MONIQUE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT PAGE WERE ON
BUT WE ARE ON THE PAGE. FORTY
FOR ALMOST DIRECTLY DO PRETTY
GOOD YEAH WE'RE DOING GOOD -- A.
B. ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY BY MR BONTA --
JUST ACTUALLY IS IT WITHOUT.
US IT WAS WE GOT A MALL.
NO WE DIDN'T BUT EVERYBODY VOTED
NO [inaudible]
BUT THEY WERE AT OKAY LET'S OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. FOURTEEN ZERO OKAY
FOR TEENS -- ITEM AND THAT
PASSES FOR TEENS -- ITEM NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN ELEVEN
BY MISTER -- TO PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
LEBRON.
LIVE ON AYE THIS AREA.
IS THERE AN AYE SANTIAGO.
CENTER -- I WALDRON.
WATER NOT VOTING.
IT IS.
ZERO AT ELEVEN ZERO TOLL PASSES
ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT AB
SIXTEEN NINETEEN BY MISS WEBBER
PLEASE -- LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WHAT I WHAT I
AGUIAR-CURRY.
I GET THIS FIGURE OCCURRING
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
APPARENTLY NOT.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE BONTA BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO ISLA.
LOW MOAN AYE NAZARIAN.
LARA NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS ROLLS
EYES SANTIAGO.
CENTER. FIFTEEN AT FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT BE
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN -- PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
MAYES.
VOTING MAYES NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I LIMóN.
LEVINE AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
WELL WE'RE NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
LOW.
THAT'S ELEVEN PASSES ELEVEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE A. B. --
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE --
MISS CARILLO PLEASE -- OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BURKE.
BURKE I FLORA.
OR NOT VOTING.
WALDRON [inaudible]
ORDER NOW. 1-123-2 LET PASSES.
ELEVEN TO THREE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY TWO AB SEVENTEEN OH NINE
BY MISTER JONES SAWYER PLEASE
LIST THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. FIVE I
GET VERY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMóN.
THE ONE I MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON HIGH FIFTEEN THAT'S
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NO AND THAT
PASSES FIFTEENS OR EXCUSE ME
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE BY MISTER
CELIS PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES BY MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
HAGER KERR AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE FLORA.
FLORA LIMóN.
THE ONE I MCCARTY.
THE AYE NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AND I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
FIFTEEN THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY NINE BY MISTER FRAZIER
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WHAT.
I WOULD I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE [inaudible]
I LIMóN.
THE LOAN I IN THIS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I RAMOS FROM A
SIZE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FOURTEEN ZERO AS
FOURTEEN ZERO AND ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY SIX AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
NINE BY MR DAILY PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA I BURKE BURKE HI Là M<c.cyan>.</c>
WHEN I MCCARTY?
IS THAT MCCARTY I NECESSARY.
THE VERY AND I RAMOS RAMOS I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI FIFTEENTH.
AS FIFTEEN ZERO PASSES.
HANG ON ONE SEC [inaudible]
SIXTEEN WHAT MEMBERS
[inaudible] SIXTEEN WE DID A
CONCERT [inaudible]
YES. TWENTY THREE WAS.
NUMBER TWENTY THREE WAS AB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY MISS WICKS
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
WE'RE DONE [inaudible]
YES.
YEAH YOU CAN OF COURSE YEAH OF
COURSE.
YES.
SO OF VOTE CHANGE.
OKAY [inaudible] FORTY ITEM
NUMBER FOR MISS WALDRON ITEM
NUMBER FORTY A. B..
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT I'M NOT
VOTING TO HIGH.
WALDRON HIGH MAKES IT --
FOURTEEN ZERO YES FOURTEENTH.
OKAY. TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
ADAM [inaudible] FORTY SECOND.
AND EVERYBODY'S ON THE WHOLE.
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND JUST PUSH.
OKAY -- ITEM NUMBER. FOUR FORTY
AB TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ -- MISTER BIGELOW
CHANGES FROM NOT VOTING TO AYE
BIGELOW AYE. FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE I HAVE IS A